PLEASE JOIN US SO GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE WILL GET STARTED.
AS A SUB COMMITTEE FOR THE WATER
PARKS AND WILDLIFE COMMITTEE
IT'S TUESDAY JUNE TWENTY SIXTH.
LIKE TO DESCRIBE READ THE
STATEMENT AS IT RELATES TO OUR
AGENDA TODAY --
IS OUR LAST THEIR REGULAR
SCHEDULED A BILL HEARING FOR THE
YEAR.
ALEX THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
EFFORT THAT YOU PUT INTO THIS
COMMITTEE.
AND YOUR THOUGHTFUL
CONSIDERATION OF THE BILL'S
MOVING FORWARD WE HAVE SIXTEEN
BILLS.
ON THE AGENDA TODAY WHAT SEVEN
CONSENT CALENDAR THE CONSENT
ITEMS ARE S. B..
EIGHT EIGHTY ONE S. B..
NINE FIFTY FIVE S. B. TEN
SEVENTY THREE S. B. ELEVEN
TWENTY SIX S. B..
THIRTEEN TEN ME THIRTEEN ELEVEN
AND S. B.. FOURTEEN NINETY THREE
DOES ANY MEMBER WAS TO REMOVE
ANY ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IT'S TIME.
WE WILL LA I HAVE TO WAIT TO
HAVE QUORUM TO BE ABLE TO DO
THAT AND WRAPPED ALL BREEDS --
STATE THE QUESTION WHEN AND ONCE
HERE.
IN ADDITION TO OUR AUTHORS WE
WILL WELCOME OUT TO SUPPORTERS
INTO OPPOSITION ALONG WITH.
ME TO USE FOR EACH OF THE BILLS
WITH THAT WE WELCOME OUR FIRST
AYE PRESENTER CENTER.
CHAIRMAN I JUST WANNA SAY THANK
YOU SO MUCH IN MEMBERS THANK YOU
FOR A MOMENT HERE TODAY AND I
APOLOGIZE ABOUT BEING LATE IS
IT'S A LITTLE BIT OF SHOWED A SO.
GOOD TIMES I'M RICHARD GIVE
PREFERENCE IN REGARD TO SP TWO
SIXTY NINE OR SB THIRTEEN OR
LONG FIRST.
ALRIGHT SIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I'M MISTER CHAIRMAN I JUST WANNA
TAKE A MOMENT TO THINK YOU INTO
YOUR A VERY CAPABLE STAFF FOR
ALL THE WORK ON THESE BILLS.
I IF IT WORKS FOR YOU WOULD LIKE
TO BE ABLE TO ADVANCE THE P TWO
SIXTY NINE FOCUSED ON FISH
TICKETS.
I THIS ISONE OF OF MISTER
HARPER'S PAPER BILLS OF THE YEAR --
SO FISH TICKETS ARE ALSO KNOWN
AS LEANING RECEIPTS AND THEY
USED BY COMMERCIAL FISH BUYERS
TO REPORT WHAT WAS CAUGHT IN HOW
MUCH WAS CAUGHT.
IN ITS MANDATORY THAT THEY HAVE
TO REPORT THESE FISH TICKETS TO
THE PARTNER OF FISH AND WILDLIFE.
CURRENTLY THESE FISH TICKETS ARE
ALL SUBMITTED.
BE A PAPER VIA MAIL.
I THE BILL REQUIRES LANE
RECEIPTS NOW TO BE READ A
COMPLETED ELECTRONICALLY
DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL WILDLIFE
WITHIN TWENTY FOUR HOURS OF THE
LANDING [inaudible]
AT HOWEVER FISHING GAME
COMMISSION RECENTLY ADOPTED
REGULATIONS THAT ENSURE THE
SWITCH FROM PAPER RECEIPTS
SLANDEROUS EACH ELECTRONIC FISH
TICKETS.
FRANKLY TRANSITIONING FROM PAPER
TO ELECTRONIC FISH TICKETS JUST
MAKE SENSE I THESE REGULATIONS
WENT THROUGH DFW IS
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURES AS
REQUIRED BY THE ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCEDURES ACT WHICH INCLUDES
PUBLIC NOTIFICATION.
AS WELL AS PUBLIC HEARINGS THIS
BILL UPDATES THE THE CODE TO
SOLIDIFY AT THE COMMISSION'S
REGULATIONS IN INCLUDES AN
URGENCY CLAUSE TO ENSURE THAT
THE REGULATIONS ARE IMPLEMENTED
AS SCHEDULED.
BUT THERE HAVE BEEN SOME
CONCERNS RAISED NO ONE BE OPEN
OPEN ABOUT IT WITH REGARD TO
SUBMITTING THE TICKETS WITHIN
TWENTY FOUR HOURS.
SO WE'RE CURRENTLY WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING FISHERMEN
INDIA W. TO FIND A TIME FRAME
THAT WORKS FOR EVERYONE AND I
THINK NO PUN INTENDED WORKING TO
BE ABLE.
TO LAND THAT.
ONE ARE THESE NEW REGULATIONS
WHICH HAVE ALREADY BEEN APPROVED
BY THE FISH AND GAME COMMISSION
ARE GOING TO BENEFIT FISHERMEN
IN FISH BUYERS IN THE STATE'S
ECONOMY.
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I
DON'T THINK YOU CAN SECURE.
IS CHAIR MEMBERS OF THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT
NO OPPENHEIM WITH PACIFIC COAST
FEDERATION OF FISHERMEN'S
ASSOCIATIONS IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL -- THIS
SPRING'S CALIFORNIA ARE A FROM
THE STONE AGE THE MODERN TIMES
WE HOPE THAT --
WITH THIS NEW ELECTRONIC LANDING
TOOL WILL BE ABLE.
TO FAST TRACK WILL AND OUR
FISHERY MANAGEMENT DECISION
MAKING --
USING STATE OF THE ART TOOLS
THAT MANAGE HAVE BEEN USING
OTHER STATES WITH WITH UP TO
DATE.
WENDY'S RECEIPTS FOR YEARS NOW
AYE IT'S ABOUT TIME THAT WE
ENABLE FISHERMEN TO HAVE MORE
SURGICAL PRECISE AND ENABLED.
ACCESS TO THE STOCKS ARE
INCLUDING SALMON.
ARE AS WELL AS DUNGEONS CRAP SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
WILL FOR TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR AND THE COMMITTEE TO
PERFECT THE BILL.
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT
THINK.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ROB ROSS
ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
FISHERIES.
AND SEAFOOD INSTITUTE THE BUYERS
THE PROCESSORS OF THE FISH.
AND WE BY THE FISH FROM THE
FISHERMEN GET IT TO MARKET ONE I
THINK THE SENATOR AGAIN FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP HE ALWAYS --
TAKES ON VERY DIFFICULT ISSUES
ONCE IN AWHILE HE GETS A PASS
AND THEY'RE NOT SO DIFFICULT.
UP THERE'S LITTLE TECHNICAL
PROBLEM WITH THIS IF WE WERE TO
BUY FISH SHAUNA [inaudible]
FRIDAY --
WE'D HAVE TO REPORT ON A
SATURDAY AND THERE'S BEEN NOBODY
AT WORK.
TO REPORTED ON SATURDAY AND
LIKEWISE.
ON SATURDAY IF WE HAD  REPORT
BY SUNDAY SO WE THINK WE CAN
WORK THROUGH THIS WILL WORK WITH
THE DEPARTMENT AGAIN THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR HIS.
LEADERSHIP AND WE WE ARE
GENNIFER.
OPENING THE MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS AT LUCAS ARTS AND HAVE
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY WERE
SUPPORT THAT CENTER REQUIRES
BILL THANK YOU SO MUCH
[inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
NO WISHING TO THEM COME FORWARD
AND SPEAKING OPPOSITION TO THAT.
SEE THERE ANYWAY.
WINE SPEAK AGAINST A BILL THAT
WOULD LIKE CLOSE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH A SURE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
WHEN YOU'RE ABLE TO STEP RIGHT
OR WE WOULD DO THAT WE HAVE A
QUORUM YOUR NEXT BILL IS S. B.
THIRTEEN RIGHT.
THANK YOU MUCH THERE --
BEFORE I START I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THE WORK ON THIS BILL AS WELL AS
EXCEPT THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
THAT MEMBERS THE GREAT CITY
CALIFORNIA PROVIDES AMERICA WITH
FRESH HEALTHY WHILE CUT SEAFOOD
I AND I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO
THE COULD ASSEMBLYMAN FROM NORTH
COAST WHO'S BEEN WORKING JUST AS
HARD.
ON ALL ISSUES OF THE FISHERIES
WELL.
AND AND HE KNOWS THAT
CALIFORNIA'S FISHING INDUSTRIES
AMONG THE TOP SEAFOOD PRODUCING
STATES CAUGHT IN AMERICA IN THE
JOINT COMMITTEES ON FISHERIES
AND AQUACULTURE WORKS WITH THE
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF HARD
WORKING MEN AND WOMEN DIFFICULT
IT'S IT'S COMMERCIAL AND
RECREATIONAL.
FISHING INDUSTRIES WORTH NOW
NINE BILLION DOLLARS A IN
ADVANCE IS AN OMNIBUS BILL EVERY
FEW YEARS REMAIN THE ISSUES AND
CHALLENGES LARGE AND SMALL.
S. B. THIRTEEN KNOW NINE
ADDRESSES VARIOUS ISSUES OF THAT
HAVE BEEN ADVANCED BY THE FLEET
REQUIRING IDEA OF W. DEVELOP
REGULATIONS FOR THE RETRIEVAL OF
LOS OR ABANDON COMMERCIAL CRAB
TRAPS.
IN EXCHANGE REPEAL DATES AT THE
EXISTING STATUTE I WANNA SAY
THANK YOU TO THE FLEET WHO
STEPPED UP VOLUNTARILY TO BE
ABLE TO MOVE THIS ACTION A IN
GRATEFUL FOR THAT.
OPERATION THE FISH AND GAME
COMMISSION TO CONSIDER REQUEST.
TO TRANSFER HOW THE PERMIT TO
ANOTHER VESSEL OF EQUAL OR LESS
A CAPACITY ARE ALSO EXTENDING
THE COMMERCIAL SALMON STAMP
PROGRAM AQUARIUM FINE ANCHOVY
TAKE LAW IN HUMBLE BAY. TO LINE
WITH THE REST OF CALIFORNIA THEY
HAVE THEIR SEPARATE AYE
REGULATIONS UP IN HUMBLE THIS
WOULD NOW BRING THEM IN LINE
WITH THE REMAINDER OF THE STATE.
THE BILL --
COMPLIES --
COMPILED THIS PROTECTION INTO
ONE SINGLE BILL A IN A ONCE I
THINK YOU KNOW NOT BEHIND AYE
SIR THEY JAMMING AT TO MY RIGHT
HE'STHE EXECUTRIX OF THE
PACIFIC COAST FEDERATION
FISHERMAN'S ASSOCIATION.
OUT ONE OF THE MARROW WITH
AUDUBON SOCIETY WHO ALSO APPEARS
WELL AND THEN OF COURSE THE MAN
THE MYTH THE LEGEND MISTER ROB
ROSS.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ROB ROSS
ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
FISHERIES AND SEAFOOD INSTITUTE.
I WANT TO THANK THE SENATOR ONE
THINK STAFF FURTHER WORK AND
PERFECTING THIS BILL.
WHEN YOU GET AN OMNIBUS BILL
USED TO CALL THEM A
BOUILLABAISSE OR A CIOPPINO BILL?
BECAUSE IT TOUCHES SO MANY FISH
AND SHELLFISH SPECIES AND IT'S
GOOD TO GET IT.
ALMOST TO THE FINISH LINE WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS --
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY NO
OPPENHEIM PACIFIC COAST
FEDERATION OF FISHERMEN'S
ASSOCIATIONS WERE THANK THE
SENATOR FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON
THIS THIS BILL IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT.
AYE AYE DISSOLVED BRIEFLY TOUCH
MONTH THREE PROVISIONS THAT WE
FIND PARTICULARLY CRITICAL --
AS WE MODERNIZE THE COMMERCIAL
FISHING INDUSTRY THROUGH THE THE
BILL FIRST IS THE SEVEN STEP
PROGRAM THIS IS A PROGRAM THAT
IS CREATED BY COMMERCIAL
FISHERMEN.
I IN ORDER TO REINVEST PROFITS
ARE THAT INDIVIDUALS RECEIVED IN
THE RESOURCE IN CONSERVATION
PRESERVATION.
THE SECOND WAY IS A A SMALL
CHANGE THAT WOULD REOPEN AREAS
OF HOW THAT TROLL FISHERIES IN
THE CENTRAL PART OF THE STATE.
UP FOR ACCESS THESE AREAS WHICH
UNFORTUNATELY LOST DUE TO A
MAPPING ERROR ABOUT FIFTEEN
YEARS AGO --
AND WERE EAGER TO SEE THESE
AREAS REOPEN --
AND SUBJECT TO FISH AND GAME
COMMISSION CONSIDERATION.
THE THIRD IS AN INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT PATH FORWARD FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DUNGENESS CRAB
FISHERY.
SPEC T ADDRESSING THE ISSUE OF
WELL ENTANGLEMENTS --
WE ARE GOING TO BE IMPLEMENTING
THE RISK ASSESSMENT AND
MITIGATION PROGRAM PROMULGATED
BY THE THE ENTANGLEMENT WORKING
GROUP.
ARE AND WE'RE GOING TO CREATE A
FRAMEWORK FOR THE PROTECTION --
OF MARINE MAMMALS AND THE FOR
PERIODS OF THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
INCREDIBLE BILL ALRIGHT OTHERS
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR THE
CONTRACTS AND HAVE THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY IN SUPPORT OF THE
FISHERIES OMINOUS ON BUS BILL
THANK YOU.
TYPE GUY JEFF CHESTER OF SENIOR
SCIENTIST AT OCEANIA ALSO MEMBER
OF THE CALIFORNIA DUNGEONS CRAB
FISHING GEAR WORKING GROUP I
WANTED TO UP PARTICULARLY SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THE PROVISIONS ON
THOUGH THE WELL TENEMENTS AND
LOOK FOR TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR AND STAKEHOLDERS.
TO CONTINUE THAT THAT PROGRESS
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING JERRY GARCIA AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE IT
KRISTIN MONSALVE WITH THE CENTER
FOR BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY AND ON
BEHALF OF OUR OVER A HUNDRED
THOUSAND SUPPORT AREAS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WE SUPPORT THAT.
THE THE BILL ON THE PROVISIONS
WITH RESPECT TO MARINE LIFE
ENTANGLEMENTS IN PARTICULAR IF
AMENDED TO WIND AND RECOMMENDS
THAT SUBDIVISION.
CEO OF SECTION SIX BE AMENDED TO
ALSO ADDRESS MARINE LIFE
ENTANGLEMENTS NOT JUST MARINE
MAMMAL ENTANGLEMENTS TO PROVIDE.
FOR CLARITY THAT THE DEPARTMENT
CAN USE ITS INTERIM AUTHORITY TO
ALSO ADDRESS LEATHERBACK SEA
TURTLE ENTANGLEMENTS AND ALSO
THAT THE BILL BE AMENDED SO THAT
THE INTERIM AUTHORITY.
ONLY SUNSETS ONCE THE EFFECTIVE
THE REGULATIONS REQUIRED BY
SUBDIVISIONS DE ARE EFFECTIVE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HOWEVER MANY WITH WHITE HOUSE
PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF
SOCIAL COMPASSION AND
LEGISLATION ALSO VERY SUPPORTIVE
OF OMNIBUS BILL WITH THE I'M
WELL INTO MY PROVISIONS I THINK
SENATOR.
THANK YOU.
LIMIT PAUSE FOR A MINUTE NOW
AMONG ESTABLISH A QUORUM SO THAT
WE CAN TAKE US SOME DIRECTION
FROM THIS COMMITTEE ON THIS BILL
AND PRIOR BILL.
AND SECRETARY.
DOLLARS.
EDUARDO GARCIA PRESENT
[inaudible]
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
CARILLO [inaudible]
CHOI PRESIDENT.
CHIU.
HERE.
FRIEDMAN GLORIA HERE
[inaudible]
HARPER.
KALRA LEVINE MATHIS HERE.
RUBIO SALAS WOULD.
IF I THINK WE HAVE A QUORUM WE
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
THOSE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE
[inaudible]
GO FORWARD [inaudible]
ALRIGHT.
IT'S LIKE CLOTHES.
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE AND I DUE TO THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS.
TURTLES MARINE LIFE --
MUCH OF WHAT WAS STATED --
WILL BE COVERED UNDER THIS BILL
AS WELL THANKS TO THE COMMITTEES
AND THANK YOU WE HAVE MOTION A
SECOND -- NO
QUESTION COMMITTEE MEMBERS ROLL
CALL PLEASE.
AND HE DID ACCEPT IT MAKES.
THE MOTION IS SUBDUED PASSES
AMENDED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
EDUARDO GARCIA AYE GARCIA AYE
GALLAGHER.
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE CARILLO.
CHOI AYE CHOI AYE CHU.
CHU AYE FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE HARPER ON PROPER AYE
KALRA [inaudible]
LEVINE MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE RUBIO SALAS WOULD
[inaudible]
WOULD I SO KEEP THAT OPEN FOR
THE MEMBERS.
TO WEIGH IN LET'S TAKE UP A
MOTION.
ON ITEM ONE S. B. TWO SIXTY NINE
MAKE A MOTION.
THE MOTION.
AND THE SECOND [inaudible]
ROCCA.
THE MOTION ON SB TWO SIXTY NINE
IS.
DO PASSED THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
EDUARDO GARCIA AYE GARCIA AYE
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE CARILLO.
CHOI AYE CHOI AYE CHU. TO I
FRIEDMAN.
GLORIA.
LAURIE I HARPER.
HARPER NOT VOTING KALRA
[inaudible]
LEVINE.
MATHIS AYE MATHIS AYE RUBIO.
SALAS WOULD [inaudible]
WOULD I I WILL LEAVE THE CALL
FOR NO.
LOCAL OPEN ON THAT ITEM AS WELL
MEMBERS THERE ARE SEVEN ITEMS ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR --
THE MOTION IS OUR SECOND SECOND
MOTION SECOND LOCAL.
THE MOTIONS ON THE SENATE
CALENDAR FOR ITEMS NUMBER. TWO
S. B. EIGHT EIGHTY ONE
WIECKOWSKI DO PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR S. B. NINE
FIFTY FIVE TO COST TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SP TEN SEVENTY
THREE TO PASTOR APPROPRIATIONS.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT S. B. ELEVEN
TWENTY SIX PORTANTINO.
THE PASTOR APPROPRIATIONS ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE SP THIRTEEN TEN
GOODPASTER APPROPRIATIONS.
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN SP THIRTEEN
ELEVEN BERRYHILL.
WHO PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BOTH CHANGING THE
NAME OF THE LICENSE FROM
SPORTSMAN? TO COMBINED HUNTING
AND FISHING ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN
SP FOURTEEN NINETY THREE SENATE
NATURAL RESOURCES ON WATER.
SHOULD PASS TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS IT'S NAY
GALLAGHER.
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE CARILLO DIFFICULT
FOR CHOI AND THAT'S WHY I CHOOSE
SMITH SHALL I FRIEDMAN
[inaudible]
GLORIA.
DARIA I HARPER UP HARPER AYE
KALRA.
LEVINE.
MATHIS.
MATHIS I RUBIO SALAS WOOD I
WOULD I HERE.
WE HAVE ENOUGH CLOSER TO HIM.
IT'S A RELIEF THAT ON BLUE
CONSECUTIVE MR DOT I'M GOING TO
BE SITTING IN FOR MISTER GARCIA.
PLEASE PROCEED WITH YOUR BILL S.
B. TEN SEVENTY THREE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BEFORE
BEGIN LET ME NOTE THAT I ACCEPT
THE SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS ON PAGE
THREE OF THE HOUSES.
APPRECIATE WORKING WITH STAFF ON
THAT S. B. NINE NINETEEN
REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES TO DEVELOP A PLAN TO
DEPLOY A NETWORK OF STREAM
GAUGES.
INCLUDING A DETERMINATION OF OF
FUNDING NEEDS AND OPPORTUNITIES
FOR REACTIVATING [inaudible]
EXISTING GAUGES.
THIS GOT MY ATTENTION THE
CALIFORNIA'S LOST THE ABILITY TO
MEASURE STREAM FLOW WHICH IS A
VERY IMPORTANT TYPE OF DATA. FOR
OUR WATER MANAGEMENT SYSTEM. 86%
OF THE STATE'S SIGNIFICANT
STREAMS ARE POORLY GAUGED STREAM
FLOW DATA SUPPORTS DAVID A WATER
MANAGEMENT DECISIONS.
UNDERLYING OPERATION OF STATE IN
REGIONAL WATER INFRASTRUCTURE
AMONG OTHER USES.
CALIFORNIA USED TO HAVE MORE
THAN THIRTY SIX HUNDRED STREAM
GAUGES NEARLY HALF OF THOSE
GAUGES HAVE BECOME INACTIVE.
EVEN FEWER GAUGES PROVIDE RICH
REAL TIME REPORTING.
RESTORING STREAM GAGES IN THE
CENTRAL COMPONENT OF THE
STATEWIDE IN REGIONAL WATER
MANAGEMENT STRATEGY THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION TO S..
B. NINE ONE NINE AND I ASK YOU
RIGHT.
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT GREAT
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF HIS
FACTS ABOUT THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY OR STRONG SUPPORT OF
SB NINE NINETEEN ONE THING
CENTER DODD. FOR LEADERSHIP AND
HELPING TO IMPROVE HOW WE MANAGE
WATER HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
THAT COMPREHENSIVE DOWNTOWN
STREAMFLOW CONDITIONS PROVIDED
FROM THE STRAIN GAUGES DOES NOT
EXIST IN CALIFORNIA AND THE
STATUS NEEDED TO MANAGE OUR MOST
IMPORTANT RESOURCE FOR PEOPLE.
FARM FOR FARMS AND WILDLIFE AS
WELL AS WE NINE NINETEEN WOULD
CREATE A PLAN TO DETERMINE WHERE
WE SHOULD TO REACTIVATE EXISTING
GAUGES AND PLAY NEW GAUGES AND
PARTY LOCATIONS ACROSS THE STATE.
THIS BILL RECOGNIZE AN ONGOING.
TWENTY FIVE ENGAGES IN THE NEED
FOR CALIFORNIA TO FILL THE VOID
TO VOTE TO PROVIDE MORE OPEN
DATA INFORMATION TRANSPARENCY
PENS TRANSPARENCY EXCUSE ME. TO
BETTER MANAGE WATER TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF PAY PEOPLE AND NATURE
WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MARK
FRIENDSTER MAKER FOR THE CINEMA
COUNTY WATER AGENCY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB.
NINE ONE NINE YOU KNOW WE USE
THE DATA FROM THE STRING GAUGES
ALONG WITH US ARMY CORPS OF
ENGINEERS TO HELP OUR OPERATION
OF FLOOD CONTROL AND WATER
SUPPLY.
AND THE REAL TIME DATA AYE
INSURES THAT FLOW RATES ARE
THERE TO PROTECT ENDANGERED FISH
FISH SPECIES.
COMING OFF OF THE TUBS FIRE LAST
YEAR ONE OF OUR GREAT CONCERN
XIN WATER AGENCY WAS FLOODING
EVENTS AND MORE SEDIMENT LOADING
FROM RUNOFF.
WE ACTIVELY SOUGHT.
FEDERAL AND STATE FUNDING
ASSISTANCE BUT MORTGAGES IN
PLACE OUR SEARCH CAME UP EMPTY
SUPPORT REALLY I ENCOURAGED BY
THIS BILL TO UP FACILITATE MORE
FUNDING FOR GAUGES GOING FORWARD.
RESTAURANT ABOUT.
YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN SUPPORT
MISTER NAME AN ORGANIZATION.
GENEVIEVE AVEDON ON BEHALF OF
CERES AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
A MARIN ON BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
CHIANA CITY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA GROUNDWATER COALITION
IN SUPPORT THINKING THAT YOU.
MARK SMITH ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA TROUT THE GRASSLAND
WATER DISTRICT IN THE MID
PENINSULA OPEN SPACE REGIONAL
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING ROSY THOMPSON WITH
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA ALSO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING AARON EVANS WITH
THE LEAGUE OF CITIES AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS ADAM ROBIN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WATER ASSOCIATION WE
SUPPORT THE BILL WE DO HAVE TWO
RELATIVELY MODEST REQUESTED
AMENDMENTS THAT REALLY EMPHASIZE
THE VALUE THAT A ROBUST AND
RELIABLE STRING GAUGE NETWORK
CAN HAVE TO THE STATE.
WE SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU.
BURKE BROUGH REPRESENTING SANTA
CLARA VALLEY WATER DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT.
SO ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NO ONE OF BRING IT BACK
MISTER SOMEONE [inaudible]
RIVER.
OKAY SO SAY NO ONE WILL BRING
BACK A QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
WHAT?
DOES THAT HAVE YOU FEE OF A HOW
MUCH OF THIS WILL COST AND THE
WHAT THE FUNDING SOURCES WILL BE.
WELL.
THAT'S PART OF THIS BILL IS TO
MAKE THOSE DETERMINATIONS WHAT
THE COST WILL BE.
THIS BILL --
DOES NOT HAVE A FUNDING --
ESSENTIALLY WHAT --
WE BE LOOKING FOR BUDGET
ALLOCATION OR TO BE ABLE TO GET
IN THE A WATER BOND OR SUB I GOT
FOR FOR FUNDS.
TO FUND THIS WE GO FORWARD BUT
WE HAVE TO HAVE THIS FIRST.
IN ORDER TO I TAKE THAT VERY
IMPORTANT STEP.
THANK YOU YOU KNOW WITHOUT HIS
MANAGER WHAT IS SO CURRENT
PROBLEM HOW DOES THIS BILL
IMPROVED HEALTH PROBLEM.
I THINK THAT THAT BY A BOOK.
AND THERE'S NUMBER OF ISSUES
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FIRSTLY AT THAT
WE KNOW THE NATURE CONSERVANCY
WE COMPLETE A SURVEY THIS YEAR
DETERMINE HOW MANY.
OF YOU KNOW OF SEARCHING GAUGES
IN CALIFORNIA ACTIVE REVERSES
NOT AND SO THERE'S OVER THIRTY
SIX HUNDRED LOCATIONS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE WERE STRING GAUGES
HAVE BEEN ACTIVE AT SOME POINT
BUT CURRENTLY ONLY 54% ARE
CURRENTLY ACTIVE.
AND SO YOU ACTUALLY HAVE A
SITUATION WHERE YOU HAVE A HARD
TIME MONITORING AT IN A REAL
TIME DATA RIGHT TO KNOW WHERE
FLOWS ARE IN STATE FOR SO FOR
HABITAT FOR VIEW OF PURPOSES OF
FISH AND OTHER PURPOSES.
AS IF YOU DON'T HAVE AND THAT I
KNOW SORT OF AN ACCURATE
MONITORING OF WITH THE WATER
FLOWS.
OUT YOU CAN HAVE ADVERSE IMPACTS
ON THAT BETWEEN THE NATURAL
ENVIRONMENT.
BY KNOWING THE ONLINE OUTLAW
WATER FLOWING HOW DOES IT RELATE
TO US. FOR EXAMPLE YOU KNOW
PROTECTING FISH --
COMES NOT SURE I UNDERSTAND YOUR
QUESTION.
BY LOWERING THE BY MEASURING.
THE AMOUNT OF LOVE I' ON IT
WHAT YOU.
YET KNOWING THAT THE AMOUNT OF
THE WATER FLOWING.
WHAT DOES US MORE ONE KNOWLEDGE?
A MINNESOTA ALREADY AFFECTED.
NO FISH LIVE SO IF THERE'S A I
MEAN THERE'S ISSUES I THINK WHAT
YOU KNOW MONITORING --
SWORDFISH NO QUESTION BUT ALSO
ADDITIONALLY AB SOME OF THE
OTHER WEEK USES FOR STRING
GAUGES ARE TO ALSO FOR ISSUES OF
FLICK FLOOD.
CONTROL AND THINGS OF THAT
NATURE AS WELL TO SUBMIT
[inaudible]
TROLL --
CONDITIONS BUT ALSO --
FOR MONITORING FOR PURPOSES OF
FOR FOR ADAM.
FLOOD CONTROL PURPOSES AS WELL.
YEAH I JUST THINK THAT DID THE
IDEAS YOU CAN'T MANAGE WHAT YOU
DON'T KNOW THIS BRINGS THE
INFORMATION --
TWO THE DECISION MAKERS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND IN SOME
CASES IT WAS.
YAWN DOT THE OF FLOW --
YOU'RE SOMEWHERE BELOW IT DAM
THEY COULD LET RELEASE MORE
WATER SO.
I HAD YOU KNOW THAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL AND IT'S IT IT'S IT IT'S
ALL PART OF THAT SYSTEM OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA ONCE HAD.
THAT WAS FUNDED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT A LOT OF IT AND THAT
FUNDING IS GOT AWAY AND THIS IS
WHY.
THAT WE NEED TO WORK MOVE ON
THIS BILL SO THAT WE CAN MANAGE
THIS DATA THESE DATA SETS HERE
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
OURSELVES.
I GUESS I WOULD JUST ADD THAT --
WITHOUT THE STATE IT'S DIFFICULT
ALSO COMMIT TO AND TO UNDERSTAND
YOU KNOW WHERE THERE MAY BE
DIVERSIONS TAKING PLACE --
FROM SRI BUT THAT CERTAINLY AN
ISSUE AND AND THE NORTHERN PART
OF MY DISTRICT WHERE DIVERSIONS
HAPPEN ALL THE TIME --
FOR ILLEGAL CANNABIS GROWS
WITHOUT HOW DO WE KNOW THAT
THAT'S HAPPENING WE KNOW THAT
THAT THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND WHY THE STREAMS ARE
GOING DRY AND WHERE THE WATER'S
GOING AND SO THIS IS PART OF
THIS IS ANOTHER PART OF THIS
ISSUE.
ANYONE OF US.
WE HAVE A MOTION [inaudible]
A SECOND.
BOB MR DOT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER DODD
THE BAD THE THE MOTION IS DO
PASS AS AMENDED --
APPRECIATE YOU VERY MUCH YOU
BRING IN THIS BEFORE I THINK
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT FOR NOT JUST
THE DISTRICT BUT I THINK FOR
CALIFORNIA THE WHOLE.
ON SHOULD THE BILL PASSED IT
WOULD LIKE TO BE CONSIDERED TO
BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR IF IT
WOULD COST SO --
WITH DATA MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL WROTE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED MOTION BY MISTER
CHIU.
OF SECOND BY MISTER GLORIA.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
EDUARDO GARCIA GALLAGHER.
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE CARILLO.
CHOI NO.
CHOI THE NO CHIU ARE CHIU AYE
FRIEDMAN.
GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE HARPER.
HARPER NO KALRA [inaudible]
LEVINE [inaudible]
MATHIS.
MATHIS NOT VOTING [inaudible]
RUBIO SALAS.
SALAS I WOULD I WOULD I SO GOT A
COUPLE.
BOOKS MISSING SO --
WILL LET LEAVE THAT --
ON CALL.
THANK YOU YOU HAVE A CUP YOU
HAVE ANOTHER [inaudible]
IT IS.
OKAY GOBBLED UP ALL THAT YEAH IT
WOULD ROLL THE DICE WITH ME HERE
MISTER DOT.
OKAY ALRIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER ALAN.
I THOUGHT I THOUGHT HE WAS GOING
TO JOIN YOU AND I HOPE.
BUT APPARENTLY NOT [inaudible]
FELT.
WELL THANK YOU --
MISTER.
TEMPORARY CHAIR AND MEMBERS --
I WANNA FIRST START OFF BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE FOR
WORKING SO CLOSELY WITH US ON
THIS MEASURE THIS IS S. B..
TEN FIFTEEN YEARS OLD START WITH
THAT.
HOW I'M VERY HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
SUGGEST AMENDMENT DISCUSSED?
AND THE COMMITTEES ANALYSIS I'M
ALSO COMMITTED TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS.
HOW ON THIS ISSUE TO CONTINUE TO
REFINE THE MEASURE AND CREATE
THE BEST?
A POSSIBLE PROGRAM.
SO THIS SAY THIS BILL --
ESTABLISHES THE CALIFORNIA
CLIMATE RESILIENCY PROGRAM AND
FIND WITHIN THE WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD --
TO BE FUNDED BY OUR GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION FROM THE JEEP
CHEROKEE. TO FIND PROVEN
PROJECTS AT A REGIONAL LEVEL
THAT WILL BE SPECIFICALLY
DESIGNED TO PROMOTE CLIMATE
RESILIENCY AND INCREASE THE
STATE'S ABILITY TO MITIGATE.
AND ADAPT TO THE IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE WHILE ALSO.
REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS THOSE TO COMPLY WITH A
LOT OF OUR AMBITIOUS STATE GOALS.
SO THE STATE CAN COASTAL
CONSERVANCY IS SOME OF YOU MAY
KNOW ALREADY HAS AN ADAPTATION
PROGRAM.
DESIGNED TO CAPTURE GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS AND HOPE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES NATURAL RESOURCES
ADAPT TO THE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE.
I BUILDING ON THIS SUCCESSFUL
MODEL THIS BILL SEEKS TO SCALE
UP OUR EFFORTS TO ENSURE THAT WE
BUILD A COORDINATED AND COHESIVE.
STATEWIDE PROGRAM TO GUIDE
EFFORTS TO ENSURE ARE NOT TO
RESOURCES ARE RESILIENT.
IN THE FACE OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
CALIFORNIA ARE HAS SEVERAL
PROGRAMS DESIGNED TO PROVIDE
FUNDING --
FOR THE REDUCTION OF GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS ARE NATURAL
WORKING LANDS AS MENTIONED IN
THE ANALYSIS BUT THIS BILL TAKES
A ASSEMBLY DIFFERENT PROTRUDE
THESE EXISTING PROGRAMS BY
ALLOWING GRANTING AGENCIES TO
TAILOR FINDING A PROJECTS.
THAT CAN ADDRESS THE RESILIENCY
IN ADAPTATION NEEDS OF A GIVEN
COMMUNITY YOUR REGION AND NOT
JUST FOCUS FUNDING ON REDUCING
EMISSIONS.
SO IN URBAN COMMUNITIES FUNDING
COULD BE DIRECTED TOWARD
PROJECTS THAT ADDRESS HEAT
ISLAND CONCERNS PROVIDE TREE
CANOPY AND PART ACCESS IMPROVE
WATER SUPPLY RELIABILITY IN OUR
CITIES.
AYE NEWMAN COMMUNITIES THEY MAY
BENEFIT THROUGH PROTECTION
RESTORATION OF OUR GREEN BELTS
AND BUFFER AREAS SUCH AS WETLAND
RESTORATION PROJECTS THAT HAVE.
REDUCE THE FLOODING EXPERIENCE
IN SAN JOSE IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
I PROTECTING AGRICULTURAL
WORKING LANDS IT SERVICE
WILDLIFE HABITAT AND CENTRAL
VALLEY.
FORCED REGIONS IN THE
COMMUNITIES WITHIN THAT MAY HAVE
DIFFERENT NEEDS ALONG WITH
REDUCING FIRE RISK IN RESTORING
FORCE TOUGH.
THESE REGIONS WILL I NEED TO
CAREFULLY MANAGE VULNERABLE
WATERSHEDS TO PROTECT DRINKING
WATER SOURCES AN ARTICULATION.
APPLIES TO THE IDEA THAT WE NEED
AT A REGIONAL FOCUS AND AS YOU
KNOW THE OAK IN CINEMA THAT
BURNED MAY BE VERY DIFFERENT
FROM THE CHAPARRAL.
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THAT'S
ALWAYS A FIRE RISK THE BROAD
RANGE OF ACTIVITIES OFFERING
THIS BILL ENSURES THAT EACH
REGION OF OUR STATE EACH
COMMUNITY WILL BE ABLE TO
COMPETE FOR FUNDS EITHER THROUGH
THEIR LOCAL CONSERVANCY.
OR IF THEY DON'T HAVE ONE
THROUGH THE WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION OR THE WICB.
ARE CONSERVANCY IS DO YOU HAVE
EXPERIENCE QUITE A BIT OF
EXPERIENCE BOTH ADDRESSING
ADAPTATION AND RESILIENCY AND
IMPORTANTLY.
WORKING EFFECTIVELY WITH LOCAL
COMMUNITIES TO FIND EMPLOYMENT
LOCAL PRIORITIES.
AND INOTES WE'VE SEEN FIRES
MUDSLIDES DROUGHTS.
FLOODS EXTREME HEAT EVENTS IT'S
IT'S ARE STRONG SENSE THAT WE
NEED TO SET UP A STATEWIDE
PROGRAM FOCUSED ON NATURAL
RESOURCES ADAPTATION.
AND RESILIENCY IN THE IN THE
FACE OF SOME OF THE CHANGING.
NOT CLIMATE CONCERNS THAT WE
HAVE AND WITH THAT I RESPECT YES
WHEN I VOTE AND TURNER WITH.
THANKS A LOT I THINK THANKS
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS THAT
LUCAS BURKE SOME HAVE THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY.
US HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
TEN FIFTEEN THINK SENATOR ALLEN
FOR CARRYING THIS MEASURE.
A YOU KNOW IT'S AND THERE'S NO
QUESTION THAT INVESTMENTS NEED
TO CONTINUE TO REDUCE EMISSIONS
AND MITIGATE THE WORST OUTCOMES
OF CLIMATE CHANGE THERE'S ALSO
NEED FIRST THE STATE INVESTING
CLIMBERS ALLIANCE.
AS THE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE
ARE ALREADY HELPING AS EVIDENCED
BY HIGHER TEMPERATURES LONGER
FIRE SEASON SENSIBLY YEAR ROUND
AT THIS POINT.
WITH OF COURSE THE MOST THE MOST
INTENSE AND DESTRUCTIVE FIRES --
IN CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY.
A ALSO LESS FREQUENT MORE
INTENSE STORMS THIS PAST DECADE
AT THESE NEEDED INVESTMENTS IN
CLIMATE RESILIENCE WILL FUND
PROJECTS AT THAT HELP
CALIFORNIA'S NATURAL RESOURCES
AND SYSTEMS.
WITHSTAND THE CLIMATE CHANGE
IMPACTS MORE AND MORE ARE
NATURAL RESOURCE.
NOT NOT RESOURCES LACK OF
CLIMATE RESILIENCE HAVING
DEVASTATING AFFECTS OUR
COMMUNITIES.
THE GOAL OF S. B. TEN FIFTEEN IS
TO PROTECT OUR NATIONAL
THAT THEY IN TURN CAN PROTECT
OUR COMMUNITIES ON CLIMATE
CHANGE IMPACTS.
A TO REACH THIS GOAL SB TEN
FIFTEEN BUILDS OFF THE KIND IT
READY PROGRAM OF THE STATE AND
COSTA CONSERVANCY.
AT CLIMB ADAPTATION PROGRAM FOR
NASA RESOURCES THE CURRENTLY
EXISTING STATUTE --
IN ITS EXPANSION OF THIS --
ANY BUILDS ON THIS EXISTING
PROGRAM AT THESE PROGRAMS
INVESTMENTS ARE GREAT START BUT
MORE MUCH MORE IS NEEDED AND NOW
WITH RESPECT ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE [inaudible] FOR MUCH.
YOU KNOW JUST YOU'RE JUST YOU'RE
TO SUPPORT AND OTHERS IN SUPPORT
PLEASE.
AT MISTER CHAIR MARK FENCE MAKER
FOR THE ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE
FUND THE MOUNTAINS RECREATION
CONSERVATION AUTHORITY THE
SENATE CLAIRE BELLY OPEN SPACE
THIRTY AND TROUT UNLIMITED IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
THE MORNING CHRIS MEARNS FROM
THIS YEAR BUSINESS COUNCIL ON
BEHALF OF SEVERAL SEVERE BASE
WHEN TRUSTING COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS ALSO HAS STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CAN SHATTER BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA AND BASS A
PLANK COUNCIL A PENINSULA OPEN
SPACE TRUST TO THE REDWOODS
LEAGUE AND THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICTS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING ELEANOR TEAS ON
BEHALF OF BIG STAR LAND TRUST
BOLSA CHICA LAND TRUST CINEMA
COUNTY WATER AGENCIES CINEMA
COUNTY AG OPEN SPACE DISTRICT
AND THE WILD THINGS CONSERVANCY
IN SUPPORT THINK YOU
[inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS MY
NAME IS BRIAN SEVEN WITH THAT
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE AND
AGRICULTURE NETWORK.
WE ARE REGRETFULLY IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL.
BECAUSE AS THE ANALYSIS SUGGESTS
IT HAD DUPLICATES AND THREATENS
TO UNDERMINE OUR EXISTING
CLIMATE RESILIENCY PROGRAMS FOR
NATURAL WORKINGMAN'S --
WE SINCERELY APPRECIATE THAT
DESIRE TO ADVANCE CLIMATE
RESILIENCY POLICY --
A AND SHARE THAT INTEREST BUT
WOULD PREFER TO BUILD ON
EXISTING PROGRAMS RATHER THAN
CREATE A NEW PROGRAM --
AND WE DO APPRECIATE THE AT THE
TIME THE AUTHOR STAFF IS SPENT
IN DISCUSSING POTENTIAL
AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL --
AS RECENTLY SPEAK BUT AS IT
STANDS RIGHT NOW CAN'T SPUR
[inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
YOU KNOW BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
I I HAVE A QUESTION GOTTA AND
THAT IS ALONG THE SAME LINES AS
THE OPPOSITION WITNESSED THIS IS
A KIND OF THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
ISSUE. FOR ME --
BEEN A VERY STRONG SUPPORTER OF
WORKING LANCE --
THE VALUE OF WORKING LANSING
CLIMATE RESILIENCY --
YOU'VE MENTIONED YOUR BILL TALKS
ABOUT PROVEN --
PROJECTS --
I BELIEVE THAT --
THERE IS NOW SCIENCE TO SUPPORT --
THAT WORKING LANDS ACTUALLY DO
THAT YET THEY'RE YET WE STILL
ARE WERE STILL PART ON THIS HOW
TO HOW HOW CAN WE RESOLVE THIS.
YEAH ARE YOU KNOW I'M VERY
SYMPATHETIC TO THIS --
SET OF CONCERNS AND I I YOU KNOW
THAT THE FACT IS THAT WE DO HAVE
A WHOLE SET OF PROGRAMS THAT ARE
SPECIFICALLY TAILORED TO
AGRICULTURE SECTOR.
ARE TO REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AND IMPROVE RESILIENCY
I I DON'T DISAGREE WITH ANYTHING
IT'S BEEN SAID I JUST.
THIS IS A DIFFERENT BILL ON IT
ON A DIFFERENT TOPIC AND I
CERTAINLY YOU KNOW SUPPORT
BUILDING ON THE PROGRAMS THAT WE
HAVE EXISTING AND WE CAN ALL
WORK TOGETHER AND TRYING.
TO TRY TO DO THAT --
WE YOU KNOW BUT IT AYE I
CERTAINLY DON'T THINK THAT JUST
BECAUSE WE IF THEY'RE THEY'RE
JUST THEY'RE DIFFERENT ISSUES I
MEAN JUST IN LET ME I DON'T
AGREE THE IDEA THAT UNLESS WE
TACKLE.
THE PROBLEM THEIR ADDRESSING
THAT WE SHOULDN'T DEVELOP
SOLUTIONS THAT ADDRESS THE OTHER
ISSUES THAT ARE AT THE HEART OF
THIS BILL.
I THINK WHAT THEY'RE ASKING FOR
SAFE I THINK WHAT MY
INTERPRETATION IS THAT THEY FEEL
THAT THAT THIS FAVORS OTHER
PROJECTS OVER THESE AND I THINK
THEY WOULD LIKE TO BE CONSIDERED.
FOR FOR EQUAL FOOTING I BELIEVE
I BELIEVE THIS IS ACTUALLY OUR
THIS IS ACTUALLY PROVEN --
THAT WORKING LANCE CANCER
QUESTOR CARBON CAN REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GASES.
SO.
I THINK THE FEELING IS THAT THEY
FEEL LIKE THEY'RE BEING PUSHED
ASIDE IN FAVOR OF OTHER PROGRAMS
SO HOW DO WE CAN WE CAN WE CAN
WE GET A COMMITMENT TO WORK
TOGETHER TO TRY TO ALLAY SOME OF
THOSE CONCERNS.
I THINK THE REAL BUT WE'RE NOT
TAKING ANY THIS PROGRAMS AWAY
NOW WHAT YOU'RE PUTTING IT IT
FEELS LIKE YOU'RE PUTTING
SOMETHING IN.
YOUR FAVORING SOMETHING ELSE AND
AND AND PUTTING THEM ASIDE
THAT'S THAT'S THE IMPRESSION I
GET LUCK THAT WOULD CERTAINLY
NOT THE INTENT AYE AYE.
AYE BUT WOULD LOVE TO SIT DOWN
WITH THEM AND HAVE A
CONVERSATION BE THAT'S NOT AT
ALL THE INTENT ALRIGHT WERE.
VERY IMPRESSED WITH SOME OF THE
PROGRAMS THAT THEY'VE BEEN
WORKING ON AND AND I THINK I
THINK THE WE TO FIGURE OUT A WAY.
TO GET TO MARRY A ME IT'S
ADDITIVE RIGHT IF WE IF THERE'S
A WAY THAT WE CAN.
YOU KNOW BETTER MARY WHAT WE'RE
DOING WITH WHAT THEY'RE DOING
I'D BE VERY INTERESTED DOING
THAT YEAH I THINK I THINK THAT
THAT THINK THE STRUGGLE HAS BEEN
IN SPITE OF THE FACT THAT THERE
IS SCIENCE TO SUPPORT WHAT
THEY'RE DOING.
THEY HAD THE THE ABILITY TO GET
FUNDING TO BE INCLUDED AND PARTS
OF THESE HAS BEEN HAS BEEN
REALLY REALLY DIFFICULT AND SO I
THINK THE FEELING IS THAT.
THAT THIS BILLIS ANOTHER BILL
THAT KINDA SETS THEM ASIDE AND
MAKE AND AND AND GETS THEM YET
IN OTHER WORDS.
I BELIEVE WHEN YOU SAY PROVEN I
THINK WHAT THEY HAVE IS VERY
BEEN BUT I DON'T THINK THE BILL
REALLY REFLECTS THAT AT THIS
POINT.
SO SO WHEN WE WERE TOGETHER. TO
TO TRY TO GET FUNDING FOR FOR
BOTH FIVE THAT WOULD BE GREAT
THAT WOULD BE MY YEAH.
YEAH LOOKING AT JUST ADD A
COUPLE QUICK COMMENTS I THINK
THANK YOU FOR SOME OF THEM ARE
FOR YOUR COMMENTS.
I I THINK THAT YOU KNOW IT IS
THAT IF WE TALKED ABOUT THAT A
SECOND AGO I THINK ALSO THERE'S
AN ISSUE OF THAT THERE ARE.
ABOUT IT'S A CINCH AND OTHER
TOOL THE TOOL KIT RIGHT THERE
MA'AM NUMEROUS TOOLS OUT THERE
AT THE THE PROOF THE ACTS OF
CRIME THE AG SMART CLIMATE
PROGRAMS THERE THAT EXIST ARE
VERY IMPORTANT NO QUICK NO DOUBT.
I THINK THERE'S A REAL NEED FOR
ME BEEN WORKING I THINK AS
ADVOCATES I IN THAT SORT NAPA
WORKING LANDS WORLD. TO THIS
EVEN QUICKLY IN PASSED SEVERAL
YEARS WILL PICK THIS YEAR TOO
WHO I'D SORT OF CULTIVATE
CHAMPIONS MEMBERS WHO ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF THESE PROGRAMS
BOTH IN OF THE WHAT THE
CURRENTLY EXISTING THAT ALSO
ONES THAT MAYBE PUT IN A PLACE.
I AND THERE HAS BEEN A REAL
EFFORT AND TO DO PORTER AND WE
ALSO HEARD OF MY MISSION
ABSOLUTELY ETHNO APPRECIATE THAT
AND WE ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT WE
APPRECIATE CENTER ALLEN'S
EFFORTS ON THE SENATE SIDE.
THAT YOU KNOW IT'S IT'S
HEARTENING TO SEE THAT THERE ARE
SO MANY MEMBERS PARTICULAR THIS
YEAR.
OUT WHO ARE INTERESTED IN THESE
ISSUES AND RECOGNIZE THAT THERE
ARE SOLUTIONS TO BE HAD FROM THE
NATIONAL WORKING LAND SECTOR A
TO HELPING SWORDFIGHTING ARE
CLIMATE CHECK CHECK.
CHECK CLIMATE CHANGE ISSUES
CHALLENGES.
BUT I GUESS WHAT I GUESS WHAT
I'M LOOKING FOR IS AND YOU KNOW
A COMMITMENT TO WORKING WITH
FOLKS ON THIS. TO MAKE THIS
ADDITIVE SO THAT SO THAT.
SHOULD WIN THIS BILL COMES. TO
THE FLOOR OR AND THAT AND THAT
THAT THAT I CAN COMFORTABLY SAY
YES THAT THIS IS GOING TO BE
SUPPORTING.
OUR OUR OUR IRAQI NETWORKING
LANCE AND AND ARE SUSTAINABLE
AGRICULTURE I GUESS WHAT I HAD
SAID THE THE CHALLENGE EXPOSE
HIS IT IS JUST IT IT'S A A
DIFFERENT BILL IT'S IT BUT THE
BILL YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT I
WOULD BE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF AND
I'D LOVE.
TO DO WHAT YOU LOVE TO WORK WITH
YOU ON A IT'S I IT'S I DON'T SEE
WHY THEY SHOULD BE EXCLUSIVE.
AT DE MAYBE EUROPE NOW I'M
CURIOUS HOW YOUR WITNESS THINKS.
I DON'T SEE WHY THESE ARE
EXCLUSIVE AT ALL WHEN YOU THINK
THESE ARE PROVEN PROGRAMS.
TO YEAH WISE IS IT WISE THIS
EXCLUSIVE.
YEAH I I MEAN IT DON'T HAVE I
GUESS THAT YOU KNOW X. MAYBE
EXACT RIGHT ANSWER FOR YOU.
AT SOME OF THE REBELS ONE
ADDITIONAL POINT MARK. ONE
ADDITIONAL POINT I WILL THAT IS
IN THIS GREAT GRAYSON THAT
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS WHICH IS
THEIRS THERE ARE NUMEROUS IT'S
LEGISLATION OUT THERE RIGHT NOW
THIS YEAR. ONE AND ONE OF THE
PROGRAMS THAT I WANTED ITEMS
THAT IS BEING DISCUSSED IS THAT
SORT OF NEED FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FOR RANCHERS AND
FARMERS.
TO AYE AND THAT IS ACTUALLY A
BILL THAT IS BEING --
SPONSORED RIGHT NOW AT SOME OF
THE WINS BILL THAT YOU WERE SORT
OF WAYS TO TRY AND GET TO THIS
ISSUE RECENTLY ISSUED THE FACT
IS THE PROGRAMS EXIST AND IT'S
JUST A MATTER OF ALLOCATING
MONEY TO THEM.
WITHIN THE GINGER UP I MEAN THAT
THAT AND THAT'S BEEN A CHALLENGE
LET'S LET'S WORK ON THE
ALLOCATION ACT THAT THE
NEGOTIATIONS HAPPENING RIGHT NOW
WOULD LOVE TO HAVE YOU HELP ON
THAT.
COUNTY AND SERIOUSLY ICE UNLESS
THERE'S A IT'S IT'S BEEN PUSHED
ASIDE I MEAN THESE ARE THESE ARE
VALUABLE PROGRAMS AND AND AND
YOU KNOW SOMEONE COUNTY
PARTICULAR.
HAS BEEN AN INCUBATOR FOR
PROGRAMS AND MENDOCINO COUNTY
FOR THE IRA AND YET AND YET IT
FEELS LIKE --
CERTAINLY FROM MY DISTRICT THAT
THAT WE WHEN IT COMES TO FUNDING
PROJECTS LIKE THIS THAT HAVE A
POSITIVE INFLUENCE ON YOU AND
YOU DON GOAT GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION.
AND A POSITIVE INFLUENCE ON OUR
WORKING SOILS THAT WE GET PUSHED
ASIDE IN FAVOR OF OTHER KINDS OF
PROGRAMS AND SO WHAT I'M JUST
LOOKING FOR IS I'M LOOKING FOR
PARTNERS.
IN OTHER AREAS TO WORK WITH ME
TO HELP TO ENSURE THAT THAT
RURAL WORKING LANCE DON'T GET
LEFT OUT.
AND THAT'S WHAT'S AND THAT'S AND
THAT'S AND THAT'S WHERE WE'RE
COMING FROM COUNT ME IN ON THAT
EFFORT AND I I KNOW.
YOU DID YOU AYE I DON'T WANT
THAT DISRUPT THEIR COOPERATION
THAT STARTED TO TAKE PLACE IN
HER HEART --
I WOULD JUST ADD THAT YOU KNOW
THIS BILL IS REALLY MODELED
AFTER AFTER A COUPLE OF PROGRAMS
THAT ARE IN EXISTENCE ALREADY
ONE BEING THE COASTAL
CONSERVANCY PROGRAM THAT DOES
CLIMATE READY PROJECT.
I BELIEVE UP INTO YOUR DISTRICT
AND MISTER CHAIR AS WELL AS THE
IN THE NEWLY CREATED FROM
FUNDING LAST YEAR WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD PROJECT.
IT'S IT'S LOOKING TO EXPAND
THOSE TYPES OF ACTIVITIES OTHER
PARTS THE STATE AND DOES
ENVISIONED THAT THERE IS GOING
TO BE COMPATIBILITY WITH THE
PROGRAMS.
THAT THE OPPOSITION WAS JUST
VOICING BUT ALSO WILL NOT TRY TO
CONSTRAIN THE ABILITY OF OUR
DIFFERENT CONSERVANCY IS THE W.
CB AND THE TYPES OF PROJECTS
THEY DO SO --
WERE ACTUALLY LOOKING TO ADD MY
THE NEXT BY PUTTING THIS PROGRAM
IN PLACE [inaudible]
AND THAT'S WHAT I'M LOOKING FOR
YEAH NAM AND AND AND IT BECAUSE
BUT BUT IT DIDN'T IT DIDN'T IT
DIDN'T FEEL IT DIDN'T FEEL LIKE
THAT CERTAINLY THE WAY IT WAS
COMING THROUGH AND CERTAINLY NOT
WITH THE OP.
THE FROM THE OPPOSITION'S
PERSPECTIVE.
SO SO SO RIGHT I THINK OUR OUR
THOUGHT IS THIS [inaudible]
ON FROM A FROM A A STATUTORY
PERSPECTIVE.
THE THAT THEY'RE THE IN ACTUALLY
THEY'RE NOT LOOKING.
FOR ANOTHER BILL REALLY THEY'RE
LOOKING FOR FOR BETTER FUNDING
RIGHT YOU'RE TRYING TO GET A
FAIR SHAKE RIGHT FRANKLY SO IT
SO LET WHY DON'T OUR OFFICES
CIRCLE OF TOGETHER AND TALK SHOP
ABOUT HOW WE CAN ASSIST --
YOU KNOW EFFORT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY GET A DECENT.
I'M NOT A FUNDING ACTING CHAIR
NOT TRYING TO HIJACK YOUR BILL
YEAH I KNOW BUT I I DID YOU HAVE
THE GAVEL IT'S ANYTHING THING
THAT --
ANYTHING OWSLEY WORTHWHILE POINT
YOU'RE BRINGING UP AND I THINK
IT OUGHT TO BE FUN THAT YOU'RE
OFTEN AND LET'S WORK TOGETHER TO
HELP GET SOME FUNDING FOR THEM.
APPRECIATE THAT OUT I LOOK AT
WHAT THEY WERE DE EGGMAN CHAIR
CAN I ADD OR SO MY IMPRESSION OF
THIS.
SURE ABSOLUTELY YEAH --
LISTENING TO YOUR QUESTIONS SO I
FEEL LIKE I THIS IS TAUGHT AND
NOT THOUGH.
BUREAUCRACY ADDING ON
NECESSARILY AND I THINK WE HAVE
A ENOUGH ARE REGULATORY.
A AGENCIES ARE AND THE PROGRAM
SO IN FACT I AND AT THIS TIME I
DIDN'T SEE ANY BENEFITS SELVA
DESPAIR I WOULD HAVE TO POSE.
THE BEAUTY OF THIS BILL IS THAT
IT DOESN'T ACTUALLY IF IT USES
EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE SO USER
CONSERVANCY'S.
ARE ALIVE CONSEVATION BOARD AND
EXIST.
IT'S ACTUALLY NOT.
OPPOSITE THE ADDITIVE TO THE
BUREAUCRACY BUT I I CERTAINLY
RESPECT YOUR POSITION.
ANYONE ELSE ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
MEG SO PUBLIC FOR WILL TO LOOK
FORGOTTEN UPSET EARLIER STAFF
WERE NOT WITH US ON THIS
[inaudible]
YES PLEASE I'M SORRY WHO.
BIGELOW.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN.
HAVING FUN ACTING AS THE
CHAIRMAN TODAY ARE YOU
[inaudible]
IT'S IT'S GREAT HOW IT IT'S A
WONDERFUL THING.
LEVEL.
I THINK THE REAL CONCERN HERE
AND I THINK THE CHAIRMAN WAS
REALLY FOCUSED ON IT.
YOU'RE REALLY ASKING FOR A NEW
BILL. TO GIVE FUNDING TO
EXISTING PROGRAMS.
THAT DON'T HAVE IT OR FIND
THEMSELVES SHORTER OF AND THE
REAL OBJECTIVE OF EACH OF THESE
PROGRAMS ARE OUTLINED IN
PRESENTED HERE TODAY.
IS TO BUY MORE LAND.
AND OUT OF THE HUNDRED ONE
MILLION ACRES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
FARTHER CLOSER 252% OF THE STATE
IS ALREADY PUBLICLY ON AND WHEN
YOU START RATCHETING THAT DOWN.
THERE'S LESS AND LESS FOR
EVERYBODY TO ENJOY IN THIS STATE
BECAUSE THESE PROGRAMS.
THAT'S A FACT BY THE PUBLICLY
OWNED MEANS THAT WE ALL ARE ABLE
TO ENJOY.
THAT'S THE GREAT THING ABOUT
PUBLICLY REALLY LAND IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO TAKE A LOOK AT
SOME OF THESE PROGRAMS YOU'RE
NOT ALLOWED ON THOSE LANDS.
THERE'S REGULATIONS AT BAND
PEOPLE NOT OUT LOUD ON HIGHLAND
THAT THERE.
PRIVATE LANDS ARE PRIVATE LANDS
OWNED BY THE INDIVIDUALS THEY
HAVE RIGHTS.
THAT MUST BE RESPECTED.
AS WE CONTINUE GOING DOWN THIS
PROCESS WE'RE SEEING MORE MORE
THE FARMLAND.
CONSUMED BY THESE DIFFERENT
ENTITIES.
TAKE HIM OFF THE BOOKS AND NO
LONGER SEQUESTERING AND DOING
THE POSITIVE WORK THAT HAS BEEN
DONE.
CREATING PROBLEMS FORCE.
MUCH LIKE THE FIRE THAT'S
BURNING RIGHT NOW AT ELEVEN
THOUSAND PLUS ACRES.
THAT HASN'T BEEN WELL MANAGED BY
THE PUBLIC AGENCIES.
WE'RE GETTING MORE POLLUTION IN
THE AIR.
NO NOT SEQUESTERING.
I THINK WE NEED TO TAKE A WHILE
ONE IS RIGHT HERE.
AND AND REALLY TAKE THE STAND
BACK AND LOOK AT WHAT MISTER
WOOD WAS CITING.
AND SEE HOW WE CAN BETTER DO IT
WITHIN THE CAN FIND MUCH OF THE
EXISTING PROGRAMS THAT WE SHOULD
BE ASKING HOW SUCCESSFUL THEY'VE
BEEN.
JUST SOME THOUGHTS RHETORICAL
NOT REQUIRING AN ANSWER
[inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
WOULD YOU LIKE.
THE MOTION MISTER SO I CAN FIND
THIS RUBIO MISSED MISTER ALLEN
WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE.
BUT I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
THE DISCUSSION I THINK THAT ARE
CONSERVANCY ISN'T ABC BE HAVE A
VERY PROVEN TRACK RECORD WERE
HAPPY TO SHARE INFORMATION WITH
YOU AYE IF YOU'VE GOT.
A DOUBTS OR OR THOUGHTS OR
QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT.
I I AM VERY INTERESTED IN
WORKING WITH THAT THE CHAIR ON
SEE WHAT WE CAN DO TO GET SOME
GINGER A FUNDING.
FOR SOME OF THE RESULTS IN
SUSTAINABLE ACT.
CLIMATE FRIENDLY AG POLICIES
THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED.
AND DOWN WAS PRETTY THE DEBATE
AND AND RESPECT PASSED FIVE OUT.
WE WILL THAT THE BILL DOES ENJOY
A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION THAT WE
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
ECONOMIC MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
THERE WILL BE AYE THERE ARE NO
TECH TECHNICALLY NO AMENDMENTS
YOU'VE AGREED.
MY UNDERSTANDING FROM THE
SUGGESTION SUGGESTIONS AND AND
ONCE AGAIN WE ALSO WE DO LOOK
FOR TO WORKING WITH THE OTHER
UPSWINGS.
MEN SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
EDUARDO GARCIA GALLAGHER.
BIGELOW NO.
BIGELOW NO CARILLO.
CHOI NO CHOI NO CHIU ARE CHIU
AYE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN AYE GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE HARPER.
HARPER NO KALRA.
LEVINE.
MATHIS KNOW ABOUT THE SNOW RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SALAS WOULD I WOULD I
FOR THE FOR COULD YOU NEVER
SPENT A WE HAVE OTHER MEMBERS
HERE THOUGH I DON'T WORK.
AND GOING THAT'S ANNOUNCED
ALRIGHT THIS IS EXCITING.
SO MEMBERS I THINK YOU AND NEXT
WE'RE GONNA.
TALK ABOUT S. B..
TEN SEVENTEEN WHICH SEEKS.
TO INCENTIVIZE CONFERENCE
SWORDFISH FISHING INDUSTRY.
I THE TRANSITION AWAY FROM
HARMFUL DRIFT GILL NETS TOWARD
MORE SUSTAINABLE GEAR TYPES SUCH
AS DEEP THAT BILLY GREER SYSTEMS.
I WHICH IS STILL BY ESTABLISHING
A VOLUNTARY PROGRAM TO BUY BACK
STATE.
DRIFT ON THAT PERMITS IN LARGE
MASTER IF GILLNETS.
USING PUBLIC AND PRIVATE FUNDS.
THE FISHERMEN WHO CHOOSE NOT TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE BUY BACK
PROGRAM WILL BE ALLOWED TO
CONTINUE TO USE DRIFT ON THAT
GEAR FOR THE NEXT FIVE YEARS.
BUT AFTER THAT THESE NOTS WILL
BE PHASED OUT.
I THE CONCERN THAT WE HAVE BEEN --
SOME OF THE MEMBERS WILL BE
AWARE OF THIS BUT THAT BASICALLY
THESE.
THESE GNATS THAT THAT TRIAL THE
OCEAN CAPTURING KILL DOLPHINS
WHALES SEA TURTLE SO MANY MORE
THREATEN ENDANGERED SPECIES AND
I WANNA BE VERY SPECIFIC ABOUT
THIS ACCORDING TO THE NATIONAL
MARINE FISHERIES SERVICE.
BEST AVAILABLE ESTIMATES BETWEEN
TWO THOUSAND ONE THE BEST DATA
WE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA.
BASED SWORDFISH DRIFT GILL NET
FISH WE CAUGHT SEVEN FIFTY THREE
DOLPHINS FIVE HUNDRED SEVEN
SEALS AND SEA LIONS UNDER TWELVE
SEA BIRDS FIFTY THREE WELLS.
THIRTY FIVE SEA TURTLES --
ACCORDING TO THEIR DATA.
IS THE NATIONAL MARINE FISH
SEASON FISHERIES SERVICE ALL OF
THE DATA DOLPHINS WERE KILLED.
AND ONLY A HANDFUL OF THE LARGE
WHALES TURTLES AND SEE LINE'S
ESCAPE WITHOUT SERIOUS INJURY OR
DEATH IN ADDITION.
OVER HUNTER FIFTY THOUSAND FISH
INCLUDING TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
SHARKS.
WERE THROWN OVERBOARD AND THERE
OFTENTIMES THROWN OVERBOARD VERY
DAMAGED.
NOW OPPONENTS POINT TO A SINGLE
YEAR'S DATA WHERE THE DRIFT ON
OFFICIALLY CAPTOR RELEASED A
LIVE. 94% OF THEIR CATCH THAT
SAME YEAR 90% OF THE FISHERY WAS
UNOBSERVED.
BY NOAH AND THE NATIONAL.
OCEANIC ATMOSPHERIC MINISTRATION
FISHERIES AND THERE'S NO WAY OF
KNOWING HOW THE RELEASED ANIMALS
FARED AFTER EXPERIENCING THE
TRAUMA INJURY.
OF CAPTURE AND DRIFT GILL NETS.
LET'S BE CLEAR EVEN A 10% THAT'S
HUNDREDS OF DEAD ANIMALS
DISCARDED OVERBOARD INCLUDING
DOLPHINS BLUE SHARKS VALUABLE
SPORT FISH.
LIKE MARLINS AND TUNA CALIFORNIA
THE ONLY STATE IN THE COUNTRY
ALLOW THIS GEAR STILL EVEN THE
UNITED NATIONS IS BAN ON
INTERNATIONAL WATERS.
A WERE USUALLY THE LEADER ON
THESE KINDS OF ISSUES THIS IS --
THIS TIME MORE ACTION ONE OF THE
LAST USING THIS OUTDATED YEAR
AND IT'S TIME THAT WE CHANGE
THIS.
I S. B. TEN SEVENTEEN AS A
BALANCE REGIONAL APPROACH TO
ENCOURAGE INDUSTRY TO TRANSITION
TOWARD MORE SUSTAINABLE GEAR WE
JUST RECEIVE SUPPORT FROM THE
FISHING GAME.
I COMMISSION AND WE ALSO HAVE
VERY STRONG SUPPORT FROM --
A LARGE NUMBER OF SPORTS
FISHERMEN AND OTHER --
RECREATIONAL FISHER.
AND FISHING ORGANIZATIONS SUCH
AS THE NATIONAL PROFESSIONAL
ANGLERS ASSOCIATION.
SO I WANNA ALSO WANT TO SAY THAT
I'M VERY ENCOURAGED AND I THINK
MY STAFFER TINA FOR WORKING
REALLY HARD OVER THE PAST TWENTY
FOUR HOURS WE'VE BEEN HAVING.
SOME INTENSE I MEETINGS WITH
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING MEMBERS
OF THE FLEET.
ABSENT SOME OF WHOM ARE HERE --
OVER [inaudible]
CAPTAIN --
YOU KNOW --
BUT THEY'VE BEEN MEETING TO
DISCUSS THE BILL AND SEE YOU
KNOW THERE'S SOME COMMON GROUND
THAT CAN BE FOUND.
OUT TO HELP TO PROVIDE THEM WITH
THE INCENTIVES THAT THEY NEED TO
FEEL COMFORTABLE TRANSITIONING
THEIR FLEET Y. I CERTAINLY AM
HOPEFUL THAT THESE TALKS WILL BE
PRODUCTIVE SO.
I ALSO WANT TO THANK MY FELLOW
COAUTHORS ON THIS COMMITTEE MUST
NOT MISS KOREA MISTER CHIU MISS
FRIEDMAN.
MISTER GLORIA MISTER LEVINE.
I'M I'VE GOT WITH ME HERE ATTIRE
BROCA'S FROM THE PEW CHARITABLE
TRUST HAS BEEN WORKING ON THIS
ISSUE FOR A LONG LONG TIME.
A BILL SHOT WITH THE COASTAL CAN
CONSERVATION ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA THEIR NIPPLES SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND I I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MOTION A SECOND PLEASE REQUIRE
HAD [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WHAT ABOUT YOU CHAIRMAN AND?
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
BILL SHED ON THE A FOUNDING
BOARD CHAIRMAN OF THE COASTAL
CONSERVATION ASSOCIATION.
A FOR THIRTY YEARS I WAS
CHAIRMAN OF THE AMERICAN
SPORTFISHING ASSOCIATIONS
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS COMMITTEE --
CURRENTLY EMIT A BOARD MEMBER OF
THE INTERNATIONAL GAME FISH
ASSOCIATION IN A LONGTIME
SUPPORTER OF THE WILD OCEANS.
SO SPECIFICALLY I'M REPRESENTING
THOSE FOUR GROUPS BUT MORE
BROADLY I'M REPRESENTING THE
OVER FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
SALTWATER ANGLERS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA ALONG WITH THE MANY
BUSINESSES THAT.
THE WORKING TO PROTECT THE THE
MARINE RESOURCE IN THE INTERESTS
OF THE ANGLERS.
SO FIRST I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
SENATOR FOR STEPPING UP AND AND
AND PUT THIS BILL TOGETHER TO
BITS.
LONG OVERDUE A HIS LEADERSHIP IS
GOING TO HELP TO NOT ONLY
PROTECT THE COAST.
BUT ALSO PROTECT BUSINESSES AND
NOT OFTEN DEFINE BILLS IT THAT
THEY HAVE AN INTEREST IN THE
RESOURCE IN THE COAST AND ALSO
BUSINESS THIS ONE DOES.
I AM WAY TOO FAMILIAR.
WITH JEFF GILLNETS.
AND I'LL CONVEY THAT IN A BRIEF
STORY [inaudible]
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR THE
LONGTIME GILLNET CAPTAIN.
CAME TO ME WITH VIDEO THAT HE
TOOK ON HIS BOAT THE LAST FOUR
MONTHS CITY FINISHED.
AND WHAT WAS ON THAT VIDEO IS
WHAT THE CENTER JUST DESCRIBED.
A DEAD ONE DID WELL NUMEROUS
DOLPHINS [inaudible]
SHARKS MARLON TURTLES IN A WHOLE
LOT OF OTHER FISH.
CAUGHT IN FOUR MONTHS.
THE REASON HE DID THIS.
HE SAYS BILL I DEVELOP A
CONSCIENCE.
I'M GETTING OUT OF THIS BUSINESS.
AND IN THE LAST FOUR MONTHS THIS
TO SHOW THE DAMAGE.
AND WHAT THE REST THE WORLD TO
KNOW WHAT I'M TURN THIS FOOTAGE
OVER YOU.
AND I JUST ASK THAT YOU MAKE IT
AVAILABLE SO THAT OTHERS CAN
UNDERSTAND WHAT HAPPENS WITH
WITH THE USE OF GILLNETS.
NOW TWENTY FIVE YEARS LATER
[inaudible]
WE FINALLY.
WE FINALLY HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO DO THE RIGHT THING AND TO
REMOVE THIS GEAR.
FROM THE COAST [inaudible]
THE PACIFIC.
FISHERIES MANAGEMENT COUNCIL
SPENT MANY MANY MANY YEARS
TRYING TO RESOLVE THIS PROBLEM
AND TRUST ME I'VE BEEN WORKING
ON THIS STUFF FOR A LIFETIME.
IT'S A PROBLEM AND IT NEEDS A
SOLUTION.
THEY CAME UP WITH UP BE PROVED A
PLAN THAT WOULD HAVE FORCED TO
FLEE TO THE FISH CLEAN.
OR GO AWAY.
WELL.
THAT WAS A THAT WAS A GREAT
EFFORT BUT LAST SUMMER NO
FISHERIES PULL THAT OFF THE
TABLE.
SO HERE WE ARE TODAY WERE FORCED
BACK TO SQUARE.
ONE AND THIS BILL WILL HELP TO
RESOLVE THE PROBLEM.
SO S. B. TEN SEVENTEEN IT'S FAIR
IT'S REASONABLE.
IT ADDRESSES THE OVERRIDING
ISSUE OF REDUCING BYCATCH AND
THAT'S REALLY THE ISSUE HERE
THERE'S JUST WAY TOO MUCH
BYCATCH.
THE COMPENSATES FISHERMEN FOR
SURRENDERING THE GILL NETS IT
PROVIDES A PATHWAY WITH DEEP SET
BUOY YEAR TO A NEW MORE
SUSTAINABLE AND PROFITABLE TYPE
OF FISHING GEAR --
AND TRY TO STAFF YOU ALL TO JOIN.
NOT ONLY ME BUT THE OVER FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND RECREATIONAL
FISHERMEN THE STATE MANY
BUSINESSES LIKE MY OWN.
THE REALLY NEED THIS TO TAKE
PLACE SO THANK YOU.
INVESTMENT THINK IT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS TARA BROCK WITH THAT FEW
TERRIBLE TRUSTS.
FIRST WE ALSO WANT TO THANK
SENATOR ALLEN AND HIS STAFF FOR
WORKING TO FIND A SOLUTION THAT
WOULD TRANSITION CALIFORNIA
SWORDFISH FISHERY.
AWAY FROM THE USE OF DRIFT ALL
THAT GEAR WHICH ACCORDING TO A
PEW COMMISSION PAUL IS SUPPORTED
BY 87% OF CALIFORNIA VOTERS.
THE GOOD NEWS AS YOU'VE HEARD IS
THAT THERE IS AN ALTERNATIVE TO
DRIVE COMMENTS DEVELOPED BY THE
PFLEGER INSTITUTE OF
ENVIRONMENTAL RESEARCH IN
OCEANSIDE WITH FUNDING FROM THE
STATE'S OCEAN PROTECTION COUNCIL.
AND FROM PEW AMONG OTHERS.
PIERRE BEGAN DEVELOPING DEEP
SEPARATE YOUR TO TARGET START
FISH OFF THE WEST COAST AND
TWENTY TEN THE RESULTS ARE
OUTSTANDING WITH 98%.
OF THEM OF THE CATCH BEING
MARKETABLE AND A VAST MAJORITY
OF THE CATCH BEING SORT FETCH.
ESSENTIALLY PIERRE FIGURED OUT
HOW TO TARGET SWORDFISH DURING
THE DAY WHEN THEY'RE FEEDING BY
THEMSELVES AND COLD DEEP WATER
AWAY FROM THE OTHER SPECIES AT
THE SURFACE THAT OFTEN --
AND UP AND JUST GO NUTS.
DEEP SEPARATE HERE HAS BEEN
DEPLOYED IN WATERS OFF
CALIFORNIA FOR OVER SEVEN YEARS
THIS IS PROVIDED OVER A THOUSAND
FISHING DAYS WORTH OF DATA WHICH
EQUATES TO OVER. EIGHT THOUSAND
HOURS OF ON THE WATER TRIALS.
IT HAS BEEN PROVEN TO PROFITABLY
CUT SWORDFISH AT COMMERCIAL
RATES WITH MINIMAL BI CATCH
WHILE ACTIVE TENDING OF THE GEAR
HAS LED TO A 100% OF THE BY
CATCH RELEASED ALIVE WITHIN
MINUTES.
FURTHER BOYCOTT SWORDFISH CAN
GET NEARLY DOUBLE THE PRICE OF
SORT FISH CAUGHT WOULD TRIP DOWN
THAT'S BECAUSE OF THE HIGHER
QUALITY PRODUCT PRODUCT AND THE
ABILITY TO FISH AT TIMES AND IN
AREAS WHERE DRAFT ON THAT
FISHING IS RESTRICTED DUE TO
CONSERVATION CONCERNS.
LAST YEAR THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE CAN BE MEMBERS OF
THE DRAFT ON THAT FLEET AND THE
NGO COMMUNITY WITH THE INTENT TO
NEGOTIATE A PILE OF STATE DRIFT
ON THAT PERMITS.
Q. PARTICIPATED IN THESE
CONVERSATIONS CONVERSATIONS AND
WE WERE HOPEFUL THAT A
RESOLUTION COULD BE FOUND BUT A
PACKAGE WAS NEVER FINALIZED.
AND WE REMAIN COMMITTED TO
FINDING A PATH FORWARD THAT
TRANSITIONS CALIFORNIA AWAY FROM
THE YOU SUBJECT GóMEZ WHILE
OFFERING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
FISHERMEN AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH SENATOR ALLEN.
THE INDUSTRY AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS TO ACHIEVE THAT
GOAL.
WE ASK YOU TO SUPPORT SB TEN
SEVENTEEN TODAY AND AS IT MOVES
THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
HELLO MY NAME'S LEO SEARCHES
WITH SOCIAL COMPASSION AND
LEGISLATION FROM LOS ANGELES IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB TEN
SEVENTEEN WERE ALSO WORKING TO
HELP PRODUCE WELL AND SEALED
TURTLE ENTANGLEMENTS.
AND WE'RE VERY EXCITED BUT THE
SEVEN POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
THAT WAS JUST REYES TO GO TO THE
OCEAN --
PROTECTION COUNCIL FOR SEA
TURTLE IN WELL ENTANGLEMENTS AND
I THINK THAT MAYBE SOME OF THAT
MONEY CAN HELP TO BUY ARE GONE
WHILE THE CONTRACTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
S. NAME AND ORGANIZATION GOOD
MORNING A FISH RESTAURANT
SAUSALITO CALIFORNIA AND TO BUY
SEE WHOLESALE SAN FRANCISCO
CALIFORNIA.
A INTO TREMENDOUS SUPPORT.
OF MY TO COMPANIES RESPOSIBLE
FOR PUTTING TWO AND A HALF
MILLION PORTIONS OF SEAFOOD IN
FRONT OF CUSTOMERS EVERY YEAR
AND HAVE NEVER ONCE HAD ANYONE
COMPLAIN THE FACT THAT WE DON'T
SELL SWORDFISH ARE DRAFT MIGUEL
THAT SORT FISH.
AND ORANGEMEN TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
S. NAME AND ORGANIZATION PLEASE
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS JENNIFER FEARING HERE
TODAY IN SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE THE SAN
FRANCISCO SPCA THE SAN DIEGO
HUMANE SOCIETY AND ALSO ON
BEHALF OF A SCHOOL.
THINK YOU THINK.
THANK YOU OBJECT CHESTER
SPEAKING ON BEHALF AND OF
OCEANIA AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU SENATOR THANK YOU.
A MAN ON THE F. OF SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
GENEVIEVE ABBOTT ON ON BEHALF OF
HILL THE BAY SURFRIDER
FOUNDATION WILD COAST AND EIGHT
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE CLEAN SEE
FLOPPING COALITION AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING KRISTIN MONTHS OUT
WITH THE CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL
DIVERSITY IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
THE MONTGOMERY FOR SEA WORLD IN
SAN DIEGO IN SUPPORT.
MORNING I KEY SONICARE
CONSTITUENT OF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHU.
AND ALSO A LAW STUDENT AT
HASTINGS AND INS STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
THE SHUTTLE GOV ON BEHALF OF THE
COMMENSURATE INDICTED STATES
STRONG SUPPORT.
I SEE BERNIE SHAW POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR TURTLE ISLAND
RESTORATION NETWORK ALSO IN
STRONG SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SCOTT WALLIN CITIZEN IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF REDUCING THE AMOUNT
OF BI CATCH WE ALL KNOW THAT
THIS IS SOMETHING WE CAN'T LIVE
WITH.
HAVING HEARD THE TESTIMONY ABOUT.
THE AWFULNESS OF THIS I HOPE
THAT YOU'LL VOTE FOR THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING DOMINIK MANGINI A
LIFELONG DALY CITY RESIDENT AND
A CURRENT STUDENT AT AT USS
GOLAN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING TIFFANI LONG --
ENVIRONMENTAL LAWYER FROM
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG STRONG
SUPPORT I HOPE WE TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO BRING UP THE
THROUGH THE MARINE MAMMAL
PROTECTION ACT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
YEAH.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS LINDA
BROWN OF FROM EL DORADO COUNTY
AND I'M A MEMBER OF THE SEA
TURTLE OF SOCIETY AND I BY
IMPAIR SUPPORT I HOPE. FOR S. B.
ONE OF ONE SEVEN AND ALL THAT
THAT TO NOTE THAT MARINE MAMMALS
ARE ON THE LINE AND THEY NEED
LEGAL PROTECTION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS KEN
WILL ON THE RESIDENT FREMONT
CALIFORNIA AND A VOLUNTEER WITH
VARIOUS CONSERVATION GROUPS AND
I'M HERE TO URGE YOU TO STRONG
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU
[inaudible]
SO MUCH ANYONE ELSE.
SEEING NO ONE DOES ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION
.
SORRY SORRY FOR THE DELAY.
BROUGHT ROSS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FISHERIES AND SEAFOOD
INSTITUTE A NUMBER OF COMMERCIAL
FISHING ORGANIZATIONS.
A NUMBER OF CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE
FROM COASTAL AREAS.
IT'S IT'S ALMOST AMAZING HOW
THIS ISSUE HAS BALLOONED INTO
[inaudible]
SUCH A IT'S A BIG ISSUE.
THE FISHERMEN ARE REGULATEDBY
THE NATIONAL IN FISHERIES
SERVICE AFTER AN EXHAUSTIVE
PROCESS.
OF THE PACIFIC FISHERY
MANAGEMENT COUNCIL.
WE SPEND AN HOUR ON A BILL THEY
SPEND FOUR DAYS.
A EVERY OTHER MONTH ON THESE
ISSUES.
I'VE HANDED OUT A FACT SHEET.
THAT ACTUALLY EXPLAINS WHAT WE
ARE DOING.
AND ON THE SECOND PAGE YOU'LL
SEE.
THE IMPACTS ON MARINE MAMMALS.
THE NATIONAL IN FISHERIES
SERVICE PREPARED TO DOCUMENT.
AND MANY DOCUMENTS.
AND THE NATIONALLY FISHERIES
SERVICE IS THE PLATINUM STANDARD.
A FISHERY MANAGEMENT IN THE
WORLD.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND GAME
IN FACT SEATED.
THE AUTHORITY TO THEM.
IT'S A HIGHLY MIGRATORY SPECIES.
AND THAT IS ALL TAKING PLACE IN
FEDERAL WATERS.
THE NAZARIAN FISHERIES SERVICE.
HAS HAS --
RECOGNIZE THAT IT'S BECOME
UNUSUAL. FOR TURTLES LARGE
WHALES AND OTHER MARINE MAMMALS
TO BE INJURED OR KILLED IN A
DRIFT GILL NET FISHERY.
DRAW YOUR ATTENTION TO THE
MIDDLE OF THE PAGE OF THE SECOND
PAGE OF I GAVE YOU.
AND YOU'LL SEE THE IMPACTS ON
ALL BEAKED WHALES.
BY THE CALIFORNIA DRIFT GILL NET
FISHERY FROM.
NINETEEN NINETY TO TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN AND YOU'LL NOTICE IT'S
GONE FROM A HIGH OF SOME.
FIFTY ANIMALS TO VIRTUALLY
NOTHING.
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT THE
IMPACTS ON SHORT BE COMMON
DOLPHINS.
HAS GONE FROM AS MANY AS FOUR
HUNDRED TO AS LITTLE AS TEN WHY
DID THIS HAPPEN.
BECAUSE OF THE ADAPTIVE
MANAGEMENT OF THE NATURAL
FISHERIES SERVICE.
THROUGH THE PACIFIC FISHERY
MANAGEMENT COUNCIL.
THEY DETERMINED THAT TO AVOID
TAKING SEA TURTLES AND I'LL
MENTION THAT WOULD ONE SEA
TURTLE HAS BEEN DOCUMENTED.
BY OBSERVERS FROM THE NATIONALLY
FISHERIES SERVICE HAS BEEN TAKEN
SINCE. NINETEEN NINETY NINE ONE
AND THE THE REASON FOR THAT IS
THE TURTLE CONSERVATION AREA.
WHICH IS A HUGE AREA OF THE
OCEAN.
WAS MADE OFF LIMITS AND WITH A
FISHERMAN SUPPORT. TO USING
DRIFT GILL NETS IN THAT AREA
WHEN THE TURTLES ARE COMING OR
GOING [inaudible]
THE FISHERMEN AND THE MANAGERS
DEVELOPED MESH SIZE MANAGEMENT
SO THAT ONLY CERTAIN TYPES OF
ANIMALS ARE TAKEN THOSE ARE
SWORDFISH [inaudible]
NOT MARLON [inaudible]
SHARK.
OPALA LIEU OF OUR TUNERS.
WE CALL THE MARKET NETS THEY
BRING IN FRESH FISH. TO SOME
THIRTY NINE MILLION CONSUMERS
WHO MIGHT ENJOY SEAFOOD.
WE HAVE AREA CLOSURES WE HAVE
TIME CLOSURES WE HAVE THE THE
NUMBER OF CONSERVATION MEASURES
IN PLACE [inaudible]
THAT HAVE.
SO SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCED THE
TAKE OF INCIDENTAL.
CATCH OR OR A MARINE MAMMALS
[inaudible]
CETACEANS.
PINNIPEDS AND THE TURTLES A
TURTLE TAKE A COURSE IS
VIRTUALLY NOTHING HOW DO WE DO
THAT IN ADDITION.
THE NETS ARE NO LONGER ON THE
SURFACE.
WE'VE DROPPED THEM THIRTY SIX
BELOW THE SURFACE.
WHERE THE FISH ARE AND THE
MARINE MAMMALS ARE NOT?
THE AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF AND HIS
SUPPORTERS HAVE SAID WE HAVE A
GREAT IDEA WE'RE GOING TO
TRANSITION YOU WERE GOING TO BUY
YOU OFFER BY YOU OUT.
NEVER GONNA TRANSITION YOU TO
TYPESET WEEK HERE.
IT'S NOT AUTHORIZED BY THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
IT'S NOT EVEN AUTHORIZED BY THE
NATIONAL RATE FISHERIES SERVICE
THEY HAVE SOME EXPERIMENTAL.
WORK THAT IS BEING DONE.
BUT HERE'S WHAT DOESN'T HAPPEN
USE DEEP SET BUT WE CARE.
YOU DON'T CATCH THE SHARK THE
LOOP ARE THE OPA THE TUNERS.
SO IN ESSENCE YOU MAKE FIVE
TIMES LESS MONEY.
USING THE DEEP SEPARATE HERE AS
YOU DO YOU SING THE NETS WE ALL
KNOW THAT THAT'S CATCH FISH.
AND THAT IS WHAT THESE THAT'S TO
THE WAY EVERY OTHER NET US.
IT WAS TAKEN STEPS TO REDUCE THE
TAKE OF OF MARINE MAMMALS AND
OTHER THINGS.
AND THEN LASTLY.
SENATOR I BELIEVE SAID.
THAT THAT WE ARE TRAWLING THE
OCEAN WITH THESE NETS THESE NETS
ARE STATIONARY THEY'RE HOOKED OF
THE BOAT AND THE DRAFT RIGHT
BEHIND THE VOTE.
WE ARE NOT TRAWLING THAT'S A
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT TYPE OF NET.
THE DIFFERENT FISHERY THE
CATCHES DIFFERENT KINDS OF FISH.
AND LASTLY THE THEY SAY THEY
HAVE MONIES. TWO TRANSITION THE
FISHERMEN.
SO YOU'RE GONNA GIVE A FISHERMAN
WHOSE FISH FOR FORTY YEARS.
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS GO
WAY GOOD LUCK ON GETTING THESE
EXPERIMENTAL PERMITS.
THAT'S NOT ENOUGH MONEY.
MONEY THERE'S NO MONEY.
THERE IS NO MONEY IN THIS BILL
THERE'S NO FUNDING IN THIS BILL.
FOR THE FISHERMEN.
NOR TO THE PEOPLE THAT THEY SELL
[inaudible]
TO PROCESSOR.
AND THE PLANT WORKERS.
THEY WON'T HAVE SEAFOOD IF THIS
BILL GOES THROUGH.
SO THEY'D TAKE US DOWN OF A ROAD.
WITH THE NOTHING AT THE END OF
THE ROAD.
AND WE ASK YOU KNOW VOTE.
OTHER OTHER WITNESSES I COULD
YEAH -- THE
MORNING HAVE TO BEAR WITH NO
NAMES AUSTIN BROWN OF THE
FISHERMEN BEAR WITH ME IT'S MY
FIRST TIME SO I DIDN'T GREAT NO
PROBLEM.
THIS IS A CATEGORY TWO FISHERY.
WHICH IS IT'S IS SUBSTANTIALLY
CLEAN ITSELF AND WE'VE BEEN --
A GENTLEMAN EARLIER SAID THAT
AND IN --
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR THAT THE IT
WAS A VIDEO AND THIS GUY SAID HE
HAD A CONSCIENCE WHILE AND IN
NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN FINGERS
AND EXTENDERS WERE.
WERE --
APPLIED IMPLEMENTED INTO THE
NETS AND THE NETS WERE A
BASICALLY THEY THEY EXTENDED
THEM AND THEY PUT TEN YEARS THAT
THAT --
PUSHED MARINE MAMMALS AWAY YOU
KNOW THAT THEY WERE ATTRACTED TO
IT.
NOT THERE ANYWAY BUT NO MY MY
FAMILY OWNS.
A COMPANY AND IN SAN DIEGO OR
I'M FOURTH GENERATION FISHING
AND WE'VE.
COMPLETELY DEPENDENT ON THAT
FISHERY.
AND I'M THIRTY YEARS OLD I PLAN
ON DOING THIS FOR THIRTY TO
FORTY YEARS AT LEAST --
SO THIS IF THIS BILL PASSES ON
UNSCREWED BASICALLY --
BUT I WANTED I WANTED YOU KNOW.
THE YOU NOT A TO GO THROUGH A
COUPLE THINGS --
OR ONE ONE MAJOR THING --
THE SENATOR IN THE SUPPORTERS --
HAVE EXTRA AT HAVE BULLIED THE
FLEET.
AND TO THE POINT WHERE GUYS
WON'T SHOW UP --
THREE PERSONAL FRIENDS OF MINE
HAVE GOTTEN DEATH THREATS.
UP FROM THE SUPPORT AND THEIR
WIVES --
THERE'S SOMETHING THAT --
IS ATTACHED TWO DID YOU GIVE
THIS YEAH --
IF YOU DON'T MIND I'D I'D LIKE
TO READ IT THAT'S ALRIGHT WITH
YOU -- THIS
ACTUALLY I WAS AT THE PACIFIC
FISHERIES MANAGEMENT COUNCIL --
UP IN IN SPOKANE RECENTLY AND A
WHEAT WE SHARE THIS WITH THE
COUNCIL --
ON MAY TWENTY FOURTH AN ARTICLE
IN THE MARIN INDEPENDENT JOURNAL.
WHICH PROVIDED INFORMATION ON
THE FISHERMEN AND THE VESSEL
LOCATIONS --
ON MAY TWENTY FIFTH ONE OF OUR
MEMBERS GARY BURKE I RECEIVED A
DEATH THREAT SHORTLY AFTER THIS
APPEARANCE HIS APPEARANCE.
ON THE ON THE NBC --
NBC NEWS RELATED TO S. B. TENS
TEN SEVENTEEN WITH THE SENATOR.
OF THE FISHING VESSEL BOTCH IT
ONE OF THE VESSELS MENTIONED IN
THE ABOVE ARTICLE --
AND USE THE NEGATIVE PROPAGANDA
VIDEO SANK AT THE DOCK.
ON JUNE SECOND UNDER CSUS A
SUSPICIOUS CIRCUMSTANCES.
IT'S BEING INVESTED BY INVESTED
ABOUT THE COAST GUARD AND
HOMELAND SECURITY --
ACTUALLY WAS SABOTAGED THE BOAT
WAS SUNK WITH BY A THROUGH HOLE.
ARMED THE CAMERAMEN ON THE ABOVE
ARE TRUE AND OTHER VESSELS
UTILIZING THE ATTACK ON THE FISH
WE GAINED ACCESS TO THE VESSEL.
UNDER FALSE PRETENSES AND IS
ANOTHER PERMIT HOLDER.
WE AWARE OF THESE INCIDENTS AND
DON'T ASSUME THEY'RE THE ONLY
ONES.
AND WE BELIEVE THIS IS
UNACCEPTABLE.
AT A DIRECT RESULT OF THE
REPEATED ATTACKS ON CERTAIN
GROUPS --
VILIFYING THE DRIFT GILL NET
FISHERY AND THE FISHERMEN.
WE BELIEVE THIS MAY HAVE AMPLE
THE ECO TERRORIST FOR SEEKING
VIGILANTE JUSTICE AND I'D BUY
BIG PLEASE DON'T.
FEES NO VOTE ON THIS BILL SO
THANK YOU.
OTHERS THAT YOU WANTED.
DUMP ON DEMOCRATS ON FISH AND
SWORDFISH FOR QUITE A FEW YEARS.
I'M ALSO A DEEP SET BURGER
FISHERMEN DEL.
AND ON THAT EXPERIMENTAL FOR THE
LAST FOUR YEARS NOW [inaudible]
A IT'S HAS SOME POTENTIAL BUT
THERE'S A LOT OF GET NEGATIVES
IT'S NOT GOING TO SUPPORT A BIG
BOAT.
AT ALL IT'S JUST THERE
[inaudible]
THEY'RE NOT.
YOU CAN'T AND YOU GOTTA DRIVE UP
ON THESE VERGE THEY CAN BACK UP
WHAT WE DO.
SO THEY NEED ANOTHER ANOTHER
AVENUE [inaudible]
AND THAT NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED.
A ALSO WITH THE DEEP SEPARATE
YOUR RIGHT NOW IT'S A THE EFP.
THE FDA'S ARE HANDED OUT TO
ANYBODY.
YOU GUYS CAN GET.
AND WERE TOTALLY AGAINST THAT
THE THEY HAVEN'T REALLY
ADDRESSED --
THAT FOR THE GILL NET FISHERMEN.
THEY WANT TO TRANSITION OF THAT.
BECAUSE LEFT THEM OUT OF IT
[inaudible]
BUT THE THE FDA'S OTHER STUDENTS
TO DENNIS.
WITH SANTA BARBARA.
THERE'S TO RUSSIANS THAT AREN'T
EVEN US CITIZENS THAT DEBT
RECEIVE THESE YUPPIES.
SO YOU CAN IMAGINE WHAT. SIXTY
OF PEAS ARE GONNA DO WHEN WE
HAVE A LIMITED IT WE WERE A NOW
LIVE IN A TREE WERE LIMITED
ENTRY ON THE YOUNG THAT FISHERY.
AND THEN WE WANT TO HAVE AN OPEN
ACCESS.
TO THREE IT'S JUST IT'S IT
DOESN'T DOESN'T WORK WHEN
ANYTHING'S HANDED OUT FOR FREE.
PEOPLE DON'T USUALLY.
TAKE IT TOO WELL IT IS DO WHAT
THEY WANT WITH IT.
SO WHAT I DO THINK IT WOULD THAT
COULD BE PUT IN THE BILL AND
STRESSED THAT --
IS FOR THE SORT FISHERMEN THAT
ARE THAT ARE GONNA.
PROTECT OUR FISHERY TRY TO GET A
GOOD MARKET PRICE FOR IT.
AND NOT USES AS A TAX WRITE OFF
LIKE SOME OF THESE OTHER PEOPLE
WOULD.
I THINK THAT WOULD BE GREAT.
ALSO IS THAT --
AS THE BILL STANDS NOW.
BUT ON THE BUY OUT I DON'T THINK
OF MANY.
ACTIVE SORT VETERANS WILL GO FOR
IT.
A A DISTANT KEEPOD FISHING.
AND LET'S SEE WHAT HAPPENS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AND IT AND I SAID FAIRNESS TO
THE PROPONENTS AYE AYE.
THE NEXT ONE IS JUST YOUR NAME
AND FOR THAT I'M SORRY IDEA.
WE HAD WE HAD TWO WITNESSES
APPEAR AND I'VE GIVEN AN OPTION
TO SPEAK SO THAT'S FINE TIMOLOL
QUE IN STRONG OPPOSITION THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION YOU KNOW.
SEEN KNOWN WILL BRING IT BACK --
TO COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
MISTER HARPER.
IF YOU CAN HELP ME OUT.
SOME ISSUES CYCLE AND RECYCLE
OVER AND OVER AGAIN [inaudible]
AND WHEN I SAW THIS BILL I WAS
THINKING I REMEMBER THIS ISSUE
BEFORE.
THIS WAS ISSUED BY ADDRESSED BY
THE VOTERS BACK IN.
NINETEEN NINETY SO JUST DESSERT
FOR LOGISTICS DO WE HAVE
[inaudible] TO INTO --
FOR OPPOSITION INDEPENDENT
DEFENSE GRAFTON.
WITNESSES BUT SO BACK IN
NINETEEN NINETY ON THE
CALIFORNIA PROPOSITION.
ONE THIRTY TWO THERE WAS ON THE
BALLOT.
A CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT TO
PROHIBIT --
GILL NETS.
BOB PROPOSITION ONE THIRTY TO
BAN THE USE A GILL NETS AND
TRAVEL THAT'S BEGINNING IN
JANUARY FIRST NINETEEN NINETY
FOUR COASTAL.
WATERS OF CENTRAL AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
I IMPOSE ADDITIONAL FEES EXCEPT
FOR SO IF YOU CAN HELP EXPLAIN.
WHY IS THIS BILL DIFFERENT?
THEN EXISTING LAW --
BECAUSE I THINK THAT MOST VOTERS
MAY PERCEIVE HAY HAVEN'T WE
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE ALREADY WHAT
WHAT WHAT IS THIS ABOUT.
YEAH BUT I'D LOVE TO TAKE THAT
BECAUSE I'M.
THE AND IN --
NINETEEN NINETY THERE IS AN
EFFORT BY DORIS ALLEN TO TRY TO
GET THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE A
BAN ON SET NET SO THAT THE
INSHORE GILLNET STILL THE SAME
BASIC PICKING TYPE TO GILL NET.
AND UP THERE WE HAD A COMMITTEE
OF SEVEN PEOPLE.
I WAS ONE OF THOSE SEVEN PEOPLE
THAT DROVE THAT EFFORT WE
ULTIMATELY WENT --
TO TO THE PROPOSITION BECAUSE WE
CAN GET IT DONE THROUGH THE
STATE.
AND SITTING HERE TODAY LISTENING
TO THESE PEOPLE TALK.
IT BRINGS ME BACK TO NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE IN NINETY ONE WE DID
IT WITH THE INSHORE GONE THAT'S
SO MUCH SMOKE IN MIRRORS SO MUCH
MORE.
FAULT INFORMATION ABOUT THE
HORRORS OF KNOW HOW HORRIBLE
WILL BE IF WE GET RID OF THESE
ENSURE GILLNETS WHICH WE DID
WITH PROPOSITION. ONE THIRTY TWO
THAT THAT THAT KEEPS THE GILL
NETS OUT OF THE YEAR CALIFORNIA
WATERS OUT TO THREE MILES.
IT'S THE SAME THING ALL OVER
AGAIN BUT IT'S A IT'S IT'S IT'S
A SIMILAR DEAR BOTH IGGY ARNETT
OF BOTH THE GILL NET.
THE TYPE OF UNITS WERE TALKING
ABOUT NOW OR THAT DRIFT GILL
NETS ARE ATTACHED TO THE BOAT.
THAT ARE TARGETED TO CATCH
LARGER --
NEAR SHORE GILL NETS WERE TO
CATCH SMALLER FISH INSHORE --
BOTH HIGHLY DESTRUCTIVE.
KNOWN TO BE HIGH DESTRUCTIVE IN
IN DAMAGING TO THE RESOURCE
THAT'S WHY EVERY OTHER STATE IN
THE UNION HAS BANNED THE USE OF
DRIFT GILL NETS.
EVERYONE.
SO IF I CAN CLARIFY SO.
THAT BALLOT INITIATIVE
[inaudible]
CARE OF GILL NETS WITHIN THREE
MILES WITH IN STATE WATERS.
IS THIS TRYING TO IMPOSE A
CALIFORNIA STANDARD ON FEDERAL
WATERS COMPLETE PLEASE HELP
CLARIFY NO IT'S REALLY PUT IS
POSING A A STANDARD ON A SIMILAR
GEAR TYPE USED IN A DIFFERENT
WAY.
A DRIFT NET AS OPPOSED TO A SET
NET.
SO THIS BILL IS SUPPOSED TO ONLY.
THE OTHER THIS BILL DOES NOT IT
WATERS OR HAD FOR FEDERAL WATERS.
IN FEDERAL WATERS.
OUT AT TWO HUNDRED MILES WHAT
HAPPENS OUTSIDE TO IN MILES WE
CAN'T -- WE
CAN'T CONTROL HERE WE HAVE
JURISDICTION OVER FEDERAL WATERS
FOR A FOR A FOR A BILL.
YES UNDER UNDER THE THE
CONSORTIUM THAT [inaudible]
DATE ADDED.
THAT THE FISH BUSIED THIS
FISHERIES CONSORTIUM WE DO HAVE
WE GET POWER. TO DO THIS
ENTERTAINING.
I THAT HAD.
HOW CONSULTANT FEDERAL SOURCES
ON?
BIGGEST HARPER OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE WISH TO ASK
QUESTIONS OF DUCK CHOI.
THANK YOU ARE LISTENING TO A
BOOK SIZE SO I'M NOT REALLY
FAMILIAR WITH THE FISHERIES
INDUSTRY AND UP PARTICULARLY --
KID AT THE IN FACT SO.
BUT THEY ARE LISTENING TO YOU.
IDEA.
HAVE A QUESTION NOT REGARDING
THE THE DROP WELL OF WAY THOSE
ARE AND ARE NOW DOLPHIN.
CAUGHT BY IDEAS ARE.
ARE GETTING AT THE FISHING.
IT HAS GONE DOWN DRAMATICALLY --
Y. THE NUMBER.
OUR IS GOING DOWN --
THAT WOULD BE MY OF FIRST
QUESTION NOT TWO OPPONENTS ARE
AND THEN NOT IF FOR THIS IS TRUE.
DATA INCORRECT DATA THEN NOT WHY
WOULD THIS BE IT WOULD BE
NECESSARY OUT KNOCKED ASK --
ON SENATOR I'M NOT OUT.
CAN YOU ANSWER FIRST THOUGHT WHY
HE THANK YOU HOWARD LISTA
TECHNOLOGY HAS IMPROVED THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE QUESTION --
I'D ADD THAT THE MARINE MAMMAL
POPULATIONS HAVE EXPLODED.
IN THE SAME PERIOD THAT WE HAVE
GONE DOWN TO VIRTUALLY NO TAKE
AND THAT'S BECAUSE OF THE P.
AREA RESTRICTIONS THE SENT OF
THE NET FLOATING ON THE SURFACE
OF THE WATER.
BY SOME FORTY FEET BY MESH SIZE
MANAGEMENT.
BY AREA CLOSURE BY PINNERS WHICH
MAKE NOISES.
THAT LED THE WHALES IN THE OTHER
CETACEANS KNOW.
THERE'S SOMETHING.
HERE THAT YOU SHOULD PAY
ATTENTION TO AND THEY AVOID IT.
SO IT'S WORKING WITH THE
MANAGEMENT WITHIN THE WITH THE
BIOLOGISTS IN THE MANAGERS WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO ACHIEVE THIS
DRAMATIC REDUCTION.
THAT THAT ALL SOUNDS VERY GOOD.
BUT THE THE REASON THAT THE
METAL TAKE IS DOWN [inaudible]
IS.
LOOK AT THE NUMBER SOARED FISH
WERE CAUGHT IN IN AT THE HEIGHT.
OVER TWO THOUSAND METRIC TONS
[inaudible]
TODAY. SEVENTY EIGHT METRIC TONS.
SO THE THE THE THE ACTIVITY.
IT'S GONE WAY DOWN.
AND SO YOU ABOUT LESS FISH
CAUGHT AND YOU'VE GOT LESS
MAMMALS CUTS NOT NOT THAT THE
KITCHEN NECESSARY THE KITCHEN SO
ME LESS MAMMALS PER SET.
THERE'S JUST A LOT LESS SETS OUT
THERE BECAUSE AS IT SHOULD BE
THAT WHOLE EFFORT HAS BEEN
SQUEEZED DOWN AS IT SHOULD BE.
I KNOW THE FOLKS COMPUTER BEEN
STUDYING THIS AND HAVE SOME DATA.
SURE YEAH THEN I MEAN WE WILL
ACKNOWLEDGE AT THE FLEET HAS --
MADE EFFORTS TO REDUCE BI CATCH
AND PINNERS WERE VERY SUCCESSFUL
AT REDUCING BEAKED WHALE CATCH.
I'M NOT ONLY HAS THE EFFORT ON
DOWN BUT WE ARE STILL SEEN
HUNDREDS OF DOLPHINS AND OTHER
MAMMALS CAUGHT IN THIS FISHERY I
THINK US UNDER ALAN GIVE YOU
SOME STATISTICS IN THE BEGINNING --
THE FLEET HAS MADE EFFORTS BUT
WE'RE STILL SEEING THESE REALLY
HIGH UNACCEPTABLE LEVEL THE BY
CATCH FURTHER ONLY LESS THAN ONE
IN FIVE SETS IN THIS FISHERY.
HAVE BEEN OBSERVED OVER THE LAST
TEN YEARS ON AVERAGE SO WE ARE
NOT.
CERTAIN ON WHAT'S GOING ON IN
THE OTHER FOUR SETS THAT ARE NOT
CARING I'M BORN OBSERVERS ALL WE
KNOW IS WHAT WE SEE THROUGH
OBSERVER COVERAGE AND CAN
EXTRAPOLATE OR DO OUR BEST GAS
AT ESTIMATING.
WHAT THE BY CATCH IS IN THIS
FISHERY SO THOSE ARE SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT ARE STILL LINGERING
[inaudible]
GOOD.
SO WHICH STARTED CHOI IDEA HOW
WOULD ADDRESS DATA IS THAT
CORRECT THAT ONCE I SAYS HAVE
VERY LITTLE.
NOW YOU SAY THE US ARE STILL A
LOT.
I THINK THAT'S UP TO US TO
DECIDE [inaudible]
RIGHT.
THERE'S OBVIOUSLY DIFFERENT
TAKES ON THAT ON THOSE ON THOSE
ISSUES.
VISIT DID YOU HAVE ANOTHER HOUSE
YEAH ASYLUM THERE QUESTION
OFFICE AND OTHER GOT SAVED LAST
THEY'RE GONNA YEAH IT'S NOT ARE
RIGHT.
I REALLY IN THE ANALYSIS THAT --
OF THIS IS SO ON THE UP MAKING
OUR U. S. OUT OF FISHING
INDUSTRY UP MORE DISADVANTAGED
BECAUSE SOUGHT.
HOW WELL THE FOREIGN COUNTRIES
ARE USING THE SAME GILET NOT
TECHNIQUES AND THAT THEY ARE
SENDING [inaudible]
FISH.
BACK TO US.
OF COURSE BY THE SAME INDUSTRY.
SO ARE WE ARE.
UP MAKING OUR US.
OF FISHING INDUSTRY AND
DISADVANTAGES TO FOR ENOUGH.
FISHERIES WELL I MEAN THE THE
HOPE IS THAT YOU KNOW THAT THESE
OTHER TECHNOLOGIES WILL PROVIDE
A MUCH MORE SUSTAINABLE WAY OF
ALLOWING THE FISHERY TO CONTINUE
TO THRIVE.
THAT'S BEEN THE WORK THAT PEWS
MORE CONFRONTATION ALSO SAY THAT
WE HAVE THE REPRESENTATIVES OF
OF THE OF LOTS OF FISHERMEN WHO
ARE VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL BECAUSE THEY'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT.
THE EXTENT TO WHICH THIS
PARTICULAR TYPE OF TECHNOLOGY.
YEAH ZONES OUT A LOT OF OTHER OF
FISHERMEN SO.
FAR YOU KNOW WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE
WE KNOW WE BY THE WAY THE UNITED
NATIONS HAS BEEN.
ADRIFT ON THAT'S GLOBALLY --
ON INTERNATIONAL WATERS NOW WHAT
WE KNOW OBVIOUSLY NOT AT THAT.
APPLY WITH EVERYWHERE --
SO THERE IT BUT BUT IT IS IT IS
IT IS OUR WILL THAT THE THE
WHOLE PLAN HERE IS TO HELP
PEOPLE TRANSITION TO THIS OTHER
TYPE.
HERE WHERE THEY CAN CONTINUE.
THEIR WORK NOW ON I THINK ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WAS RAISED BY
ONE OF THE WITNESSES WHO WHO
SPOKE ABOUT THE FACT THAT HE
DOES USE.
THE DEEP SIBUK AREAS THAT WE
NEED TO POWER I THINK PART OF
THE DEAL THAT WE'RE GONNA HAVE
TO STRIKE HERE ULTIMATELY BOTH
IN TERMS OF A BOOK AND IN
ADDITION TO THE MONEY AND IN
FIGURING OUT ABOUT A GOOD SWEET
SPOT TO HELP.
PUT PEOPLE ON A SPINSTER ON
PLACE TO BE ABLE TRANSITION OFF
WE'RE ALSO GONNA HAVE TO ADDRESS
THIS PERMITS ISSUE --
SO THAT WE DON'T AND THAT IS
THAT WE REALLY GIVE --
THE FISHERMEN WHO ARE
TRANSITIONING PRIORITY AND WE'RE
NOT YOU KNOW GIVING THESE OTHER
FOLKS [inaudible]
I YEAH THE RIGHT TO COME IN AND
I AND AND AND AND AND YOU USE
OUR FISHERIES IRRESPONSIBLY SO
ON THIS IS ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO FIGURE
OUT IN THE IN THE COURSE THE
NEGOTIATION.
BUT I'D LIKE I ENJOYED YOU HAVE.
WE'VE GOT A LOT OF BACK AND
FORTH ON THIS A DOCTOR TRADE YET
ANOTHER QUESTIONER US IT OKAY
THANK [inaudible]
AB [inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN.
ACTUALLY I WAS GOING TO ASK
ABOUT THE PERMIT ISSUE SO I'M
GLAD THAT --
YOU ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THAT ISSUE.
AND I ALSO WANT TO SAY AS
SOMEONE WHO'S A CO AUTHOR OF THE
BILL.
THAT THE THREATS THAT YOU THE
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN RECEIVING IN
THE SINKING OF THE BOAT IS
COMPLETELY UNACCEPTABLE.
AND I WANT TO SAY TO ANYONE.
I'M SUPPORTING THIS BILL THAT
THAT IS NOT HELPFUL AND IT'S
ABOMINABLE BEHAVIOR AND
CERTAINLY NOT CONDONING THAT AND
I'M GLAD.
THAT THE AUTHOR IS CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH THE FISHING COMMUNITY
I'M HOPING THAT HE'S WORKING IN
GOOD FAITH TO ADDRESS YOUR
CONCERN.
AND I HAD JUST RIGHT NOT ONLY DO
I NOT CONDONING I CONDEMN IN THE
STRONGEST POSSIBLE TERMS.
I IT IS ACTUALLY AN ACCEPTABLE
AND I YOU KNOW I WOULD LOVE TO
WORK WITH YOU TO MAKE SURE THAT
THIS DOESN'T HAPPEN AGAIN AND
THIS IS A BILL.
WE NEED TO KEEP.
WE HAVE THIS DISCUSSION IN THE
CONFINES OF PUBLIC POLICY MAKING
AND NOT GET INTO VIOLENCE AND
AND DESTRUCTION AND I I CAN'T.
CONDEMN IT STRONGLY ENOUGH LIGHT
I JUST WANTED AND I WANT TO
REITERATE THE CALL.
I'VE TO ANY ORGANIZATION
INVOLVED SUPPORT THIS BILL HOW
ABSENT ACCEPTABLE THIS IT.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
YEAH I ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS.
OKAY --
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE ON ON
THIS CENTER REALLY APPRECIATE
THE DISCUSSION AYE AYE I THINK
THAT ULTIMATELY THIS IS A THIS
IS A NEGOTIATION THAT WERE
ENGAGE WITH RIGHT NOW AND I
THOUGHT I DO FEEL THAT WE CAN
GET TO A PLACE WHERE --
WHERE WHERE WE CAN WHERE WE CAN
MAKE FOLKS HALL?
AND I HOPE.
TO TO MAKE OUR VICTORY MUCH MORE
SUSTAINABLE AND I THINK IT'S
PART OF WHY WE WERE ABLE TO GET
A THIRTY THREE TO ZERO VOTE.
ON THE SENATE FLOOR.
AND SO I I ASK YOU MEMBERS TO
GIVE US THE OPPORTUNITY KEEP
WORKING ON THIS AND I AYE INTO
IT AS WE AS WE CAN WITH THIS
NEGOTIATION SO WITHOUT I RESPECT
ESCRIBO.
OKAY -- WITH
THAT THERE IS A MOTION AND A
SECOND BY SUMMER FRIEDMAN SECOND
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA --
SO.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS DOES HAVE A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE CHAIR --
AND IT WOULD BE GOING TO PASS TO
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
[inaudible]
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GALLAGHER NUMBER.
GALLAGHER NOT VOTING BIGELOW
[inaudible]
CARILLO.
CHOI NOT WARNING CHOI NOT VOTING
CHIU [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN.
GLORIA AYE GLORIA AYE HARPER.
HARPER NO CHOLERA [inaudible]
LEVINE [inaudible]
MATHIS GO.
BECAUSE MATHIS NO RUBIO
[inaudible]
SALAS [inaudible]
BY.
BOB HOPE YOU WORK WITH.
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING AND SALAS I
WOULD.
OKAY OWN THAT WILL KEEP THAT ON
CALL AND WE HAVE SOME MORE
MEMBERS I STILL BE COMING AND
AND THANK YOU SENATOR AND PREACH
AND I'D ALSO HONORARIA THANK.
THANK YOU.
FOR BOTH WORKING WITH THE
OPPOSITION TRYING TO FIND THE
RIGHT SPOT HERE LATELY AS HE
SAID -- AND
ALSO FOR ME OF CONDEMNATION IS
THE RIGHT WORD FOR ANYBODY THAT
WOULD.
YOU KNOW --
KNOW SEEK TO TERRORIZE PEOPLE
ABSALOM AND CERTAINLY THAT
PRECEDE THOSE COMMENTS SO WE'LL
KEEP THAT ON OKAY ON ROLL CALL
ON RIGHT SENATOR PORTANTINO YOUR
YOU ARE NEXT THANK YOU.
MOVE THE BILL S. B..
TWELVE SIXTY THREE MOTION BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MATHIS.
SECONDED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SALAS.
YOU ALREADY GOT A MOTION AND A
SECOND ALRIGHT SINGER GIVEN THE
THE MOTION IN THE SECOND ROW OF
THE THREE FIVE THIS BILL HAS --
DID PASS OUT THE STATE SENATE ON
NOT CONSENT --
S. B. TWELVE SIXTY THREE
REQUIRESTHE OPEN OCEAN
PROTECTION COUNCIL TO DO WOULD
TO ADOPT AND IMPLEMENT A
STATEWIDE MICRO PLASTIC STRATEGY.
AND SUBMITTED TO THE LEGISLATURE
HONOR BEFORE DECEMBER THIRTY
FIRST TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I VOTE.
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF FOLKS WHO
WANT TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS THEM JUST CA.GOV AT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SANITATION AGENCIES ALL THE PRE
FOR THE SPONSOR WERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
IF YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUP CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST WASTE IN SUPPORT OF SB
TWELVE SIXTY THREE AS IT'S
PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED AND WE
REALLY LIKE TO THANK THE SENATOR.
FOR TAKING THIS CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS WHICH MAKE IT.
IS NEEDED TO ADDRESS PLASTIC
POLLUTION AND THAT THE BILL IS
NOT INTENDED TO PRECLUDE --
OTHER STATUTORY CHANGES SO I
THINK YOU THE SENATOR FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON PLASTIC POLLUTION
REDUCTION THIS YEAR AND DRIVE
THE OKAY JUST TO CONFIRM SO
YOU'RE GONNA BE TAKEN AMENDMENTS
IN THE STM IS THAT RIGHT THERE
RIGHT OR NOT YOU MAY GET AUTHORS
IN THERE'S NO COMMITTEE AMEND
YEAH.
BREATH NOT TODAY IN THIS
COMMITTEE ANYWHERE AS THIS
PURPOSE SORRY RIGHT THANK YOU --
OKAY --
OTHER MEMBER OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC IN SUPPORT.
HEARINGS GREEN COUNTY SANITATION
DISTRICT OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY
HERE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GENEVIEVE ABBOTT ON BEHALF OF
SURFRIDER FOUNDATION HILL THE
BAY WILD COAST AND OTHER MEMBERS
OF THE CLEAN SEIZE LOBBYING
COALITION.
ALSO IN SUPPORT AS PROPOSED TO
BE AMENDED --
THINK THE THOUGHT THERE FOR
WORKING WITH US TO SHORTEN THE
TIME LINE AND MAKE THIS BILL
COMPLEMENTARY AND INCLUDE
LANGUAGE THAT IT WON'T PRECLUDE
ANY OTHER ACTION THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IS TAKING THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
OKAY --
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
CASEY NINE I WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE THERE IS A
MOTION AND A SECOND AT THIS
POINT -- TO
AND THE MOTION IS TO MOVE THIS.
TO ASSEMBLY ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY
AND TOXIC --
WHO HAS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
FROM THE CHAIR?
ALRIGHT SCENE AT THE FURTHER WE
WILL WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
SENATOR [inaudible]
YEAH.
OKAY --
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON ENVIRONMENTAL
SAFETY AND TOXIC MATERIALS.
EDUARDO GARCIA GALLAGHER BY
GALLAGHER I GET LOW [inaudible]
CARILLO.
CHOI AYE CHOI AYE CHU
[inaudible]
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE HARPER UP HARPER AYE.
KALRA.
LEVINE.
MATHIS I'VE MATHIS AYE RUBIO
[inaudible]
SALAS.
SALAS I WOULD.
ARE YOU HAVE THE US SIX TO ZERO
VOTE -- WILL
KEEP THAT ON CALL AND THANK YOU
SENATOR.
ARE AYE WE ARE WAITING ON
AUTHORS [inaudible]
SO MY FRIENDS IN THE SENATE WHO
WANT TO PRESENT THEIR BILLS.
WE WOULD LOVE TO HAVE YOU.
WE HAVE SENATOR GLAZER HERE.
SENATOR ARE YOU --
READY TO PRESENT.
ALRIGHT STEP RIGHT UP.
WE HAVE S. B. [inaudible]
THIRTEEN SIXTEEN SECRETARY
[inaudible]
YES SIR.
PROCEED MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU HERE IN THIS BILL THAT THIS
BILL WOULD.
WOULD AUTHORIZE THE DEPARTMENT
OF PARKS AND REC. TO DECIDE THE
FUTURE OF A PROPOSED EXPANSION.
OF IT OFF HIGHWAY MOTOR VEHICLE
PARKED THAT'S IN MY DISTRICT.
THIS EXPANSION IS KNOWN AS THE
ALAMEDA TESLA [inaudible]
EXPANSION.
AND ITS ADJACENT TO AN EXISTING
OFF HIGHWAY PARK --
THAT'S KNOWN AS CARNEGIE THAT'S
AS I SAID IN MY DISTRICT.
AND THAT EXISTING PARKS BEEN
THERE FOR ABOUT FORTY YEARS.
IN THE NINETEEN NINETIES THE
DEPARTMENT --
OVER A SERIES OF TRANSACTIONS
PURCHASE THIS ALAMEDA TOUGH LOVE
PROPERTY.
ABOUT NINE MILLION DOLLARS.
AND IT HAS BEEN MIRED IN
CONTROVERSY EVER SINCE.
THIS BILL THAT'S OF INFO BEFORE
YOU TODAY DOES NOT MANDATE
ANYTHING.
DOES NOT SPEAK TO THE ACTIVITY
OF OFF ROAD RIDING.
AND IT DOES NOT TAKE AWAY THE
CURRENT OFF HIGHWAY VEHICLE PARK.
EVERYTHING REMAINS THE SAME.
IT SIMPLY GIVES THE PARKS
DEPARTMENT THE OPTION. TO SELL
THIS PROPOSED EXPANSION AREA IF
THEY DECIDE IT'S IN THE PUBLIC'S
INTEREST.
AND THE AND BY DOING SO
RETURNING MONEY TO THE OFF
HIGHWAY VEHICLE FUND.
FROM WHICH IT ORIGINATED.
THE ONLY CONDITION IS THAT THIS
LAND BE PERMANENTLY PRESERVE FOR
CONSERVATION PURPOSES IF THEY
CHOSE THAT OPTION.
THIS BILL SUPPORTED BY TWENTY
FIVE LOCAL.
STATE PRESERVATION NATIVE
AMERICAN COMMUNITY AND
ENVIRONMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS AS
WELL AS SIX LOCAL PUBLICATIONS
HE'S.
I AM FOR THAT REASON I'D ASK
YOUR CONSIDERATIONS DAY IN YOUR
AFFIRMATIVE VOTE AND JOINED
TODAY BY EDWARD MORENO WITH THE
SIERRA CLUB OF CALIFORNIA.
AND THAT I LOOK FOR DISCUSSION.
MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS AGAIN ADAM
RIGHT ON BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT.
I'M HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND
MEMBERS STATEWIDE INCLUDING
ACTIVE MEMBERS AND VOLUNTEERS
HERE CLUB LEADERS LIVING IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY.
HAVE BEEN WORKING TO MAKE THIS
VERY SPECIAL NATURAL AREA
COMMONLY REFERRED TO AS TESSA
PARK.
MITCHELL IT IS PRESERVED.
OUR LOCAL SHARE THE CHAPTERS A
PART OF THE ULTIMATE LANDFILL
OPEN SPACE COMMITTEE THAT IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR EXPANDING.
LOCAL OPEN SPACE MITIGATION
FUNDS AND HAS OFFERED TO USE ITS
LOCAL FUNDS TO PURCHASE THE
ALAMEDA TESLA EXPANSION AREA.
WE ARE -- WE
CAN OF THIS LAND SO MUCH BECAUSE
IT'S A STUNNING BALLOT
BIODIVERSITY HOTSPOTS.
THE MOIST CALIFORNIA RANGE MEET
THE NORTH EDGE OF THE OF THE DRY
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY PRODUCING
HABITAT THAT BRINGS TOGETHER A
VARIETY OF ANIMAL AND PLANT
SPECIES.
IS THERE IS GENERALLY DESCRIBED
AS BLUE OAK WOODLAND AND
GRASSLAND BUT THAT DOESN'T GIVE
THAT INTO THE PLACE JUST.
AND ARE.
UNLIKE OTHER WOODLAND AND
GRASSLAND IS A REGION.
ISN'T REALLY BECAUSE OF ITS BAO
DIVERSITY BUSINESS AND HAS DRAWN.
ONE OF THE MOST A ONE OF THOSE
WAS JOHNNY THE FOUNDER OF SIERRA
CLUB.
AND THE FATHER OF NATIONAL THE
NATIONAL PARK SYSTEM.
A SCIENTIST BACK CONSENSUS
STATEMENT ON THE ECOLOGICAL
VALUE OF THE ALAMEDA TESLA
EXPANSION AREA OF WHICH WE HAVE
PROVIDED YOU A COPY.
WAS SIGNED BY OVER FORTY FIVE
SCIENTISTS INCLUDING.
A NUMEROUS UNIVERSITY PROFESSORS
LEADERS OF UNIVERSITY --
LEADERS OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA'S INVERTEBRATE
ZOOLOGY.
I AND THE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF SCIENCES.
THE STATEMENT --
DOCUMENTS A RARE EXCEPTIONAL AND
REPLACE IRREPLACEABLE NATURAL
RESOURCES LOCATED IN THE ALAMEDA
TESLA [inaudible]
EXPANSION AREA.
INCLUDING A FORTY CHOOSE A
SPECIAL STATUS SPECIES WILDLIFE
SPECIES INCLUDING. EIGHT
FEDERALLY OR STATE LISTED
CANDICE PC'S. THIRTEEN SPECIAL
STATUS IN AND TWENTY EIGHT
LOCALLY RARE PLANT SPECIES.
I LOCAL BUY LOCALLY REFERENCE
SPECIES.
DIGNITY CRITICAL HABITAT FOR
CALVIN READ LIKE A FROG AND
ALAMEDA WITH SNAKE THAT YEAH
EAST BAY CALIFORNIA PLANT.
NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY BOTANICAL
UP PRIORITY PROTECTION AREA.
CRITICAL LINKAGE HABITAT
CORRIDORS.
THAT GOLDEN EAGLE NESTING
FORGING AREA.
NATIVE --
CALIFORNIA PLANT SITE AND IF
KATHLEEN SIDES OF ECOLOGICAL
SPIRITUAL AND CEREMONY
IMPORTANCE.
HISTORIC TOWN FIVE AND HAVING
COALMINES A TESLA.
AND S. B. THIRTEEN SIXTEEN IS
FOCUSED ON A SPECIFIC LOCAL
ISSUE AND PROVIDES A MECHANISM
TO PROTECT THE THE ALAMEDA TOUCH
EXPANSION AREA.
IN A WAY THAT IS HEALTH WISE FOR
THE ENVIRONMENT.
UNFAIR FOR THIS FOR STATE PARKS
AND AND THE DIVISION BUT HAS A
STATEWIDE IMPORTANCE.
THIS BILL WILL HELP ALLOW.
SCIENTISTS AND THE PUBLIC TO
VIEW ESTA AND STUDY A STUNNING
BIOLOGICALLY RICH AND
INCREASINGLY WERE HABITAT.
JUST A RELATIVELY SHORT DRIVE IN
THE HEARTS OF THE BAY AREA AND
SILICON VALLEY.
THE TESLA AREA SCREAMS OUT FOR
GOOD RESPONSIBLE STEWARDSHIP.
THIS BILL OPEN OF A PATH WHICH
PROVIDE THE KIND OF STEWARDSHIP
AT ONCE.
OUR AT YOU SUPPORT SB THIRTEEN
SIXTEEN THANK YOU.
I THANK YOU --
OTHER PEOPLE IN SUPPORT.
MORNING IS CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE UNFIT OTHER THEM ON
BEHALF OF CUP WHEN THEY PLANT
SOCIETY AS WELL AS ONGOING
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
BERNIE MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THE
CONTRACTS ON BEHALF THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ONE PUBLIC OF ON ON BEHALF OF
SAY MONDAY OUT OF WITH MORE THAN
EIGHT THOUSAND MEMBERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING PRISON MONTHS OUT
WITH THE CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL
DIVERSITY IN SUPPORT.
KIANA CITY ON BEHALF OF THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN STRONG SUPPORT
THINK YOU.
DR SARAH CUT FOR BURGER I'M HERE
REPRESENTING THE SCIENTISTS WHO
AND SIGNED THE CONSENSUS
STATEMENT ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE
OF THIS PROPERTY THINKING.
THAT'S WORSE BURKE PRESIDENT
EAST BAY CHAPTER THE CALIFORNIA
ATIVE PLANT SOCIETY
REPRESENTING ALAMEDA CONTRA
COSTA COUNTIES IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU CHAIR CELESTE'S
GARAMENDI I'M WITH FRIENDS OF
TESLA PARK WHICH IS AN ALLIANCE.
THAT INCLUDES ALL OF THE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT THE AUTHOR
SPOKE TO OVER TWENTY FIVE LOCAL
ORGANIZATIONS [inaudible]
AND SIX PUBLIC AGENCIES
INCLUDING ALAMEDA COUNTY THE
CITY OF LIVERMORE.
ON ALAMEDA COUNTY RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICT LIVERMORE
AREA RECREATION PARK DISTRICT IN
EAST BAY REGIONAL PARK.
I'M DISTRICT THAT PUBLIC SUPPORT
FOR THIS BILL IS IMPORTANT.
IN COMBINATION WITH THE LOCAL
AREA IF I CAN MAKES TWO QUICK
STATEMENTS PLEASE. ONE IS A ARM.
THERE CERTAINLY IS SOME
DISCUSSION ABOUT THE ABOUT THE
NEED FOR THIS AREA NAMES ARE JIM
NYE I CAN'T HAD HAD TO DO THIS
FOR EVERYBODY SO IF I COULD.
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT ANY DAY GO TO
THE NEXT ISLAND SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HELLO I'M KRISTIN BAUER VAN
STRATEN ACTRESS FROM LOS ANGELES
AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF THE SIERRA
CLUB THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS TECH HOUSTON
REPRESENTING THE AFOREMENTIONED
EAST BAY REGIONAL PARK DISTRICT
WE TOURED SUPPORT --
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
YES PLEASE COME FORWARD
.
PROCEED I'M NOT SURE WHO'S GOING
FIRST YOU ALTHOUGH FIRST MR
MCHALE IF YOU'D LIKE TO CO
ANCHOR YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN TERRY
MCHALE WITH ERIN REGAN
ASSOCIATES.
REPRESENTING THE COALITION OF
OFF HIGHWAY VEHICLE RECREATIONAL
STE.
ALL THIS IS ONE OF THOSE
SITUATIONS WE HAVE GREAT RESPECT
FOR THE AUTHOR.
BUT IS THAT [inaudible]
GREAT.
QUOTE COMES THIS IS A TERRIBLE
TERRIBLE BILL.
WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS
ESSENTIALLY TAKE WORK THAT HAS
BEEN DONE?
OF FOR DECADES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO ADVANCE OFF
HIGHWAY VEHICLE RECREATION.
AND DOES MORE THAN JUST SAY THAT
THE PARKS CONSOLIDATE AUTHORIZES
THE DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES IF STATE PARKS
DETERMINES.
THAT THEY CONSULT.
BUT LIKE TO REMIND THIS
COMMITTEE WE SPENT THE ENTIRE
YEAR LAST YEAR.
THE ENTIRE YEAR GOING THROUGH
THE OFF HIGHWAY VEHICLE PROGRAM
TO MAKE SURE THAT MET THE NEEDS
OF ENVIRONMENTALISTS IT MET THE
NEEDS OF LOCAL ENTITIES IT MET
THE NEEDS OF STATE GOVERNMENT.
AND THE TESLA DISCUSSION WAS IN
THE EARLY PART OF THOSE
NEGOTIATIONS AND IT WAS REJECTED.
THAT IT NEEDED TO STAY WITHIN
THAT HE'D AEGIS OF THE STATE
PARKS.
WHAT WE DID LAST YEAR IS THAT'S
DIVISION WITHOUT THE FOLLOWING
DUTIES AND RESPONSIBILITIES?
THE PLANNING ACQUISITION
DEVELOPMENT CONSERVATION AND
RESTORATION OF THE LANDS IN THE
STATE VEHICULAR RECREATIONAL
AREA.
AND TO ENSURE THAT THE PROGRAMS
COMPLIANCE.
CALIFORNIAN FIRE MENTAL QUALITY
ACTS.
WHAT WE HAVE HERE LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN?
HERE'S A SITUATION IN WHICH THE
STATE PARKS AND WHAT WE LEARNED
LAST YEARS THAT THERE ARE MORE
ENVIRONMENTAL SCIENTIST AND MORE
CULTURAL SCIENTISTS.
ASSOCIATED WITH THE OFF HIGHWAY
VEHICLE RECREATION PROGRAM THAN
ANY OTHER PART OF PARKS ANY
OTHER PART OF PARKS.
AND THEY'RE THE ONES WHO ARE
BEST EQUIPPED TO DEAL WITH
WHETHER THEY SHOULD BE SOLD.
BUT WE JUST PUT ASIDE THE NOTES
FOR JUST A SECOND JUST SAY THIS.
OFF HIGHWAY VEHICLE RECREATION.
IS ONE OF THE MOST POPULAR PARTS.
THE PARKS PROGRAM.
AND TOO OFTEN THIS BREAKS DOWN
AND REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS.
WELL WE HAVE FOUND OUT IS THAT
DEMOCRATS ARE RIDING JUST AS
MUCH AS REPUBLICANS.
IT IS NOW ONE OF THE MOST
POPULAR RECREATIONAL ACTIVITIES
OF PEOPLE OF COLOR IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
THIS IS NOT A RICH WHITE DAMMIT
REPUBLICAN PROGRAM.
DOES THE PROGRAM WORK.
THE PROGRAM WORKS IT
STRAORDINARIO EARLY WELL
REMEMBER THERE ARE TWO HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY STATE PARKS IN
CALIFORNIA.
ONLY EIGHT OF THEM.
OR OFF AYE WAY VEHICLE
RECREATION.
ONLY EIGHT OF THE TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY OR OFF HIGHWAY VEHICLE
RECREATION.
AND I WOULD ASK THIS QUESTION
BEFORE I CLOSE.
ANY STATE.
I THINK A BETTER IDEA BEEN THE
GLAZER BILL IN WHICH WE IGNORE.
ALL OF THE WORK THAT HAS GONE
INTO THE OHP PROGRAM INTO TESLIN
PARTICULAR.
THAT INSTEAD OF AUTHORIZING
ANYONE.
STEAL THIS PARK CAN GIVE IT TO
SOMEONE ELSE.
THEY WILL ACTUALLY DO A HEARING.
ON TESLA ITSELF.
BECAUSE I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE
WOULD BE SURPRISED TO DISCOVER.
THAT WHEN THIS PARK WAS SET
ASIDE IN.
NINETEEN BUT THEY WENT TO THE
LOCAL ENTITIES.
AND MANY OF THOSE PEOPLE WHO ARE
OPPOSING IT PUBLICLY NOW SIGNED
OFF.
ON THIS PARK AND NOW WE'RE DOING
NOT IN OUR NEIGHBORHOOD.
I WOULD ALSO SAY THIS.
BEYOND THE FACT.
STEALING THE PARK.
OR TRYING TO STEAL THE PARK OR
SETTING UP THE POSSIBILITY OF
STEALING THE PARK WHEREVER WE
WANT TO SAY.
SENATOR GLAZER MENTIONED THAT
THE OHP PROGRAM WILL GET MONEY
BACK.
WITH THE SAIL OF THIS PARK IS
PART OF THE PARK.
PERHAPS THAT'S THE MOST
INSULTING PART OF THIS ENTIRE
BILL.
I CAN NOT THINK OF ANYWAY.
THAT THE LEGISLATURE CAN BE MORE
DISRESPECTFUL TO AN OHP PROGRAM.
THAT HAS DONE EVERYTHING
POSSIBLE TO FOLLOW THE RULES.
THEN TO SAY THAT THE PARK ITSELF
CAN BE SOLD FOR LESS.
THEN THE FAIR MARKET VALUE.
WES THEN THE SPARE MARKET VALUE
IN A REAL ESTATE MARKET THAT IS
BOOMING IN AN AREA OF THE STATE
IN WHICH PEOPLE ARE DOING
EXTRAORDINARILY WELL.
THAT WE WANT TO INSULT THE
PROGRAM AND SAY LET'S SELL.
AT LESS THAN MARKET VALUE NO
THIS IS A BAD BILL AND I WOULD
ASK DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS TO
BOTH REJECT IT LET'S DO A
HEARING ON THIS PARK.
LET'S GET TO THE TRUTH OF THE
PARK LET'S NOT TURN THIS PARK
OVER TO PEOPLE.
SOLD WHO ARE WILLING TO SIGN OFF
ON IT.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ARE ACTING CHAIRMAN.
I AM DIOMEDE I'M A CONSTITUENT
OF SENATOR GLAZER.
THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL BEFORE
YOU TODAY.
I AM ALSO PAST PRESIDENT OF
CALIFORNIA OFF ROAD VEHICLE
ASSOCIATION.
AN OFF ROAD VEHICLE ENTHUSIAST.
A SMALL BUSINESS OWNER.
A MOTHER A GRANDMOTHER A
DEFENDER OF ACCESS [inaudible]
MOST IMPORTANTLY.
I AM HERE IS A STAKEHOLDER FOR
THE EXPANSION OF CARNEGIE STATE
VEHICLE RECREATION AREA.
IT'S INCUMBENT ON EACH OF US TO
PRIORITIZE ISSUES AND ALLOCATE
RESOURCES APPROPRIATELY WHERE WE
CAN MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
THE BILL BEFORE YOU IS THE
LEGISLATIVE EFFORT TO MITIGATE
LEGAL ACTIONS.
AND THE RELATED EXPENSE FOR
EXPANDING CARNEGIE S. B. ARE A I
REPEAT.
S. B. THIRTEEN SIXTEEN WAS
INTRODUCED.
IS IN PROCESS.
AND MAY SET PRECEDENT.
STOP THE USE OF H. VIS ON A
PROPERTY PURCHASED WITH OHP
FUNDS WHOSE STATED PURPOSE WAS
TO EXPAND AN EXISTING OHB
FACILITY.
A SINGLE FACILITY OUT OF TWO
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY PLUS STATE
PARKS IS ADDRESSED.
IN THIS BILL.
OUR STATE PARKS ARE HELD THE TO
A HIGH STANDARD.
THE H. M. V. R. DIVISION IS HELD
TO AN EVEN HIGHER STANDARD.
ESPECIALLY AFTER SB TWO FORTY
NINE THE BIPARTISAN BILL.
WHICH MISTER MIKHAIL HAS ALREADY
REFERRED.
TO WAS SIGNED INTO LAW LAST FALL.
THANK YOU TO THIS COMMITTEE AND
YOUR STAFF FOR ALL THE WORK ON
THAT AGREEMENT.
THAT BILL GRANTED THE CITIZENS
pOF CALIFORNIA A NATIONALLY
RECOGNIZED SUSTAINABLE OHB
PROGRAM.
STATE PARKS MISSION IS TO
PROVIDE FOR THE HEALTH
INSPIRATION AN EDUCATION OF THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA BY HELPING
TO PRESERVE THE STATE'S.
EXTRAORDINARY BIOLOGICAL
DIVERSITY PROTECTING ITS MOST
VALUE.
NATURAL AND CULTURAL RESOURCES
AND CREATING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
HIGH QUALITY OUTDOOR RECREATION.
STATE PARKS HAS DEMONSTRATED.
THAT THEY CAN DELIVER ON THEIR
MISSION.
AND PROVIDE FOR HIGHWAY
MOTORIZED OFF HIGHWAY MOTORIZED
RECREATION.
DP ARE HAS THE CREDIBILITY THE
ABILITY.
AND THE COMMITMENT TO MITIGATE
THE DAMAGE DONE TO THE EXPANSION
PROPERTY BY PRIOR TENANTS.
DAMAGE DONE BY PRIOR TENANTS.
FULFILL ITS MISSION AND GIVE US
THE OHP OPPORTUNITY WE HAVE
LEARNED.
APPROVAL OF THE GENERAL PLAN.
HAS BEEN A YEARS ALONG
INVESTMENT.
WITH PUBLIC INPUT FOR EACH STEP
OF THE PROCESS.
S. B. THIRTEEN SIXTEEN WOULD NOT
ONLY ENABLE THE SALE OF THIS
PROPERTY IT WOULD PERMIT A SALE.
PRICE BELOW MARKET VALUE. TO AN
ORGANIZATION THAT WOULD DO
EVERYTHING STATE PARKS WOULD DO.
BUT WOULD ELIMINATE THE
POSSIBILITY OF OHP.
HOW IS THIS FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE?
I HAVE BROUGHT WITH ME TODAY
PACKETS THAT WILL ENABLE YOU TO
MAKE AN INFORMED DECISION.
IN YOUR PACKET YOU WILL FIND
PHOTOGRAPHS OF CARNEGIE S. B.
ARE A THE EXPANSION AREA AND
HOLLISTER HILLS AS WE ARE A POOR
STATE PARKS IS ESTABLISH THE
KIND OF PARK THE EXPANSION COULD
OFFER US.
ADDITIONALLY THERE'S A COPY OF A
LETTER DRAFTED IN NINETEEN
NINETY FIVE ACKNOWLEDGING THE
PURCHASE PURPOSE OF THE TEST THE
PROPERTY BY ADJACENT LANDOWNERS.
S. B. THIRTEEN SIXTEEN IS AN END
RUN AROUND THE PROCESS.
USING LEGISLATION TO SUPERSEDE
THE WILL OF CITIZENS AND
TAXPAYERS.
IT FURTHER UNDERMINES THE
ABILITY OF CALIFORNIA STATE
PARKS TO CARRY OUT THEIR MANDATE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THE OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS COMMITTEE CAPPING LIGHTS
REPRESENTING A STATEWIDE
ORGANIZATION OFF ROAD VEHICLE
LEGISLATIVE POLITICIAN IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
VERSIONS OF ORIGIN ON BEHALF OF
BETA CALIFORNIA MOTORCYCLE
RIGHTS ORGANIZATION IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BRUCE
NICHOLAS HARRIS WESTERN STATES
REPRESENTATIVE FOR THE AMERICAN
MOTORCYCLIST ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT --
BRINGING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
FROM MEMBERS [inaudible]
DOCTOR CHOI.
I LUCKED AS BECAUSE SENATOR
GLAZER TO RESPOND.
UP TO THE LADY ETCETERA
OPPOSITION STATEMENTS SO.
ON SOUNDS SOUGHT THIS AS SOMEONE.
A TERRIBLE --
FOR THOSE PEOPLE WHO ARE
CURRENTLY ENJOYING [inaudible]
L. [inaudible]
RUBIO REPARATION --
OPPORTUNITIES SO IN A LIMITED TO
SPACE.
AND THE BY SELLING THAT PROPERTY.
TO ARE LESS THAN.
MARKET PRICE SO WHAT ARE YOU
AIMING.-FOR OUR UNDERSTAND [inaudible]
SENATOR [inaudible]
IF YOU CHAIR.
WELL I I GUESS I'D SAY WE HAVE.
REGARD ALL THIS DISCUSSION
WELCOME TO MY DISTRICT
[inaudible]
BECAUSE THAT BUT THIS PFIZER HAS
BEEN GOING ON FOR VERY VERY LONG
TIME -- WITH
GOOD INTENTIONS BY ALL SIDES.
ON THIS ISSUE AND IT'S IT'S WHY
THIS BILL REALLY IS HERE TO
PROVIDE AN OPTION THAT DOESN'T
EXIST TODAY --
BUT THAT SO.
BUT DOCTOR CHOI THE THIS IS THE
EXISTING OFFER.
VEHICLE.
PARKED IN MY DISTRICT
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
THE PICTURE --
IT IS MATCHING THERE'S EIGHT OF
THESE IN THE STATE YES ONE OF
THEM'S RIGHT HERE AND IT'S A LOT
OF PEOPLE LIKE TO ENGAGE IN THAT
ACTIVITY AND AND HERE'S THE
HILLS OF LIVERMORE --
WITH THE CURRENT --
CARNEGIE PROPERTY THAT WE HAVE
[inaudible]
SO.
LOT IMPACTS LOT OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS BUT
CERTAINLY PEOPLE IN MY DISTRICT
GET TAKE GO TO OFF HIGHWAY.
PARK THAT SIT NEARBY WHICH IS
NICE -- TO
AND HERE IS THE ADJACENT LAND.
NEXT TO IT --
AND AS YOU CAN SEE THAT THAT IT
KINDA LOOKS THE SAME.
EXCEPT FOR IT DOESN'T.
AND AND THE VIEW IS THAT BECAUSE
WE HAVE.
FIVE ADJACENCY ISSUE HERE THAT
WE SHOULD GO AHEAD AND JUST ADD
SOME MORE HILLS AND AND LET
THOSE FOLKS HAVE A LITTLE BIT
GREATER SPACE IN WHICH DIRECTORY.
OBVIOUSLY TESTIMONY TODAY IT'S
BEEN ABOUT THAT --
UNIQUE NATURE OF THIS AREA THIS
THIS AREA THAT THAT'S IT THE
EXPANSION AREA.
AND WHY THEY'RE SET A LOT OF
CONCERNS ABOUT THE ENVIRONMENT
DEGRADATION THAT WOULD RESULT --
IN THAT ACQUISITION AND THAT
COMBINATION AND THIS IS NOW THE
DISPUTE HAS BEEN GOING ON FOR
YEARS AND YEARS AND YEARS.
I AND MY DISTRICT.
OUT WELL INTENTIONED BY PEOPLE
WHO ENJOY THIS ACTIVITY IN THOSE
WHO'D LIKE TO PRESERVE IT.
JUST TO CLARIFY REAL QUICK
SENATOR.
WHEN WERE THESE PICTURES TAKEN I
GUESS --
YAQUI ALL ALL LAST MY STEP COME
UP AND GIVE ME THAT THE DATES
BUT JUST TO PUT SOME CONTEXT
JANET AND I I MY I IMAGINE THE
LAST FEW YEARS BUT I'LL CHECK ON
IT OKAY YOUR JOB CHAIRPERSON
KNOW WHILE Y. SHE'S SHOWING THAT
UP PICTURE.
THIS IS OUR OPPOSITE THE PICTURE
ARE LEFT AND THE RIGHT.
AND UP BEFORE AND AFTER --
THEN WILL YOU LIKEN THIS IS A
LOT MORE YOU SEEN THERE IS THAT
THAT THAT THAT I I THINK I
UNDERSTAND I SEE I THINK I SEE
THE PICTURE LET ME EXPLAIN IT --
THOSE WHO WERE AT CURRENTLY
RUNNING THE CARNEGIE PROPERTY OF
REALIZE THAT THEY HAVE NOT
MANAGED IN A VERY RESPONSIBLE
WAY.
AND THEY ARE TRYING TO THEY
TAKEN A SMALL SECTION I'VE GONE
OUT THERE PERSONALLY TO SEE THIS
THEY TAKEN IT SMALL AREA OF THE
PROPERTY IN SAID IT WE CAN
REDIRECT THAT ACTIVITY.
YEAH YEAH ON TRAILS MAYBE WE CAN
STOP THE MASSIVE DEGRADATION
THAT'S OCCURRED OVER MANY
DECADES AND SO THEY ARE.
TRYING OUT IN CERTAIN PARTS OF
THE PARK AN EFFORT TO TRY TO
STOP THAT WIDESPREAD DEGRADATION
WHICH DOES EXIST TODAY.
AND I THINK WHAT YOU'RE SEEING
IS THE EFFORTS THAT THEY HAVE
UNDERTAKEN TO TRY TO AYE.
AYE DIRECTED AYE AS BEST THEY
CAN TO SEE IF THEY CAN MINIMIZE
SOME OF THAT MASSIVE DAMAGE
THAT'S BEEN DONE ON THAT
EXISTING PARCEL AND AYE AYE AYE.
I PRAISE THEM FOR THAT AND IT'S
THE RIGHT THING TO DO.
AT THE STEWARDSHIP HAS NOT BEEN
GOOD AND I THINK THAT'S WHY
YOU'RE LOOKING AT A BEFORE AND
AFTER OF A PART OF PORTION OF
THE CARNEGIE PROPERTY.
OKAY DO YOU HAVE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS AFTER CHOI.
RIGHT.
YEAH AND I JUST SAY IS JUST AS A
MATTER OF A CONTEXT THAT YOU
HAVE DRIVEN THROUGH THE AREA
MANY TIMES.
THERE'S ALSO THE SUMMER VERSES
THE MORE SPRING TIME RIGHT IN
THE SUMMER EVERYTHING LOOKS DEAD
YOU KNOW [inaudible]
BUT LOOKS VERY LUSH YOU KNOW IN
THIS IN THE SPRING WRITING ALSO
RIGHT.
SO I KNOW THERE'S THOSE
DIFFERENT TIMES AND IT'S BUT I'D
REVENUE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
YES SAID.
SO REMEMBER HARPER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOU.
AS I'VE INTERACTED WITH FOLKS
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS ONE
THING THAT SEVEN VERY CLEAR TO
ME IS THAT --
OFFER A OFF HIGHWAY VEHICLES ARE
VERY POPULAR AMONG CALIFORNIANS --
THEY'RE POPULAR AMONG TOURISTS
THAT ARE VISITING CALIFORNIA.
I AND THE TREMENDOUS USE THAT WE
SEE -- WITH
OUR A STATE VEHICLE RECREATION
AREA SHOWS ME.
I THAT THERE IS INDEED NOT
ENOUGH SPACE NOT TOO MUCH SPACE
IN OUR STATE PARKS.
I YOU KNOW I'M SOMEONE WHO
ENJOYS IN THE NATIONAL PARKS
BEING ABLE TO SKI.
AND YEAH.
YOU KNOW YOU'LL HAVE A SKI RUNS
THAT ARE --
CARVED INTO.
A MOUNTAINOUS AREAS
UNDERSTATEMENT LIKE TAHOE IN THE
SIERRAS AND DOWN NINE THE
SAMPRADAYA MOUNTAINS WHERE I
LIVE.
UP BUT THAT'S A PART OF THE
STEWARDSHIP OF GOOD OPEN SPACE I
IS THAT --
PEOPLE [inaudible]
CALIFORNIANS AND THOSE WHO VISIT
CALIFORNIA ARE ABLE TO TO ENJOY
THAT THE SPLENDOUR OF OUR OUR
BEAUTIFUL STATE --
AND SO THAT'S WHY I'LL BE VOTING
IN OPPOSITION THIS BECAUSE I
THINK THAT WE NEED MORE THIS
SPACE NOT LESS.
I THINK --
SO MEMBER GLORIA.
THANK YOU SIR OF COURSE FOR THE
AUTHOR AND OF THE THIRTY ONE
HUNDRED ACRES THAT WERE ACQUIRED
ARE YOUR BILL COMES OFF THIRTY
ONE HUNDRED ACRES POTENTIAL SALE.
IT DOES IT AS AN OPTION ONLY BUT
YES I'M IN AND JUST TO CLARIFY
BECAUSE I HEARD THE COMMENTS
ABOUT.
FAR BELOW MARKET BUT THAT'S ONLY
IN THE SITUATION WHERE THAT THE
LAND REMAIN PUBLIC INFORMED --
PARK USES CRACK.
BUT THERE THERE IS EXISTING LAW
ON THEY A DISPOSITION OF LAND.
AND IT PROVIDES THE DEPARTMENT
OF GENERAL SERVICES WOULD
DETERMINE.
THE TERMS AND CONDITIONS THAT
WOULD BE IN THE BEST INTERESTS
OF THE STATE.
JUST AS IT DOES WITH THE SALE OF
ANY PROPERTY.
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
WOULD FOLLOW THEIR STANDARD
PROCEDURE WHICH PRESUMABLY
INCLUDES CREEK OBTAINING A
CURRENT APPRAISAL --
THE ASSERTION THAT IT'S GOING TO
BE BELOW THIS AND THAT BELOW
MARKET THIS AND THAT.
EYES JUST DAY A SPECULATION ON
THEIR PART --
OBVIOUSLY --
MONEY WAS SET ASIDE PICKED OVER
NINE MILLION DOLLARS TO PURCHASE
THE LAND MANY.
MANY YEARS AGO WHICH IS WHY WE
HAVE THIS.
YEAH ONE CAN COME TO ANY
CONCLUSION THEY WISH ABOUT THE
VALUE IT MIGHT PROVIDE A UPON A
SALE BUT ONCE AGAIN.
THE DECISION TO SELL IS IT
REMAINS IN AND THEY AYE AYE AND
TO THE AUTHORITY OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF PARKING RACK AND
THE OFF HIGHWAY.
VEHICLE CONDITION WHO ARE THERE
TO PROMOTE THE SPORT.
IT REMAINS IN THEIR IN THEIR
JURISDICTION AS TO WHETHER OR
NOT THEY WOULD EVEN CONTEMPLATE
[inaudible]
A SALE.
I UNDERSTAND IT THE SIMPLY AS I
THINK YOU SAID EARLIER ADDING
ADDITIONAL OPTION OR A PUTTING A
ANOTHER OPTION ON THE TABLE BUT
AGAIN JUST TO BE CLEAR IF I VOTE
FOR THIS TODAY WHAT I'M.
WHAT I'M SAYING IS IF IT TO THE
IF IT IS EVER SOLD FOR LESS THAN
FAIR MARKET THAT'S BECAUSE IT'S
GONNA BE RETAINED AS OPEN SPACE
BY ANOTHER PUBLIC AGENCY?
I WOULD BE BECAUSE THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
WOULD AS THEY DID WITH ALL.
OUR STATE PROPERTY MAKE AN
ASSESSMENT ABOUT --
WITH WHAT THE SALE WOULD BE IN
TERMS OF THE BEST INTEREST OF
THE STATE --
ARE THIS BILL A A THAT REQUIRES
THAT IF THERE IS A SALE IT WOULD
BE FOR CONSERVATION PURPOSES
ONLY.
THAT WOULD BE THE ONLY AT RA
ALLOWED USE IF THERE WAS A SALE
TO TAKE PLACE.
AND I WOULD NOTE THAT THERE IS
THAT IN A NEIGHBORING I'D --
BUT FIND THAT IS INDICATED THAT
THAT THEY HAVE THE MONEY SET
ASIDE IT THAT'S THIS DOES BECOME
AVAILABLE FOR SALE THEY'D BE
VERY INTERESTED IN PURCHASING IT
SO THERE'S A IT'S ACTUALLY
WILLING BUYER ON THE SIDELINES
NOW.
ALLOWING THE DEPARTMENT OF
PARKING RACK AND THE OFF HIGHWAY
VEHICLE COMMISSION DECIDE WHAT
THEY THINK IS IN THEIR BEST
INTEREST YOU CAN.
SIT IN COURT AND LITIGATE THIS
FOR YEARS AND YEARS AND YEARS AS
IT HAS BEEN.
OR YOU CAN DECIDE THERE MIGHT BE
ANOTHER OPTION AT THIS BILL
WOULD PROVIDE THAT MISTER CHAIR
POINT INFORMATION YET THE ON AND
SOME ARE NOT YOU --
PROPERTY --
PAGE TWO LINES NINETEEN TWENTIES
SPECIFY IN THE BILL --
MAY TRANSFER THE LAND TO LOCAL
AGENCY OR NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
FOR LESS THAN FAIR MARKET --
WAS NOT PUBLIC AGENCY
[inaudible]
AND THE YEAH.
BUT RIGHT WILL KNOW THAT THE
BILL SAYS WHAT IT SAYS DOWN.
BUT I THINK YOU'RE.
RIGHT.
I THINK THE POINT THAT I'M
TRYING TO MAKE.
IS IT IS NOT THE SIZE OF THIRTY
ONE HUNDRED ACRES FOR
RESIDENTIAL COME COMMERCIAL
DEVELOPMENT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
OPEN SPACE CONSERVATION.
AND THAT DOES HAVE A PUBLIC
BENEFIT AND LET'S LET LEAD TO
MISSED WELL BUT YOU GLORIFIED
NURSES ARE GOING PROFIT
ORGANIZATION I MEAN I HAVE
PLENTY OF NONPROFIT CONSERVANCY
THAT OPERATE PUBLIC LANDS AND IN
MY DISTRICT I MEAN THAT'S IF YOU
HAVE A DEBATE ABOUT THE OVERALL.
A NATURE OF WHAT NONPROFIT IMAGE
HARPER WE CAN HAVE A DEBATE I
HEARD YOUR COMMENTS PREVIOUSLY
I'M NOT SURE WHY YOU'RE CHOOSING
TO TAKE MY TIME TO TO CASTIGATE
ME OVER A BILL THAT'S NOT MINE
BUT I'M SIMPLY TRYING INQUIRE
ABOUT INFORMATION SO PLEASE.
KEEP YOUR COLLEAGUE THAT
COURTESY WHEN I'M SO TO CREATE
ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY YOU MENTION
A NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION THAT IS
FUNDED.
THAT IS DOING WORK ADJACENT
ALREADY YES WHAT KIND OF WORK
THEY DO IN THAT CASE ACTUALLY OF
A FUND THAT WAS CREATED THAT
WITH THE CITING OF A LANDFILL.
WHERE --
PEOPLE AGREED SAID THAT A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF FEES WOULD GO
INTO THIS FUND FOR LAND
PRESERVATION OF THE AREA SO.
THIS SITE LANDFILL AND CITY --
HAS BEEN --
HAS QUITE A BANK ACCOUNT NOW
THAT IF THEY SO CHOOSE COULD BUY
THIS LAND THAT'S VERY NEAR THERE.
ERA AND THAT'S IN THE
JURISDICTION OF THEIR OF WHAT'S
BEEN REQUIRED. TO TO LET THE TO
PRESERVE LAND MISS CHAIR I KNOW
HE'S A FAIR AMOUNT OF TIME SAYS
MISTER HARPER --
BUT I I WOULD WOULD JUST KNOW
FROM YOU MISTER GLAZER THIS IS
NOT YOU DOING THE SOLO --
THERE WAS NUMBER SPEAKERS AND
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE
SUPPORTED THIS --
ADDITIONAL YOU HAVE CO AUTHORS
OF SENATOR GALGIANI HILL BY
KOWSKI WIENER ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
BERMAN BONTA CHIU GRAYSON LIVING
AND TING I POINT THAT OUT SIMPLY
BECAUSE THIS DOES SEEM LIKE A
DISTRICT BILL.
AND IT'S DIFFICULT FOR ME TO
UNDERSTAND FOR PROPERTY I'VE NOT
BEEN TO BEFORE THE COMPLEXITIES
ARE HERE BUT WHAT I AM PICKING
UP IS THAT THERE'S BEEN.
A LOT A WHOLE LOT NOTHING DONE
FOR QUITE A USED ON THE PERHAPS
THIS COULD SHAKE LOOSE SOMETHING
THAT ACTUALLY HAPPENED ON THE
SITE RATHER THAN THE ONGOING
CONTROVERSY THAT SEEMS TO BE
GOING ON HERE IS THAT RIGHT.
THAT'S RIGHT MISS YOU THAT
THAT'S RIGHT I WOULD ALSO ADD
THAT OF THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER THAT --
IS THAT.
OVERLAPS THIS PROPERTY IS
ASSEMBLY WOMAN CATHARINE BAKER
AND SHE IS A CO AUTHOR OF THIS
BILL IS IS DISTINCTLY A DISTRICT
ISSUE.
THAT WE HAVE STAYED ON THE
SIDELINES AND WATCH THE FIGHT GO
ON FOR YEARS.
AND IT'S OUR OF MUTUAL EFFORT
WITHOUT TAKING SIDES ON IT FOR
ANY ONE SIDE OR THE OTHER.
JUST CREATE AN OPTION THAT IF
THE POWERS THAT BE DECIDED THAT
THIS LITIGATION IS GOING NOWHERE
AND WE LOVE TO USE THAT MONEY TO
ACQUIRE.
OFF HIGHWAY SPACE ELSEWHERE THEY
WOULD HAVE A TOOL IN WHICH TO
ENGAGE IN THAT.
THE NETWORK LIVE THE BILL'S CHIN.
AND THERE IS A MOTION.
ON HIS SECOND A BIAS IN THE
RIVER LEVINE.
YES SUMMER MATHIS THANK YOU.
TOM FOR FIRST I UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORTANCE OF RUNNING DISTRICT
BILL CHATTER UNDISTURBED BILLS --
QUITE OFTEN MYSELF --
TO WITH THE PICTURES A ENDING
THERE'S SOME GREAT POINTS THAT
IS FIRE SEASONAL IN IN YEAH WE
CAN SAY A PICTURE IS WORTH A
THOUSAND WORDS BUT THAT THE
REALITY IS IS IT'S ALL IN THE
CONTEXT WHEN THE PICTURE WAS
TAKEN AND ALL OF THAT --
YOU KNOW.
THEY ARE.
OHB GUYS ARE OFF ROADERS ARE OUR
GREAT STEWARDS OF THE LAND.
NOW FOR ME IT'S VERY TRAGIC THAT
EVERY SINGLE YEAR AS I SIT ON
THIS COMMITTEE FOR THE LAST
FORTY YEARS --
I'VE SEEN THE STATE I'VE SEEN
MEMBERS TRY TO TAKE AWAY
[inaudible]
LAND USE FOR OUR OFF HIGHWAY
VEHICLES IN.
IT'S VERY DISCOURAGING BECAUSE
WE DON'T HAVE VERY MUCH OF THAT
SPACE AVAILABLE.
YOU KNOW I CONSIDER NOT TO LOOK
AT THESE PICTURES I CAN YOU KNOW
AS AS AN AGRICULTURE GUY CAN GO.
NO THAT'S THAT'S GREAT SPACE FOR
FOR CATTLE GRAZING DO OTHER
THINGS AS WELL.
BLIGHT.
I'M NOT SITTING HERE ADVOCATING
THAT WE SELL THAT PROPERTY THE
YOU KNOW THE CATTLEMEN'S.
WE NEED TO KEEP THE SPACE THERE
IT'S THERE FOR A REASON AND IT'S
THERE FOR PEOPLE DIRECTORY.
I CAN UNDERSTAND GROUPS WANTING
TO SAY HEY LOOK WE CAN.
YES SELL IT TO US WILL CLEAN UP
WILL DO SOMETHING ELSE WITH IT.
THAT THAT'S NICE BOY.
SPACE EXISTS AS AN OFF ROAD
SPACE. FOR PEOPLE OF RECREATION
WE ONLY HAVE VERY FEW OF THOSE
SPACES LEFT IN CALIFORNIA WE
NEED TO HOLD ON TO THOSE.
BECAUSE WHAT HAPPENS IN AND I'LL
TELL YOU HAVE BEEN A GUY FROM A
RURAL DISTRICT.
WHAT HAPPENS IF YOU LOSE THAT
SPACE?
THEN YOU HAVE TRESPASSING ISSUES
THEN YOU HAVE PEOPLE TAKING
THEIR OFFER OF VEHICLES ROF
HIGHWAY VEHICLES ARIANNA COLUMN.
ON TO OTHER PEOPLE'S LANDS A
STRONG AGRICULTURAL CROPS.
STRAINED RANGE LANDS AND OTHER
THINGS IS IMPORTANT. TO THE
COMMERCE IN IN. TO ENSURE THAT
THERE SOMEWHERE FOR THESE PEOPLE
TO GO SEE THE SAME REASON WHY WE
STARTED BUILDING SKATEPARKS IN
THE NINETIES.
BECAUSE EVERYBODY WAS TIRED
EVERYTHING AND TORE UP SO LEGAL
SKATEPARKS WE HAVE OFF ROAD
VEHICLE PARKS FOR THE SAME
REASON.
BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT TO SEE
THIS HAPPENING ON PRIVATE LANDS.
THAT ARE OWNED THAT ARE USED FOR
COMMERCIAL USE OR ANYTHING ELSE.
WE WE HAVE THESE PARKS THERE TO
PROVIDE A SAFE SPACE. FOR OFF
ROADERS TO GOV RECREATION.
AND I'M SORRY I CANNOT SUPPORT
TAKING THAT AWAY FROM THEM.
MISTER CHAIRMAN CANCER JUST A
QUEST WAS UNDERNEATH OF THE YES
OF MISTER MCKAY I WAS GOING TO
GIVE YOU AN OPPORTUNITY TO JUST.
REBUT ANY THINGS THAT HAD COME
UP DURING THE DISCUSSIONS HOUR
HOLTER REAL QUICK IN TERMS OF
THE USE OF THE LAND.
IT IS INACCURATE TO SUGGEST.
BED SUDDENLY BECAUSE THEY WERE
UNDER PRESSURE.
THE OFF HIGHWAY ROAD DIVISION
DECIDED TO MITIGATE A CERTAIN
PROPERTY IN ORDER TO APPEASE
THIS LEGISLATURE OR ANYONE ELSE.
LET'S BE VERY CLEAR IN THE
LEGISLATION THAT WAS RUN LAST
YEAR.
IT IS NOT DISCRETIONARY.
THEY HAVE TO MITIGATE THE SLANT
SOLDIERS PASSED THESE PICTURES
AROUND TAKE A QUICK LOOK AT THEM.
BUT HERE'S THE DEAL.
IF THEY DO NOT MITIGATE THEN IT
IS CLOSED.
IT IS CLOSED.
AND ONE OF THE DISCUSSIONS I HAD
LAST YEAR WAS THE IDEA TO WOULD
MITIGATE IT AND CLOSE IT FOREVER
WHICH OF COURSE MADE NO SENSE
BECAUSE I'M A VERY SHORT TIME.
WE WOULDN'T HAVE THESE PARKS
ANYMORE BUT THE MITIGATION IS
NOT DISCRETIONARY THEY HAVE TO
MITIGATE IT THEY DO IT AN
EXTRAORDINARY PART OF THEIR
EXPENSES DOWN ON THAT.
THE SECOND THING.
PROBABLY THE MOST DISTURBING
THING I'VE HEARD TODAY.
IS THAT SENATOR GLAZERS
SUGGESTION.
THAT THIS BILL PROVIDES AN
OPTION AND NOTHING ELSE AND THAT
HE DOESN'T HAVE A DOG IN THE
FIGHT [inaudible]
AND YET.
IF LEFT TO HIS OWN DEVICES HE
WOULD ALREADY SELL THE LAND TO
SOMEBODY WHO'S IN LINE TO BUY IT.
THE LAND CAN BE PURCHASED BY A
NONPUBLIC ENTITY FETCHED THAT'S
TRUE.
IT WILL BE OPEN LAND AND THAT IS
OF VALUE TO SOME FOLKS.
BUT THE TRUTH IS IT WILL NOT BE
ALLOWED TO BE USED FOR ANY OFF
HIGHWAY VEHICLE RECREATION FOR
WHICH IT WAS INITIALLY INTENDED.
MY SUGGESTION AGAIN IS THAT WE
DO A HEARING ON THIS.
AND GET TO THE BOTTOM OF IT TO
SAY THAT THIS IS A DISTRICT BILL
ALONE.
IS INACCURATE IT IS A STATE PARK
ARE WE GOING TO ALLOW EVERY
SINGLE DISTRICT NOW TO DECIDE
HOW STATE PROPERTIES ARE GOING
TO BE USED.
THE LAST THING I WILL SAY IS
SOMEONE MUCH SMARTER THAN E WHO
HAS BEEN WORKING ON THIS FOR A
LONG TIME.
HAS MADE A SUGGESTION THAT I
THINK MAKES SENSE. TO BRING
PARTIES TOGETHER IN A HEARING IN
A DISCUSSION AND TALK THAT
PERHAPS THERE'S MULTI USE THAT
CAN BE DONE ON THIS PROPERTY.
LET'S START FINDING RESOLUTION
LET'S STOP THE IDEA OF THE
FIGHTING BUT LET'S DO IT IN A
WAY THAT IS NOT PUNITIVE TO THE
OFF HIGHWAY VEHICLE DIVISION
ONLY EIGHT PARKS FOLKS ONLY
EIGHT PARKS.
AND IF YOU ALLOW EACH SENATOR
EACH ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO DECIDE
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO SELL STATE
PROPERTY.
BEFORE YOU KNOW WE'RE GONNA SIDE
THAT SHERIFF'S INTO A HIGHWAY
PATROLMAN FIRST.
THE YOU KNOW FOR GONNA LOSE THE
REASONS THAT WE HAVE THESE
DISTINCTIONS IN THE BEGINNING.
I THANK YOU MR MCHALE --
AND NOT SEE ANY OTHER --
COMMENTS --
I WILL JUST SAY YOU KNOW IT IS
THE SECOND YEAR THAT I KNOW
WE'VE HAD THE SAME ISSUE MAYBE A
DIFFERENT BILL THAT SAME ISSUE --
IN THIS COMMITTEE AND IT SEEMS
LIKE THERE ARE VERY STRONG.
YOU KNOW STRONGLY HELD VIEWS IN
THE LOCAL COMMUNITY OBVIOUSLY
WERE.
YOU KNOW MOST OF US DON'T LIVE
IN THAT DISTRICT RIGHT DOWN AND
YOU ARE ARE KIND OF BEING ASKED
TO MAYBE.
ASCERTAIN OR MAKE A DECISION
THAT'S YOU KNOW.
SOMETHING THAT PEOPLE IN THAT
AREA VERY --
PASSIONATE ABOUT RIGHT AND SO
THAT DOES MAKE KIND OF TOUGH
MAYBE THAT IS SOMETHING THAT A
HEARING IN THE FUTURE MIGHT HELP
PROVIDE SOME MORE.
CLARITY AND AND PROVIDE A LOT
MORE OF ALL THE DIFFERENT VIEWS
ASSOCIATE HERE ONE THING I WOULD
JUST SAY AS SENATORS.
BECAUSE IT IT SOUNDS TO ME LIKE
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IS THAT.
YOU WANT TO GIVE THIS OPTION --
AT NIGHT I THINK I HEARD THAT
PRETTY CLEARLY FROM YOUR FROM
YOUR TESTIMONY.
BUT I THINK THE CONCERN FROM THE
O. H. V. SIDE IS WHAT THIS IS
SOLD FOR LESS THAN FAIR MARKET
VALUE WE DON'T RECOUP.
THE MONEY TO OH HV WHICH IS THE
WHOLE POINT OF HAVING NO WAY TO
BE IS TO PROVIDE THE SPACES AND
TO ENSURE THAT THERE IS.
AND THIS PLACE FOR THE OFF A YOU
OFF OFF ROAD VEHICLES --
THEN WE CAN'T REALLY GET THAT
REPLACEMENT OR FIND SOME OTHER
AREAS SO WHY NOT JUST TAKE OUT
OF THEIR THAT LANGUAGES YOU
COULD SELL IT FOR LESS --
THEM FAIR MARKET VALUE.
AB WELL AND I WOULD SAY THAT
WERE FOLLOWING CURRENT STATE LAW.
AND I THINK YOU MAKE AN
ASSUMPTION THAT I THINK IS A
FAULTY ONE THE FOLKS THAT ARE IN
CHARGE OF THIS CHOICE ARE THE
PEOPLE THAT.
I YOU LIKENED --
OTHERS AT THIS PANEL LIKE YOU
KNOW WE'RE TO BE --
HIV IS THAT IS THAT THE KEY TO
THE OFF HIGHWAY VEHICLE
COMMISSION THAT THEY'RE THERE TO
SUPPORT THE SPORTS.
AND THEY'RE DIRECTLY ON THE
FRONT LAWN OF THESE CHOICES OF
WHAT. TO DAG WHAT THEY DO
TOMORROW.
AND THAT IT THAT IT DID NOT
TRUST THEIR JUDGMENT ABOUT
WHAT'S IN THE BEST INTEREST OF
OFF ROAD I WOULD AGREE WITH THAT.
THAT THEY FEEL LIKE THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO GET THE VALUE THAT THEY
WOULD REQUIRE MORE THAN THEY
WERE GONNA TAKE THAT INTO
ACCOUNT IN THE CHOICE THAT THEY
MAKE RIGHT IF YOU'RE ON THAT
COMMISSION.
USAGI WE COULD SELL IT BUT WE
CAN ONLY GET ACTS WELL MAYBE WE
SHOULD HOLD ON TO IT AND
CONTINUE THE LITIGATION AND THE
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS ARE BEING
SPENT TO FIGHT THIS THING. FOR
THE YEARS PASSED IN THE YEARS IN
THE FUTURE THEY COULD MAKE THAT
CHOICE.
BUT IT'S THEIR CHOICE TO MAKE.
AND I'M SAYING THAT IF YOU LOVE
OFF HIGHWAY VEHICLE.
ACTIVITY THAT THERE IS A SERIOUS
THEIR IT.
THAT.
A CASE CAN BE MADE.
THAT HEY MAN GOOD WE WOULD WE
WANTED TO EXPAND ITS NOT WORK
AND WE'RE IN LITIGATION FOR EVER
LET'SFIND A BETTER USE OF THAT
MONEY LET'S GET THAT ACTIVITY AT
A PLACE THAT.
CAN BE WELCOMED AND EMBRACED AND
AND CREATED.
AND RATHER THAN BEING IN THIS
QUAGMIRE IN THE MUD WHERE
NOTHING HAPPENS AND THAT'S
THAT'S WHERE I THINK ASSEMBLY
WOMAN BAKER AND I'VE GOTTEN IN
THIS SPACE IS THAT.
THEY'VE BEEN THE MUD WRESTLING
FOR A LONG TIME AND NOTHING'S
COME OUT OF IT AND SHE'S NOT OP
AGAINST OFF ROAD USE SONORA LIFE
IT'S DONE AND MANAGE CORRECTLY
[inaudible]
BUT DO YOU WANT TO HAVE THE
OPTION IF YOU THINK THAT THIS IS
GOING NOWHERE THAT'S REALLY THE
PURPOSE OF THE BILL THAT
DISTRACTING CHAIR IN.
A FAIR POINT YOU KNOW THAT THEY
WOULD MAKE THAT DECISION --
YEAH I THINK THAT THEY ARE THERE.
YA YOU WILL BE WILL WHO'S ON
THAT WHAT WHO SERVES ON IT YOU
KNOW IT'S ARE IT'S A GOVERNMENT
APPOINTED BOARD COULD CHANGE
OVER TIME.
AND THEN I THINK THE BIGGER THE
BIGGER POINT MADE BY SOME OR
HARPER IS WE ARE THIS IS PUBLIC
LAND I MEAN CERTAINLY WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE GONNA GET
AT LEAST FAIR MARKET VALUE FOR
EVER GOING.
TO SELL PUBLIC PROPERTY YOU KNOW
AND SO I THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE
CONCERNS BUT I KNOW WE'VE.
IT'S PROBABLY GOOD I THINK WE'VE
NAILED ALL THE ISSUES ASSOCIATED
WITH THIS BILL TODAY SO --
WITH THAT I DO HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND --
BY AS A MEMBER LEVINE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE --
I THINK UNDER THE THOUGHTFUL
CONVERSATION I KNOW THERE'S
PASSIONS ON ALL SIDES AS I SAY
WELCOME TO MY DISTRICT.
AND THAT I REALLY WASN'T TRYING
TO TAKE A SIDE I KNOW THERE'S AN
ASSERTION HERE.
I WHICH I THINK IS THAT NOT
PROPERLY MADE I I WANT TO GIVE
THE DECISION MAKERS WHICH ARE
PEOPLE WHO BELIEVE IN THIS
RECREATIONAL ACTIVITY SOME
CHOICES AND OPTIONS.
I CERTAINLY GOVERNOR* I
THINK WE PUT GOOD APPOINTEES ON
THEIR END.
OF THE GIVEN TO WORRY ABOUT --
BUT I I DO THINK THAT --
IT'S IT'S A WORD THE BILL IT'S A
DISTRICT BILL BUT I'D ASK YOU TO
CONSIDER IT FAVORABLY AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
I AGREE I THINK HE WOULD MAKE
SOME GOOD APPOINTMENTS AND OKAY
WITH THAT MADAM CLERK WOULD YOU
PLEASE.
IT IT THIS IS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE CHAIR --
TO THE ASSEMBLY ACCOUNTABILITY
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW
[inaudible]
COMMITTEE.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GALLAGHER NO GALLAGHER NO
BIGELOW [inaudible]
CARILLO.
CHOI NO CHOI NO CHIU
[inaudible]
FRIEDMAN.
GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE HARPER NO HARPER NO
KALRA.
LEVINE AYE LEVINE AYE MATHIS NO
MATHIS NO RUBIO SALAS.
SALAS NOT VOTING [inaudible]
WOULD. TWO TO FOUR THAT WILL
CLEAR THAT BELONG BECAUSE THEY
HAVE OTHER MEMBERS OF THE COMEY
THANK YOU SENATOR [inaudible]
LISA NEVER [inaudible]
OKAY.
OKAY SENATOR BILL.
S. B. THIRTEEN NO.
ONE WHICH I AM THINKING WILL BE
MUCH LESS CONTROVERSIAL THAN OUR
LAST -- BILL.
WELL WE'LL SEE.
TALK ABOUT DAMS.
NOW THAT IS A VERY LIKE BOARD
SUBJECT AS YOU KNOW RIGHT --
SENATOR BILL PLEASE PROCEED YEAH
THANK YOU --
MEMBERS --
THIS BILL --
S. B. --
THIRTEEN NO --
ONE IS A BILL THAT WOULD HELP
EXPEDITE FLOOD.
AND DAM SAFETY PROJECTS --
BY PERMITTING PROVIDING PERMIT
APPLICANTS WITH A MECHANISM. FOR
US UP SUPPLE.
CONSTRUCTS WILL TUITION NOW OVER
A YEAR AGO --
IN SAN JOSE --
WE HAD --
FOURTEEN THOUSAND CONSTITUENTS
IN MY DISTRICT WERE DISPLACED BY
THE KILEY CREEK FLOOD.
IN A BECAUSE LE AS OF NOW WE
DON'T KNOW THE TOTAL AMOUNT BUT
SEVENTY THREE MILLION.
AND DAMAGES DEVASTATED --
MANY PEOPLE'S HOMES.
AND WE'VE HAD OTHER DISASTERS IN
CALIFORNIA OF THEN A PAINFULLY
DEMONSTRATED.
THE THREAT THAT THEY POSE TO
HUMAN LIFE THE FLOOD CONTROL
PROJECTS --
INTENSE SAFETY ENHANCEMENTS CAN
REDUCE.
THE RISKS OF NATURAL DISASTERS
AND SAVE LIVES.
SO THIS BILL [inaudible]
WILL PROVIDE PERMIT APPLICANTS
TO APPLY FOR SUPPLEMENTAL
[inaudible]
CONSULTATION.
IN ORDER TO FACILITATE EARLY
ENGAGEMENT.
WITH PERMIT AGENCIES.
OF THROUGH THIS KIND OF
CONSULTATION.
AGENCIES CAN IDENTIFY ACTIONS TO
HELP EXPEDITE THE REQUIRED
PERMITS CLARIFY AND DISCUSS
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS AND
MEDICATIONS.
AND PROVIDE FEEDBACK ON PROMOTE
DOCUMENTS.
POTENTIALLY SAVE --
AND RESOLVE ANY CONFLICTS.
THE PROJECT APPLICANTS WILL PAY
FEES.
COVER THE COST OF IT INTER
AGENCY TEAM COMPRISED OF THE
RELEVANT AGENCIES.
I WANT TO MAKE IT CLEAR THAT ANY
PROJECT WILL STILL BE SUBJECT.
TO THE ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW
PROCESS.
I THOUGHT TODAY HAVE WITNESSES
FROM THE SANTA CLARAVALLEY
WATER DISTRICT --
WE'VE HAD NO OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL.
URGENT AYE VOTE ON IT AND ALL
TURN OUT MY WITNESSES PLEASE
[inaudible]
OKAY WITNESSES.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS RACHEL
GETS AND THE DEPUTY
ADMINISTRATIVE OFFICER WITH THE
SENECA VALLEY WATER DISTRICT
WERE SPONSORING SB THIRTY NO ONE
BECAUSE DELIVERING FLOOD
PROTECTION.
WATER SUPPLY AND ENVIRONMENTAL
STEWARDSHIP PROJECTS IN A TIMELY
FASHION IS BECOMING INCREASINGLY
DIFFICULT THIS BILL SIX A
SOLUTION THAT BOTH BOLSTER STATE
PERMITTING AGENCIES WITH MORE
RESOURCES.
AND IMPROVE THE ENVIRONMENT
REVIEW AND PRINT PROCESS HE
THREW ENHANCE CONSULTATION WITH
STATE PERMITTING AGENCIES.
I WHERE HERE WITH ME TODAY IS
KURT LEUENBERGER FROM OUR
WATERSHED STORAGE BIN PLENTY
DIVISION TALK MORE ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES.
WE FACE AND HOW S. B. THIRTY NO
ONE WILL HELP DELIVER THESE
FLOOD RISK REDUCTION AND DAM
SAFETY PROJECTS FASTER WITHOUT
COMPROMISING ON ENVIRONMENT
PROTECTION.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
KURT LEUENBERGER AND A SENIOR
WATER RESOURCE SPECIALIST
WORKING FOR THE WATERSHED
STEWARDSHIP AND PLANNING
DIVISION.
OF THE SENATOR VALLEY WATER
DISTRICT THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY SPEAK TODAY.
A GETTING A MAJOR FLOOD RISK
REDUCTION AGAIN SAFETY PROJECT
THROUGH THE ENVIRONMENT RUBIO
PERMIT APPROVAL TAKES YEARS AND
AT TIMELINE HAS GOTTEN LONGER AS
THE NUMBER OF PERMANENT
LOCATIONS HAVE INCREASED.
STAFF RESOURCES IN STATE BERMAN
AGENCIES HAVE NOT.
THESE AGENCIES ARE OPERATING IN
TRIAGE MODE.
MEANING THEY ONLY HAVE THE FULL
TIME TO FULLY ENGAGE ON THE
PERMIT APPLICATION BEFORE THEN
AND VERY LITTLE CAPACITY TO
PROVIDE EARLY CONSULTATION
PROJECT DESIGN AN ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEW.
UNFORTUNATELY THE LACK OF FULL
ENGAGEMENT.
BY STATE PERMITTING AGENCIES
EARLY IN THE PROCESS IS A
SIGNIFICANT TRIBUTE DELAYS
ENVIRONMENTAL PERMIT ISSUANCE.
THE RESULT IS COSTLY PROJECT
REDESIGNS UNPLANNED MITIGATION
COSTS AND MOST CONCERNING
SIGNIFICANT DELAY OF THE LIFE
SAFETY PROJECTS SUCH AS FLOOD
PROTECTION IN DAM SAFETY.
S. B. THIRTEEN A ONE WILL HELP
REMEDY THESE ISSUES PROVIDING A
FRAMEWORK FOR SUPPLEMENTAL
CONSULTATION WITH STATE AGENCIES
EARLY IN THE DESIGN OF FLATTENED
AND SAFETY PROJECTS AND STAY
ENGAGED THROUGHOUT THE
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW AND
PERMITTING PROCESS.
THIS MECHANISM IS MODELED AFTER
SIMILAR FRAMEWORK RECENTLY
DEVELOPED SEVERAL FEDERAL ANDSTATE REGULATORY AGENCIES TO
REDUCE PERMITTING TIME FOR A
MULTI BENEFIT RESTORATION
PROJECTS AROUND SAN FRANCISCO
BAY.
EARLY ENGAGEMENT THROUGH
SUBLIMINAL CONSULTATION WILL
MAKE THE SECRET PROCESS BETTER
BY GETTING IT SIGNIFICANT
VIOLENT TAX IDENTIFIED BY STATE
AGENCIES AND ANY PROPOSED
LITIGATIONS INTO THE DRAFT THE
I. R. FOR STAKEHOLDER REVIEW AND
COMMENT.
OUR GOAL IS MORE COLLABORATION
ON THE TIMELY DELIVERY OF VITAL
FLOOD RISK REDUCTION DANCE
SAFETY PROJECTS MORE RESOURCES
FOR STATE PERMITTING AGENCIES
IMPROVE TRANSPARENCY THROUGH A
SEQUEL.
AND MORE COMPLETE PERMIT
APPLICATIONS S. B. THIRTY NO ONE
WILL DELIVER FLED INDIAN SAFETY
PROJECT PERMITTING FASTER
SMARTER WITH MORE TRANSPARENCY
WITHOUT COMPROMISING
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION.
I URGE YOUR SUPPORT SB THIRTEEN
A ONE THANK YOU.
THINK ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING REYES HE THOMPSON
WITH METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT
OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
TOM MICHAEL RIGHT AGAIN ON
BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS SANTA CLARA COUNTY
IN SPORT.
KIANA SECURITY ON BEHALF OF THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT THINKING.
SPENCER SOCKS THAT WELCOME GROUP
ON BEHALF OF THE SANTA CRUZ
COUNTY FLIGHT CONTROLS AND SEVEN
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU WITHOUT ANY OTHER
PEOPLE IN TESTIMONY FOR SUPPORT
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION.
MAKE A MOTION PATH TO PASS IT ON
MOTIONS THEIR SECOND WE'VE GOT A
SECOND MISTER.
A DOCTOR CHOI MADE THE MOTION
ESTHER SALAS SECOND [inaudible]
ANY. FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
[inaudible]
FOR MISTER BELL [inaudible]
SCENE.
NINE AND DATA SEGMENT CLOSE.
MAKING THINGS GO FASTER SAVES
MONEY SAVES THE TAXPAYERS MONEY.
OF THIS IS A WIN FOR THE
TAXPAYERS ARE CHEN ARE VOTE.
GREAT THANK YOU [inaudible]
SCUTTLED.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
EDUARDO GARCIA GALLAGHER.
BIGELOW CARILLO CHOI YES CHOI
AYE CHU [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN GLORIA HARPER LEVEL.
HARPER NOT VOTING CHOLERA.
LEVINE BY LEVINE AYE MATHIS
[inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SALAS.
SALAS I WOULD [inaudible] THREE
THE VOTE IS THREE ZERO WILL KEEP
THE ROLE OPEN FOR YOU THANK
WELCOME.
I'D THE NEXT AUTHOR IS AYE MR
STERN [inaudible]
PAGING [inaudible]
MR STERN [inaudible]
AND RESTART [inaudible]
WHAT?
I ANSWER HIM CALL.
AT U. WELCOME OWNER THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR.
WELL I THINK YOU --
FIRST OF ALL MISTER CHAIR AND
YOUR STAFF FOR ALL THE HARD WORK
YOU PUT IN THE BILL --
AND YEAH THIS IS.
IT'S IMPORTANT MEASURE WERE
FACING HERE TODAY NOT OFTEN IN
CALIFORNIA DO WE HAVE THE
ABILITY TO IMPACT.
THE ENTIRE WORLD --
WITH ONE STROKE OF A PEN BUT I I
THINK THIS BILL COULD ACTUALLY
BE WHAT TURNS THE TIDE IN THE
FIGHT TO PRESERVE THE THE LAST
REMAINING ICONIC ENDANGERED
AFRICAN SPECIES S. B. FOURTEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN DOES THAT BY
PROHIBITING THE POSSESSION OF
BODY PARTS. ELEVEN ICONIC
AVERAGE ENDANGERED SPECIES AND
EARLIER THIS YEAR AS YOU KNOW WE
LAWSUIT AND AYE THE LAST MALE
NORTHERN WHITE RHINO.
AND THE STRANGEST KEEP
CONTINUING --
ELEPHANTS ARE DOWN 30% IN IN
POPULATION OVER THE LAST --
SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN LINES ARE
DOWN 43% FROM NINETEEN THROUGH
TWENTY FOURTEEN IN THE BLACK
RHINO IS DOES DECLINE 97% SINCE
NINETEEN SEVENTY I THINK THE
ESSENCE OF HIS BILL.
IS THAT [inaudible]
CONSERVATION STRATEGY NEED NOT
ADOPT A POLICY.
OF POACHING AND OF KILLING TO
ACTUALLY ACHIEVE ITS ENDS.
THAT WE DON'T NEED TO KILL TO
CONSERVE AND THAT IN FACT --
THAT WHATEVER PROWESS --
SOME TOUGH GUY MAY FEEL BY
PUTTING --
MOUNTING ON ABOVE HIS MANTEL UM.
THE AN AFRICAN.
I'LL A FENCE OR A BLACK RHINO --
THAT THAT THAT THAT CELEBRATION
OF OF MASCULINITY IS --
IS DEAD IT'S IT'S OUTDATED AND
THAT HAS TO AND AND THIS YEAR OF
TROPHY HUNTING --
HAST AND AND I THINK IT STARTS
WITH US SO --
I HAVE FOLKS YOU KNOW MUCH MORE
ABOUT THIS THAN I HERE WITH ME
TODAY SO WITH THAT I JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK.
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE --
AND ALLOW --
WHO WANTS TO GO FIRST?
IF YOU DON'T MIND OKAY SO NICK
SACKETS WITH SOCIAL COMPASSION
LEGISLATION.
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS NICHOLAS
SACKETT DIRECTOR OF LEGISLATIVE
AFFAIRS FOR SOCIAL COMPASSION
LEGISLATION WE ARE HONORED TO BE
THE SPONSOR OF THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION.
THIS BILL IS IMPORTANT STEP IN
REDUCING UNNECESSARY AND
UNSUSTAINABLE KILLING OF
ELEPHANTS LIONS RHINOS AND OTHER
SPECIES THAT ARE.
UNDER --
THREAT DUE TO HABITAT LOSS
POACHING AS WELL IS LAWFUL
KILLING BY INTERNATIONAL TROPHY
HUNTERS.
WE CAN'T STOP THE DECLINE TO
EXTINCTION OF THESE ANIMALS
WITHOUT ADDRESSING EACH ASPECT
DE UNITED STATES IS THE LARGEST
IMPORTER OF WILDLIFE TROPHIES IN
THE WORLD WITH HUNDREDS OF
ELEPHANTS IN THOUSANDS OF LINES
KILLED AN IMPORTED OVER THE PAST
DECADE.
SADLY MANY OF THESE ANIMALS ARE
KILLED BY CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
AND BROUGHT INTO THE STATE.
WHILE HUNTERS REGULARLY CITE THE
SUSTAINABLE NATURE OF THEIR TAKE
AND THE SO CALLED CONSERVATION
BENEFIT THAT FLOW FROM SUCH
KILLING.
NO STUDIES HAVE PROVEN THIS TO
BE THE CASE.
THROUGHOUT AFRICA THE PURPORTED
ECONOMIC BENEFITS OF TROPHY
HUNTING GO TO WEALTHY HUNTING
OUTFITTERS AND CORRUPT OFFICIALS
[inaudible] FOR EXAMPLE.
BUT THERE'S EVIDENCE TO SUGGEST
THAT LESS THAN 3% OF TROPHY
HUNTING REVENUES ACTUALLY ARE
SHARED WITH THE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE.
A RESPONSIBLE FOR PROTECTING
THESE ANIMALS MEANWHILE THE
ECONOMIC BENEFITS FROM ECO
TOURISM DWARF ALL THOSE FORMS OF
DWARF OTHER FORMS OF REVENUE FOR
THESE COUNTRIES WHILE NOT
DECIMATING ENDANGERED SPECIES.
TROPHY HUNTING RESULTS NOT JUST
IN THE NEEDLESS DEATH OF
INDIVIDUAL ANIMALS BUDDY CREATES
IS A SCENARIO WHERE.
A GOOD GENES ARE BEING TAKEN OUT
OF THE GENE POOL ON THESE
ANIMALS ARE GENETIC POOL OR
DECLINING.
A I ONE EVEN EXAMPLE A LINE UP
POPULATIONS HAVE DECLINED ALMOST
50% THE LAST TWO DECADES BECAUSE
THE TROPHY HUNTING.
IN THE SAME PERIOD OVER TWENTY
THOUSAND AFRICAN LINE PARTS WERE
TRADED REPRESENTING OVER SEVEN
THOUSAND INDIVIDUAL ALLIANCE AND
SHAMEFULLY.
THE U. S. IMPORTER OVER HALF OF
THESE FORM OF TROPHIES.
SO DESPITE THE SHOCKING
POPULATION DECLINE IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION REVERSED THE
MORATORIUM ON IMPORTING THESE
IMPORTANT DANGER SPECIES MAKING
WAY. FOR EVEN MORE RAPID DECLINE
WE FACE WE ARE FACED WITH SOME
PREEMPTION ROADBLOCKS AND THAT
IS WHY I S. B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN IS NARROWLY TAILORED. TO
THREAD THE NEEDLE AND BE ABLE TO
DO WHAT CALIFORNIA'S ABLE TO DO
WHICH IS BANNED THE POSSESSION
AND STATE.
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY I AFTER
I BOW AND INTRODUCE A SAM JOE
HOA.
MY MY NAME IS SAM HALL.
I'M RETIRED THE PRETTY RESIDENT
AGENT CHARGE FOR THE SECOND
LARGEST PORT IN THE COUNTRY AND
HERE IN LOS ANGELES.
OF FORMER US FISH WILDLIFE AGENT
WITH TWENTY THREE YEARS
CORPORATE EXPERIENCE.
IN TWO THOUSAND LIMON WORLD'S
POPULATION REACH SEVEN BILLION
IS NOW SEVEN POINT SIX BILLION
MANY STRESSED ECOSYSTEMS LEAVE
LARGER MAMMALS.
VULNERABLE LIKE ELEPHANTS
GIRAFFES AND BOTH AFRICAN RHINO
SPECIES SEARS TROPHY HUNTERS
SEEK A QUARRY LIKE BLACK MAIN
LIONS AND RARE AFRICAN ELEPHANT
TUSKERS.
GENETIC VIABILITY CAN BE
IMPACTED COUPLED WITH THE MAN
FOR BODY PARTS IN TRADITIONAL
MEDICINE.
WIDESPREAD CORRUPTION PLAGUES
IMBABA WHEN SOUTH AFRICA WITH
LITTLE OR NO JAIL TIME FOR MOST
OFFENDERS.
MY TWO THOUSAND THREE
INVESTIGATION ON ALLEGATIONS OF
ILLEGAL FLYING HUNTINGTON
ZIMBABWE.
REVEALED THEIR POORLY WRITTEN
LAWS PREVENTED FEDERAL
PROSECUTION OF SUSPECT US TROPHY
HUNTERS.
INCLUDING A SIMILAR INCIDENTS
LIKE CECIL THE LION.
LISTEN AND EXTINCTION IN THE
EARLY EIGHTEEN HUNDREDS
PASSENGER PIGEON NUMBERS WERE
SEVERAL BILLION AND BY NINETEEN
HUNDRED NONE SURVIVED IN THE
WILD.
HISTORY DOES REPEAT ITSELF WITH
EXTINCTION.
LARGER SPECIES ARE VULNERABLE
LIONS ELEPHANTS RHINOS LEOPARDS
AND ABLE PARTS ARE EXPLOITED IN
THE GLOBAL ONLINE BLACK MARKET.
TRADE OF ILLEGAL WILDLIFE.
LARGE SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES
PROFIT FROM THE ILLICIT Y. LIFE
TRADE OF RHINO HORN ELEPHANT
IVORY INCLUDING LINE AND TIGER
CLAWS.
STEPHAN CON RENOWNED
WHISTLEBLOWER ATTORNEY
DOCUMENTED EXTENSIVE ILLICIT
TRADE THROUGH STING OPERATIONS
DETAILED IN THIS MONTH'S WIRED
MAGAZINE.
THE SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES ARE
REPORTEDLY AT THE CENTER OF THE
GLOBAL TRADE IN ENDANGERED
SPECIES.
TRAFFICKING IN ILLEGAL WHILE I
PARTS IS AKIN TO TAKE IN A
STOLEN VEHICLE AND SO IN THE
PARTS INDIVIDUALLY THEY'RE WORTH
MORE THAN THE WHOLE.
GROWTH OF THE ILLEGAL WILDLIFE
TRADE.
THE ILLEGAL WILDLIFE TRADE WAS
ESTIMATED AT TEN BILLION
ANNUALLY IN. TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN
TWENTY THREE BILLION IN TWO
THOUSAND AND FOURTEEN AND MORE
RECENTLY HUNDRED FIFTEEN BILLION
AFTER A RECENT MONTH LONG
INVESTIGATION IN NINETY TWO
COUNTRIES.
OVERNIGHT PARCEL SHIPPING VENUES
HAVE BEEN A PLATFORM FOR DECADES
THAT SUPPORT TRAFFIC IN A HOST
OF ILLEGAL WHILE I PARTS AND
PRODUCTS.
INCLUDING LIVE REPTILE SHIPPED
OVERNIGHT FROM AROUND THE GLOBE.
WELL IF CRIME SUPPORTS
TRANSNATIONAL CRIMINAL
SYNDICATES AND TERRORISM.
IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN MY
COLLEAGUE BRIAN CHRISTIE IN
NATIONAL GEOGRAPHIC'S WARLORDS
OF IVORY CHRONICLE THE ELEPHANT
IVORY TRADE TO TRANSNATIONAL
CRIMINAL SYNDICATES.
AND SUGGESTED EVIDENCE OF IVORY
TRAFFICKING USED TO FORGE LINKS
BETWEEN SEVERAL AFRICAN
TERRORIST GROUPS OTHER
INDEPENDENT REPORTS.
SUPPORT HIS ASSESSMENT.
THINK GLOBALLY ACT LOCALLY WITH
JANE GOODALL SUPPORTIVE S. B.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN AND THE
SUPPORTING EVIDENCE OF TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY IMPACTS ON THE
ILLEGAL WILDLIFE TRADE.
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATORS HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY MAKE A DIFFERENCE
WITH THIS KEY LEGISLATION IN A
PRODUCTIVE UNIFIED EFFORT.
THANK YOU KINDLY FOR ALL THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THIS CRITICAL LEGISLATION.
GREAT THANK YOU SO THOSE WHO ARE
IN SUPPORT OF PLEASED TO STATE
YOUR NAME IF YOU BELONG TO AN
ORGANIZATION THAT REPRESENTING
AND YOUR POSITION WHICH IS
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS JUDY MAN CREW SO
MY GROUP IS SOCIAL COMPASSION
AND LEGISLATION WE ARE THE
SPONSOR OF THE BILL.
AND I'M FROM LAGUNA BEACH
CALIFORNIA AND THIS IS A
NONPARTISAN ISSUE IT'S ABOUT
SAVING ANIMALS NOT ABOUT HUNTING
THANK YOU.
A MORENO AMBIANCE HERE CLUB
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
PATTY SCHENKER FOR LOS ANGELES
PER ANIMAL DEFENDERS
INTERNATIONAL WHAT IS HAPPENING
IS A GLOBAL TRAGEDY LET'S DO
SOMETHING THIS BILL DOES THANK
YOU.
SO BURKE IMAGE ON BEHALF OF THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
GLORIA BUTLER ON BEHALF OF
SOCIAL COMPASSIONATE LEGISLATION.
AND THE HUMANE SOCIETY NATIONAL
COUNCIL.
I SUPPORT.
SIMONE REYES LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA DO WHAT'S RIGHT FOR
ANIMALS IN SUPPORT.
KITTY CLEAR PRESIDENT OF WORLD
ANIMAL NEWS IN PEACE FOR ANIMALS
OUT OF LOS ANGELES I'M HERE
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF CHEN GOT
ALL.
AND WE ALL SUPPORT INCLUDING
JANE AND HER TEAM.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS AUNTIE
CYANA MCCONNELL DEFENSE ATTORNEY
AN ANIMAL RIGHTS ACTIVISTS THAT
SOCIAL COMPASSION LEGISLATION I
ASK THAT YOU SUPPORT THIS BILL
ANIMALS BELONG IN THE WILD AND
NOT ON THE WALL THINKING.
DEBORAH KLASSEN NEVADA
CALIFORNIA HUMANE SAY THE UNITED
STATES PLEASE SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING KRISTIN MONTHS OUT
WITH THE CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL
DIVERSITY AND ON BEHALF OF OUR
OVER A HUNDRED THOUSAND MEMBERS
AND SUPPORTERS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE SPELL THANK YOU.
ELIZABETH BAKER FROM SAN DIEGO
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KRISTIN BY IVAN STRATTON FROM
LOS ANGELES I SUPPORT.
CHRISTIE MOLLY FROM ROSELLE
CALIFORNIA PLEASE SUPPORT.
YOU SERVICE FROM LOS ANGELES AND
STRONG SUPPORT.
LESLIE DAVIES FROM SAN DIEGO
CALIFORNIA PLEASE SUPPORT.
BETSY DOWN HER FROM SAN DIEGO
CALIFORNIA AND REPRESENTING PET
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION PLEASE
SUPPORT.
PIPER KREISEL HSUS ROCKLIN
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT.
JANET MCCARTY HSUS ELEVEN FULL
SIMPLY SUPPORT THINKING.
HI JENNIFER CAVITY WITH H. S. U.
S. FROM EL DORADO COUNTY PLEASE
SUPPORT KEEP CALIFORNIA THE TOP
FOR THE ANIMALS.
HI MY NAME IS CALEY BROKE SOME
FROM NEWPORT BEACH CALIFORNIA
AND I ASK THAT YOU SUPPORT SO WE
CAN KEEP THESE ANIMALS OUT OF
THE HISTORY BOOKS.
FOR GENERATIONS TO COME.
HELLO THERE MY NAME IS AARON HOW
THE HUMANE SOCIETY OF THE UNITED
STATES DISTRICT LEADER.
FROM SACRAMENTO AND IN FULL
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS SHELLY LIN I'M
WITH SOCIAL CMPASSIONATE
LEGISLATION I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS FILM.
MARY KATE STEWART FROM LAGUNA
BEACH CALIFORNIA AND ANIMALS
BELONG IN THE WILD AND NOT ON
THE MANTLE.
HILLARY PICKLES FROM LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA SUPPORTER OF SOCIAL
COMPASSION LEGISLATION IN
LEGISLATION SUPPORT.
BETHANY DAVIS CALIFORNIA
CREDENTIALED TEACHER.
LET'S HAVE THESE ANIMALS FOR OUR
CHILDREN.
BETSY WASSON FROM WASHINGTON DC
PLEASE SUPPORT.
BECAUSE UNDER SHOWS FROM FROM
LOS ANGELES THANK YOU FOR MAKING
A CHANGE.
CRYSTAL MARLIN ON BEHALF OF THE
ENTIRE MEMBERSHIP IN CALIFORNIA
ON THE HUMANE SOCIETY OF THE
UNITED STATES WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE.
LINDA WORTH SACRAMENTO ANIMAL
SAVE SACRAMENTO ANIMAL RIGHTS
SACRAMENTO.
SACRAMENTO VEGAN SOCIETY WE ALL
WANT COMPASSION FOR ANIMALS.
GALA NASAL OFFERS SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA I'M A VOLUNTEER AT
THE BROAD CHAU SHELTER STRONGLY
SUPPORT.
JANE VELEZ MITCHELL ATTORNEY AND
AUTHOR MARINA DEL REY.
WE HAVE DESTROYED WELL OVER 50%
OF ALL WILDLIFE FOR TO BRACE WE
WON'T HAVE ANY LEFT SOON WE'VE
GOT TO DO SOMETHING THANK YOU.
GENESIS BUT WHERE.
WE DID NOT HAVE AT THE EARTH
ANCESTORS WE BORROW FROM MY
CHILDREN I'M REPRESENTING THE
CHILDREN AND I URGE YOU TO VOTE
YES [inaudible]
PEOPLE YET.
JANELLE PLUS YOU KNOW MOTHER OF
THESE COMPASSIONATE CHILDREN
THEY TAUGHT ME COMPASSION BY NOT
HURTING ANIMALS FIRED YOU TO
VOTE YES THEY BROUGHT ME HERE.
MS PLUS CITY SHOULD BE VERY
PROUD THEIR GREAT.
I SEE NO OTHER AYE TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION YES MISTER CHAIRMAN.
I'M JOHN JACKSON AND I'M NOT A
LOBBYIST.
I'M A PROFESSIONAL.
A CONSERVATIONIST FOR OVER
THIRTY FIVE YEARS WITH
ACTIONABLE ACT ACTIVE PROGRAMS
IN THE RELEVANT COUNTRIES --
MOST OF THE WILDLIFE IT TO HER.
COVERED BY THIS BILL
[inaudible]
ARE [inaudible]
IF YOU'RE.
SECURED BY HONEY.
OR THEY ARE STABLE OR INCREASING
IN SOUTHERN AND EASTERN AFRICA
NOW DIFFERENCE REGINA SOUTHERN
EASTERN AND IT'S AN AFRICA IS
THE HUNTING PROGRAMS.
THE STATE WILL USE.
YOU TO PAY TYPE POSITION THAT
WAS ADOPTED FROM THE UNITED
STATES BECAUSE THEY WILDLIFE
MANAGERS THERE.
THE DEPUTIES WERE PLAYING THE
UNITED STATES WHERE WE HAVE THE
NORTH AMERICAN LIFE MODEL BASED
UPON THE USE OF PACE SYSTEM.
NOW IN PARTICULAR.
LET ME SAY THAT THEM.
HUNTING PROVIDES THREE THINGS AT
A CRITICAL.
THAT SPECIFICALLY ADDRESS THE
THREATS TO WILDLIFE.
AND SOUTHERN ASIA AFRICA WHERE
WHAT MOST WOULD STILL EXIST
[inaudible]
HABITAT LOSS THE FIRST THREAT.
THE SECOND IS COACHING SPECIAL I
PARTICULARLY VALUABLE ITEMS LIKE
IVORY RHINO HORN THE SO FORTH.
THIRD IS YOU HAVE TO HAVE A
CONSERVATION INFRASTRUCTURE JUST
LIKE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WHO IN THE WORLD PAYS FOR THAT.
SO WHAT YOU HAVE HERE IS MORE
HABITAT.
THE HUNTING HABITAT THAN YOU CAN
IMAGINE ALL THESE THE GOOD FAITH
PEOPLE.
IN SOME COUNTRIES LIKE TANZANIA
THE HUNTING AREAS A SIX TIMES
LARGER.
STUNT LARGER THAN THE NATIONAL
PARKS THE SERENGETI GORE GO
CRATER SO FORTH. TO THE OPPOSITE
EN IN THE SOME BOB WAY OF
MOZAMBIQUE IT'S THE HUNTING AREA
TWICE THE SIZE OF THE NATIONAL
PARKS.
THE WHILE AFTER.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE OWES
ITS EXISTENCE. TO THEIR HABITAT.
IN THAT HABITAT EXISTS BECAUSE
OF THE HUNTING PROGRAMS USE THE
PAY PROGRAMS.
IT'S THE MOST IN THE WORLD IS
UNDISPUTED [inaudible]
SECOND [inaudible]
POACHING.
AT POACHING POLITICAL PREFERRED
TO CALL COUNT APPROACHING%
[inaudible]
WHAT TROLLS APPROACHING?
SAMPLING IN CALIFORNIA LAW
ENFORCEMENT FOR A ONE HUNDRED
FISHMAN HERE BY THEM NONRESIDENT
TOURIST FOR HUNTERS IN LIFE AND
REGULATE HUNTING IN AFRICA.
MOST OF THE HABITAT.
ATTEMPTED BY THE HUMMING
COMMUNITY DIRECTLY OR INDIRECTLY.
FOR PRINCIPLE WAYS THEY PAID THE
BILLS LEARNED OF WHILE I'VE
DEPARTMENTS 80% OF THE MONEY
THEY GET FROM THE FEES GOES ANTI
POACHING [inaudible]
PETER FAX.
BUT I HUNTING OPERATORS
THEMSELVES HAD THE POLICE THEY
LAND THIS IS A FACT OF LIFE.
YOU HAVE TO PLEASE YOUR
RESOURCES LIKE DUCKS UNLIMITED.
ARE GRAYSON WALLET HABITAT
[inaudible]
OF THIRD THE COMMUNITIES HAVE
THEIR OWN AND BY LAW IN MOST
CASES I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT.
A REQUIRED BY LAW OR IF DEBT TO
PARTICIPATE AS WE GET OUR UP
THIS UP.
I DON'T IN ALL FAIRNESS THE AND
EVERYONE GETS ABOUT TWO MINUTES
IF THIS WASN'T MENTIONED EARLIER
IN THE COMING --
EVERYONE IT'S ABOUT TWO MINUTES
MAYOR SUMMARIZE.
THAT'S WHEN ASKING IDEA I'M SURE
THAT'S WHAT I'M ASKING IT OKAY.
A BRIEF YOU DON'T WANT THE
HAUNTING MEMORABILIA TO BE LEFT
IN AFRICA THE FIND THE WRONG
PLACE [inaudible]
OKAY.
ARE ABOUT ABSENT THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THREE LETTERS THIS
MORNING FROM AFRICA.
GOVERNMENT WHILE OF DEPARTMENTS
PRIMER SECRETARIES.
SAYING THIS IS THE LAST THING
YOU WANT TO DO.
CONFIDENT JOHN DINGELL
INTRODUCED AND FOR THE IN A
DANGER SPACE ACTING HAS BUT
PROVISIONS.
PERMITS ONLY GRANTED FOR THESE
SPECIES --
IF THE HANDSOME IS PROVEN.
I THINK YOU'RE A MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I'M
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE CAPITAL
WINTER PRESENTING SPIKELET
INTERNATIONAL OUTDOOR SPORTS
MEANS COALITION CALIFORNIA
SPORTSMEN'S LOBBY A NATIONAL
SHOOTING SPORTS FOUNDATION.
I RESPECT YOUR TWO MINUTES AND
BE BRIEF I JUST WANT TO COVER
SOME REALLY BASIC THINGS ARE
ABOUT THE BILL --
FIRST OF ALL THIS BILL WAS --
ONE OF THAT GOTTEN AMENDS AFTER
THE SPOT BELT OUTLINED ON APRIL
SECOND FOR THE RECORD.
AND THIS BILL IS NOT GERMANE
THIS WAS A PUBLIC UTILITIES CODE
BILL WHICH DELTON TRANSPORTATION
XIN GAME CODE --
THE BILL ATTEMPTS TO DISCOURAGE
CALIFORNIA SOME LEGAL GAME
HUNTING IN AFRICA --
I KNOW THE SUPPORTERS MENTIONED
THEY HAD SOME BARRIERS WILL A
FEW OF THOSE BARRIERS ARE THIS
BILL IS CONTRARY TO THE FEDERAL
ENDANGERED SPECIES ACT FOR MANY
SPECIES.
THUS INVALIDATING IT AND
PREEMPTED FRANKLY.
ON THE STATE OF NEW JERSEY
ENACTED SUCH A LOT OF HAVE
TOSSED OUT IN THE COURTS AFTER
NEW JERSEY REALIZED IT WAS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
AND IT ENTERED A CONSENT DECREE.
CALIFORNIA WOULD BE CONTRARY TO
FEDERAL LAW EXPOSING CALIFORNIA
TOO EXPENSIVE LITIGATION AND IT
WOULD LIKELY LOSE.
THE BILL IGNORES THE
CONSERVATION BENEFITS OF HUNTING
AND MANAGEMENT PRACTICES AS WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER --
AND WE'RE NOT IN A BETTER
POSITION TO JUDGE A SCIENCE OF
THE UNITED STATES FISH AND
WILDLIFE SERVICE SOCIETIES AND
THE INTERNATIONAL UNION FOR
CONSERVATION OF NATURE.
THE BILL WOULD ACTUALLY HURT
AFRICAN COMMUNITIES AND SOUND
MANAGEMENT PRACTICES.
IT ATTEMPTS TO MANAGE RESOURCES
IN ANOTHER CONTINENT IN A
HEARING WITHOUT THE BENEFIT OF
THE EXPERTS.
AND THAT IS VERY DANGEROUS
FRANKLY FOR EXAMPLE THE
REFERENCE TO BOTSWANA --
STOPPING HUNTING IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN AS THE SUCCESS OF IS
MISLEADING AT BEST.
THIS WAS DONE ON STATE AND
COMMUNAL LANDS HUNTING WAS STILL
ALLOWED ON PRIVATE LANDS
ADDITIONALLY SINCE THAT TIME
RESEARCH THAT'S APPROACHING IN
HUMAN WILDLIFE CON.
FLICKS HAVE INCREASED NOT
DECREASED SINCE THE SUSPENSION
AND THE RURAL COMMUNITIES ARE
PETITIONING THE GOVERNMENT TO
REOPEN HUNTING.
THE LAS REFERENCE THAT ADDRESS
WILDLIFE OUTSIDE CALIFORNIA OR
FOR COMMERCIAL PURPOSES.
AND PERSONAL POSSESSION WHICH IS
THIS BILL GOES WAY BEYOND THAT.
FOR NON ASA SPECIES THERE'S NO
SCIENCE TO SUPPORT THE BANNING
OF IMPORTATION IN POSSESSION AND
FOR THE LISTED SPECIES THE
UNITED FISH AND WILDLIFE
SERVICE'S HAS JURISDICTION OVER
THOSE DETERMINATIONS BASED ON
SCIENCE.
THE PENALTIES ARE STAGGERING.
AND ESTABLISH A BOUNTY HUNTING
ON LAW ABIDING CITIZENS A TAKING
AND WILL DRAIN OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS FROM THE
DUTY OF MANAGING OUR OWN
RESOURCE.
AND I WOULD JUST IMPLORE UN
CLOSE TO THINK ABOUT A COUPLE
THINGS.
YOU'RE SITTING IN JUDGMENT OF A
LEGAL RECREATIONAL PURSUIT OF
YOUR CITIZENRY.
OUT OF THIS STATE AND YOU'RE
TELLING THEM THAT THEY CAN
LEGALLY BRING IT AND THEY CAN
LEGALLY POSSESS IT.
BUT WE'RE GOING TO COME GET YOU
ONE DAY THIRTY AND MAKE YOU A
CRIMINAL.
AND I WERE CLOSE TO STANDARD
STERN WHO LAST TIME I TESTIFIED
CALLED HUNTERS POACHERS IN THIS
TIME SUGGESTS THAT WOMEN DON'T
COUNT THEY DO.
I THINK YOU VERY MUCH.
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY IS THERE ANY
OTHER TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL [inaudible]
PLEASE --
STATE YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION
WHICH RIGHT NOW IS I AM DANCERS
HIM A MEMBER OF THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS OF THE CALIFORNIA
WATERFOWL ASSOCIATION WILL SOAR
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE CHAIR.
AND HAD TWO MINUTES A PIECE%
RIGHT TO THINK EIGHT THE REASONS
WHY THANK YOU.
SEARCH YOUR BILL GAINES MEDINA
ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF THE
ROCKY MOUNTAIN ELK FOUNDATION
THE CONGRESSIONAL SPORTSMAN'S
FOUNDATION THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF THE WILD SHEEP
FOUNDATION CALIFORNIA DEAR
ASSOCIATION AND SIX OTHER
WILDLIFE ORGANIZATIONS.
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
YOU'RE CHAIRMAN MEMBERS RIGHT
GRIPPED SPEAK ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE PISTOL
ASSOCIATION WERE PROPOSED THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN JIM WATER SUB
MEMBER OF THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS
OF THE MISSOURI WILDLIFE IN THE
MISSOURI --
SAFARI CLUB AND THAT'S MISSOURI
SPELLED M. Z. YOU ARE I WHICH IS
A SWAHILI WORD.
VIRTUE TO OPPOSE THIS BILL.
VOTE ON IT BECAUSE OF SCIENCE
AND THE FACTS NOT A MOTION.
DAN READ WITH NATIONAL RIGHTFUL
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION.
SAMPRAS REPRESENT GUN OWNERS
CALIFORNIA.
OVER THIRTY THOUSAND MEN AND
WOMEN.
IN CALIFORNIA RIGHT WERE OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS WHITE CHEN AND I ALSO
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
ROBERT DTS REPRESENTATIVE FOR
THE RIVER CONSERVATION CAMPING
VISITOR AFRICA FIVE TIMES THAT'S
REMOVED SNARES MANY TIMES I'M
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SEE NO OTHER
OPPOSITION WILL TO GET BACK TO
THE MEMBERS OF YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
FOR ON THE BILL YES US A MEMBER
FRIEDMAN.
THANK YOU --
I AM GONNA BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL TODAY I DO HAVE ONE
QUESTION SLASH CONCERN --
AS SOMEBODY WHO ALSO AS AN
ANTIQUE DEALER I AM CONCERNED
ABOUT WHAT THIS MEANS FOR PEOPLE
WHO HAVE.
THESE ITEMS THAT ARE OLDER --
I'VE SEEN WHAT'S HAPPENED WITH
THE IVORY BAN WHICH I ALSO
SUPPORT BUT QUITE HONESTLY WHEN
IT COMES.
TO VINTAGE JEWELRY DEALERS I'M
JUST AN AVERAGE PERSON WHO'S
TRYING TO MAYBE SELL A PIECE OF
GEORGIA TO BE FROM THE EIGHTEEN
HUNDREDS.
IT'S REALLY BEEN --
A BAD SITUATION ON THE GROUND
FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE WITH A LOT
OF ITEMS BEING SEIZE FROM PEOPLE
AND WE DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT TYPE
OF BONE OR IVORY IS IN.
IN THIS AND I HAVE THE SAME
CONCERN WITH THIS BILL DO YOU
HAVE ANY WAY OF ADDRESSING THAT
OR ARE YOU SAYING THAT NO MATTER
WHEN THESE ITEMS WORKERS.
WERE PROCURED OR THEN THEY'RE
ALL FAIR GAME WHAT'S YOUR
POSITION ON THAT THANK YOU
ACTUALLY FOR THAT QUESTION
SOMETHING WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON
WITH.
A BOTH COMMITTEE STAFF HERE AS
WELL AS ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY IS
BILLS DOUBLE REFERRED.
SO -- THE
THE AMENDMENTS THAT WE'VE BEEN
CONTEMPLATING IT NAY NAY CAN
COMMENT ON THEM BUT THERE'S A
PROCESS FOR DEMONSTRATING THE
DATE OF POSSESSION.
DESERTED DISTINGUISH BETWEEN --
ITEMS THAT ARE ALREADY HERE AND
ITEMS THAT ARE BROUGHT IN.
IT SHOULD THIS BILL BECOMES LAW
AFTER THE BAND SO JUSTTO BE
CLEAR SO YOU CAN STILL SELL AN
ITEM IF IT'S AN OLDER ITEM OR NO
[inaudible]
OF THE WITH THIS BILL DOESN'T
DEAL WITH SELLING AT ALL SO IF
IF IF THE SELLING OF THE ITEM IS
LEGAL UNDER FEDERAL LAW.
THEN YOU'LL STILL BE ABLE TO
SELL IT KNOWLEDGE AGAIN.
IF UNLESS NOW FEDERAL LAW
DOESN'T --
PREEMPT POSSESSIONS SO WE'RE
SAYING YOU CAN'T POSSESS IT NOW.
IF THAT IT IT THAT MEANS THAT
YOU CAN'T SAY YOU CAN'T SELL IT
BEN YOU BEND YOUR BILL TO SELL
IT BUT THERE'S A GRANDFATHER
DATES IF YOU'VE HAD THE THE ITEM
ALREADY.
AND FEDERALLAW SAYS YOU CAN
SELL IT THEN YOU CAN SELL IT.
BUT THE CAN YOU PURCHASE THAT
AND AN ITEM THAT SOMEBODY ELSE
HAD HIS LAST PREVIOUSLY BEFORE
THE BAN.
NO YOU WILL NOT BE ABLE TO BUY A
CAN'T BE SOLD. TO ME THAT'S
THAT'S AN ISSUE I MEAN SOME OF
THESE ITEMS ARE QUITE OLD THEY
WOULD FALL UNDER THE CATEGORY OF
ANTIQUES.
AND I THINK THAT YOU SHOULD TRY
TO ADD AN AMENDMENT THAT ALLOWS
FOR THE SALE.
OF THOSE ITEMS THAT I UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE'S SOME DIFFICULTY BUT
YOU KNOW.
I DO YOU REALLY WANT TO
CRIMINALIZE PEOPLE IF THEY HAVE
GRANDMA'S SHAWL SHOWERS A
LEOPARD SHAWL TO AND MAYBE YOU
DO.
BUT WE DON'T WANT TO SUMMARIZE
THAT POSITION. TO THIS BILL'S
ENACTMENT SO SO THEY THAT
AMENDMENT SAYS YOU CAN
DEMONSTRATE POSSESSION OF THE
ARTICLE FOR JENNIFER TWENTY
NINETEEN BY FURNISHINGS AND
DOCUMENTATION.
SO BALLOT PERMITS A BILL OF
LADING --
ABOUT APPRAISAL PHOTOGRAPHIC BUT
AREN'T YOUR POINT ABOUT SALES.
IT'S OUT OF OUR PURVIEW --
TO GET INTO SALES THE REASON THE
BILL FOCUSES ON POSSESSION IS
STRICTLY TO STAY WITH IT WITH
WITHIN OUR LANE AND NOT BE
PREEMPTED BY FEDERAL LAW SO I TO
WHAT THEN YOU CAN'T.
PURCHASE ONE OF THESE OLDER
ITEMS BECAUSE YOU WOULD NOT HAVE
OWNED IT BEFORE.
NO MATTER WHEN IT WAS PROCURED
YOU WOULD NOT HAVE OWNED IT FOR
A YEAR BASICALLY DE FACTO
BANNING THE SALE OF ANY ANTIQUE
ITEMS.
SO DISRUPTING FREE TO THINK
ABOUT MOVING OKAY FORWARD WITH
IF.
BECAUSE THEN EVEN IF SOMEBODY
GOES TO AN ANTIQUE STORE A FLEA
MARKET AND BUY SOMETHING THAT'S
CLEARLY OLD.
MAYBE IT'S A PIECE OF SOMETHING
THAT'S AN OLD PIECE OF JEWELRY
FOR INSTANCE WHICH WE SEE
COMMONLY AND IN THIS BUSINESS.
ON YOUR THAN SAYING THAT THAT
ITEM THAT THEY'RE BREAKING THE
LAW TO POSSESS IT AT THAT POINT.
I I WILL POINT OUT THAT ARE.
UNDER SOCIETY'S APPENDIX ONE ALL
THOSE SPECIES LISTED ARE NOT
ALLOWED TO BE SOLD UNDER THE ESA
INSIDE HE'S.
SO BUT YOU KNOW YOU CAN'T HAVE
COMMERCIAL SALES OF OF
ENDANGERED SPECIES ON APPENDIX.
ONE THANK YOU THANKS FOR THAT
CLARIFICATION SIGN OR MATHIS.
YES THEN YOU MUST HAVE GOT A FEW
QUESTIONS TOM IN AND KIND OF FOR
FOR BOTH SIDES --
WHAT ARE THE CONSERVATION
BENEFITS THE?
OF OF REGULATING HAUNTING UNDER
YOUR BILL SENATOR AND ENOUGH I
CAN GET.
THE ANSWERS YOU KNOW BECAUSE IT
SEEMS LIKE YOU'RE TRYING TO
DISCOURAGE THAT --
ALSO HOW DOES THE BILL OBSTRUCT
THE CONSERVATION ACTIVITIES
UNDER FEDERAL.
ENDANGERED SPECIES ACT --
HOW IMPORTANT IS THE
CONSERVATION OF HONEY INTO THESE
RURAL COMMUNITIES AND PROGRAMS
AND I KNOW SOME OF THAT WAS
ADDRESSED EARLIER --
IF YOU.
FULLY ANSWER THAT --
WHAT THE FACT WITH THE BILL HAVE
ON THE CAPACITY OF THESE RANGE
STATES TO PROTECT THE SPECIES --
AND THEN WE'LL ONE BY.
ONE YEAH ABSOLUTELY ARMY I GOT
GREAT QUESTIONS FOR YOU OKAY
LET'S START AT THE TOP CENTER
YOU YOU KNOW I'VE TRAVELED
INTERNATIONALLY AND I'VE SEEN
SOME OF THESE THINGS SO YEAH SO
GIMME GIMME GIMME THE FIRST ONE
TO GET OUT WHAT WHAT ARE THE
CONSERVATION BENEFITS.
OF THE REGULATED HUNTING UNDER
YOUR BILL AND WHAT OF THE AND TO
DISCOURAGE SO THE GOAL THE GOAL
OF THE BILL IS ENHANCE
CONSERVATION AND AND THAT THE
THESIS OF THE BILL IS THAT.
HUNTING IS OF MUCH LESS
SUSTAINABLE WAY TO PROMOTE
CONSERVATION OF THESE AFRICAN
ENDANGERED SPECIES THEN THROUGH
OTHER.
TECHNIQUES SO WE THINK MORE
DOLLARS GET BACK INTO THE
COMMUNITY TO DO THE KIND OF POPE --
POACHING ENFORCEMENT AND THE
OTHER SORT OF IMPORTANT MEASURES
THAT -- THAT
THE OPPONENTS WERE DISCUSSING
THROUGH SAFARIS ECO TOURISM
WITHOUT AN ACTUAL HUNTING
OBJECTIVE BUT THAT THERE ARE
DIFFERENT WAYS TO GO TO THAT
COTTON AND ENJOY THESE ANIMALS
THAT ACTUALLY.
WILL BRING MORE REVENUE BACK
THIS COMMUNITIES AND KEEP A YOU
KNOW A FEW A FEW APPROACHES AND
IF THAT WAS WAS THE CASE THAT
ARE GOING TO THINK THE COUNTRIES
WOULD BE PUSHING FOR THAT.
WELL THE COUNTRIES ARE JUST
HUNGRY FROM.
I'D LIKE TO HEAR.
THAT'S LIKE SAYING.
WITHOUT WINGS A BIRD WILL FLY
RIGHT WINGS IN THIS CASE OR THE
LAW OF THE REVENUE FROM THE
HUNTING.
THE HABITAT FOR THE HONEY.
THE OF COMMUNITY PROGRAMS
INVOLVING MILLIONS OF PEOPLE.
AND MAJOR NGOS NOT THE ONES THE
SPONSORS WOULD MAKE NGOS AT W.
W. OF THE LARGEST THAT THE
WORLDWIDE WORLDWIDE OF OF
FOUNDATION THE CONSERVATION ASIA
I UCN.
THE ARM OF ALL THE RANGE
NATION'S THE SPECIALIST GROUPS.
ALL ACTION PLANS ALL DEPENDING
ON HONEY JUST LIKE A WHILE I'VE
NOT AMERICA I MEAN IT'S IT'S A
FACT.
AND I WOULD NOT TALK ABOUT A
LITTLE BIT A HABITAT WHEN I TALK
ABOUT A LARGE PART OF IT WOULD
FALL DOWN MOST OF THE HABITAT
MOST OF THE HALF APPROACHING
REVENUE.
THESE ARE FACTS THAT NOT
DISPUTED FACTS I HAVE NO I'VE
COMMITTED OF SENT BY FAX.
A COPY OF THESE OF THE ALL THESE
FACTS. TO EVERY COMMITTEE MEMBER.
BUT THIRTY PAGES.
WHILE REFERENCE AUTHORITY PAGES
AND I'M ON A ARE YOU SEE AND I
WANNA SLEEP DESPAIR WILL USE
LIVE WITH A SPECIAL GROUP I'M ON
AFRICA LINE WORKING GROUP I'VE
BEEN DOING THIS FOR THIRTY FIVE
YEARS.
AND I PROMISE YOU THAT THERE ARE
TENS OF THOUSANDS ALONG FOURTH
OFFICES PAY PARA HUNTERS IN
AFRICA.
IT DOES NO SUBSTITUTE FOR THE NO
ALTERNATIVE IN THIS BILL
CERTAINLY THAT PROVIDE.
IT'S IT'S YOU SHOT YOU'RE TRYING
TO SAY THE BIRDS GOING TO FLY
WITHOUT WINGS.
BEST ANSWER THE FIRST QUESTION.
NO WE JUST WANT THE BIRDS TO
ENABLE THE FLY NOT BE OFF YEAH
YEAH.
OF THE VOTE.
OKAY I JUST WANNA WATCHES HAVE A
LITTLE BIT AT A QUORUM SO SIR I
KNOW YOU'VE GOT SOME IS ASKING
QUESTIONS BEHIND YOU BUT
DIRECTOR ANSWERS TO THE CHAIR OF
OUTPUT ON THEM AND THAT IS HOW
YOU DIRECTOR ANSWERS TO THE
COMMITTEE.
AND WE ALSO WANT TO STOP A BACK
AND FORTH CONVERSATION I KNOW
YOU GUYS.
ARE ENJOYING THAT CONVERSATION I
I THINK I'D ENJOY THAT
CONVERSATION BUT THAT'S NOT THE
PLACE RIGHT HERE TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION SO IF.
MR MATHIS HAS SOME FOLLOW UP
QUESTIONS I DO MAKE YOUR
QUESTIONS.
IF SOMEONE HAS IT PERTINENT
ANSWER GO AHEAD AND ANSWER IT
BUT LET'S TRY TO LIMIT SOME
SIDEBAR.
OR SOME QUIPS SO THAT WE CAN
JUST MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN GET
AND VOTE ON THIS VERY IMPORTANT
DON'T GET.
MY APOLOGIES FOR EQUIPMENT BACK
BY AT YES --
IN IN IN IN THE EARLIER COMMENTS.
AND PLEASE DIRECTOR.
YOUR REMARKS IN INTO THE
MICROPHONE SO THEY'RE RECORDED --
HOW HOW DOES THE BILL OBSTRUCT
THE CONSERVATION ACTIVITIES
UNDER THE ENDANGERED SPECIES ACT?
AND AND SERVE YOU DIRECT INTO
THE MICROPHONE.
YEAH BUT THAT WAS TO THE YEAH UP
A VOTE HARD LOOK THAT THE IN
ENGINE SPECIES ACT.
OUR HAS SPECIAL PROVISIONS TO
USE HUNTING AS A TOOL FOR
CONSERVATION.
AND TODAY WAS LISTED SPECIES IS
THE FOREMOST TO IT ALSO
IMPLEMENT SITE THESE.
SITE IS HAS BETTER RESOLUTIONS.
ALLOWING QUOTAS FOR THE SPECIES
FOR EXAMPLE BLACK RHINO --
FIVE EN THE OF THE BE HAVE TO
MEET CERTAIN STANDARDS MONEY
EXPENSE OF FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
RONALD WAS STRAIGHT INTO THE
CONSERVATION SPECIES ON ON ON ON
ON ON ON IT WAS DESIGNED THAT
WAY FROM INCEPTION [inaudible]
JOHN DINGELL WAS THE AUTHOR AND
A JUST PEACE ACT ALL THREE OF
THEM.
EXCUSE IN THE NINETEEN SEVENTY
THREE IS PACIFIC WOULD PROVIDE
FOR AND SECRETARY IN ISSUE
PERMITS FOR IMPORTATION HUNTING
TROPHIES WHEN ENHANCES SURVIVAL
SPECIES FILL LABORATORY GRAHAM.
THAT THE USERS LEVERAGE.
THE SOUTHERN EAST AFRICAN
COUNTRIES THAT THEY CAN
IMPORTANT TROPHIES ONLY IF THEY
MEET CERTAIN STANDARDS.
HIS SOME REAL BURDEN IT TAKES
SOMETIMES YEARS TEN TWENTY YEARS
TO IMPORT BUT THAT THE IT STEPS
THOSE PROGRAMS UP IN AFRICA
THERE THE FOREMOST PROGRAM IN
THE WORLD AS REASON WHAT
POPULATIONS OR A STABLE SECURE
OR AND OR GROWING.
AND SUDDENLY SAID AFRICA THE
ONLY ONES BOTH THE LINE'S MOSTLY
ELEPHANTS MOST A RHINO.
A IF NOT ALL OF THEM ALMOST.
AND THAT THE DISTINCTIVE ABOUT
THAT IS THERE SUSTAINABLE USE
BASE PROGRAM.
OF THAT'S HOW IT AFFECTS THERE
IS COMPOSED IN CONFLICT WITH THE
ENDANGERED SPECIES.
OKAY AND THEN FOLLOW UP ON THAT
WELL HOW IMPORTANT IS THE
CONSERVATION HUNTING TO THE
RURAL COMMUNITIES WITHIN THE
PROGRAMS WHERE IT WITH I MEAN I
KNOW -- W.
ASK CAMPFIRE LIFE PRESS PROJECT
I MEAN YOU'RE TALKING IN CLOSE
TO YOU KNOW SOMETHING LIKE A
MILLION FAMILIES IN SOME OF
THESE CASES.
IN THESE COUNTRIES SO IF YOU CAN
EXPAND ON THAT SIR.
FORGIVE MY BACK AGAIN ALL TAUGHT
IN THE HOPE THAT THE CHAIRMAN OF
THIS IS [inaudible]
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT.
THESE ARE RULE PEOPLE THEY
ULTIMATELY WILL ULTIMATELY WOULD
TERM IT WILL DETERMINE THE
SURVIVAL OF THE SPECIES.
THAT ALSO IN THE SHORT TERM
DETERMINE WHETHER NOT THESE
BEACHES HAVE A PLACE TO LIVE
OUTSIDE OF PROTECTED AREAS WHICH
ARE.
BUT NOT AS NUMEROUS AS THEIR
HOMELANDS.
MOST WILDLIFE IN SOUTHERN
EASTERN AFRICA EXIST IN THE
COMMUNITY AREAS.
NOW OF THAT WITH ELABORATE
PROGRAMS.
SUPPORTED BY OFFICIAL WHILE OUR
SERVICE.
BY KAT US CONGRESS BY STUDIES BY
WERE WHILE I PHONE AND OTHERS.
THAT FOR EXAMPLE WE CAN'T FIRE
PROGRAM IS ABOUT WAY.
HIS SEVEN HUNDRED SEVENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND FAMILIES MOSTLY
CHILDREN.
THEY EARN 70% OF THE REVENUE
FROM TOURISTS FOR HUNTING.
A MOST OF THESE ARE.
SPEECH IS THAT IT WAS SPEAKING
OUT HERE TODAY FACTO SPEECHES
ARE SO IMPORTANT THE SYSTEM
WOULD COLLAPSE.
WITHOUT THE IMPORTER OF TROPHIES
THE UNITED STATES.
BUT ALSO THE SPECIES WOULD
DISAPPEAR BECAUSE A SERVICE HAVE
SHOWN THAT HAVE NO TOLERANCE FOR
LA HINTS AND ELEPHANTS IN THEIR
BACKYARD.
THAT THIS IS --
THAT THESE PROVISIONS ACTUALLY
BENEFIT TO SPEECHES AND ALL
GROWING THOSE POPULATIONS.
THE SAME THING AS IN THE LIBYA
THE MEDIA --
HAS A LIFE WERE WHILE I FUND HAS
THAT WERE ALL OF LIFE PLUS
PROGRAM THIRTY YEARS OLD. FOR
NOW PROGRAMS IN THE WORLD DEPEND
ON THIS --
THE HUNTING OF THE SPECIES IS
GENERATING THE COR REVENUE --
THIS IS TRUE IN TANZANIA THROUGH
US ALL OF SOUTHERN EAST AFRICA
THE MOST SUCCESSFUL PROGRAMS
THAT DAY OR DEPENDENT ON HUNTING
FOREVER IN TO THIS IS THIS IS A
BLACK AND WHITE OPEN UNCLE
UNCONTESTED.
WHAT YOU'RE NOT HEARING ABOUT
THE FACTS YOU HEARING ABOUT --
AT SOME --
THESE ARTIFACTS AND I YOU SEE
UNDERSTAND BONTA WWF STAND
BEHIND OF THE US GOVERNMENT FISH
WHILE OUR SERVICE STANDS BEHIND
IT.
ENFORCEMENT OF THE ENDANGERED
SPECIES ACT INSIGHT IS A HUNDRED
EIGHTY SEVEN THEY SHOULD STAND
BEHIND IT --
ARE I WILL I WAS THE CHAIRMAN
THE CITY CHAIR I SHOW MUCH TO
SAY ABOUT THIS.
ALRIGHT SO A POINT HAS BEEN MADE
SENATOR STERN WOULD LIKE TO
RESPOND ON THAT POINT AND I WILL
I'LL ASK YOU TO DO THAT SO
PRESELIO YEAH THANK YOU --
BE COMPLETE I WOULD I WOULD
CONTEST A THE ALLEGED FACTS. OH
BY SIMPLY STATING THAT.
OF THE FORTY BILLION DOLLARS IN
THIS IS IN YOUR COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS.
BUT OF THE DIRECT ECONOMIC
CONTRIBUTION INTO AFRICA IN
TERMS OF SUPPORTING JOBS IN
THESE RURAL COMMUNITIES TO
SOMEHOW SAY THAT THEY HAVE TO
CHOOSE HUNTING TO SURVIVE.
IS NOT ACCURATE --
TOURISM ALONE IS CONTRIBUTE OVER
FORTY BILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN AND SUPPORTED OVER SIX
MILLION JOBS IN AFRICA.
AND VERY OFTEN THE THE HUNTING
AND ECO TOURISM ARE DIRECTLY IN
CONFLICT WITH EACH OTHER NOT
ALWAYS NOT NECESSARILY ALWAYS
BUT THE WAY THAT THESE PROGRAMS
ARE ADMINISTERED.
WE SIMPLY DON'T HAVE THE
CONFIDENCE IN THE CURRENT
ARRANGEMENT THAT SOMEHOW THIS
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS A GONNA
MAKE THOSE CERTIFICATIONS FAIRLY
BECAUSE YOU HAVE FOLKS WHO ARE.
AVID HUNTERS OF ENDANGERED
SPECIES IN THE WHITE HOUSE SO I
DON'T HAVE A LOT OF TRUST IN
THEM TO BE ABLE TO ENFORCE
WHATEVER --
GOALS MISTER DINGELL MAY HAVE --
BUT MORE SO AND NICK CAN
PROBABLY FILL YOU IN BUT THERE
IS MORE MONEY COMING IN ON THE
ECO TOURISM SIDE.
THAN ON THE HUNTING SIDE TO
SUPPORT THESE THREE SENATE
ACTUALLY OF NUMBERS FROM THOSE
COUNTRIES STATING THAT YET SO
THE BECAUSE TERRORISM IS
TERRORISM REGARDLESS OF WHETHER
THEY'RE FOR YOU GET WATER FROM
HUNTING BUT LET'S MILLION WITH A
COUPLE YEAH ACCORDING TO
ARCHAEOLOGY IN SOME [inaudible]
SURE.
TRIPCASE UGH ACCORDING TO HUMANE
SOCIETY INTERNATIONAL --
TROPHY HUNTING REVENUE UP
PERCENTAGE OF TOTAL TOURISM
DOLLARS IS LESS THAN ONE WHERE
SENATE THAT'S OCCURRING THE
HUMANE SOCIETY OF AN
INTERNATIONAL MEANS THE IDEA.
AND GET US NOT ACCORDING TO THE
GOVERNMENT.
THE OF THESE COUNTRIES WELL THE
PROBLEM WITH GETTING INFORMATION
FROM THESE COUNTRIES IS THAT YOU
CAN'T AND I'LL GIVE AN EXAMPLE.
THAT I'M I'M NOT INTERESTED IN
HIGHEST AT AYE MR SAID IN THE
COUNTRIES THAT AS IN IF YOU
DON'T HAVE THAT THEN YOU DON'T
HAVE THAT SIR.
RIGHT WE DON'T HAVE THAT BECAUSE
THEY DON'T GIVE IT TO US BECAUSE
IT DOESN'T EXIST THEY CAN'T
ACTUALLY HAVE THOSE NUMBERS IF
THEY DON'T HAVE A ROBUST
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM WHICH THEY
DON'T.
ALRIGHT SO I DO WE HAVE ANY
OTHER MEMBERS WHO WOULD LIKE TO
ASK A QUESTION THAT I LIKE THAT
TAX MONEY WE WANNA QUESTION
THINK.
OKAY GO FOR IT ALRIGHT.
SO I MEAN IT'S YOU YOU GUYS WILL
ACTUALLY HOUSE ALL THE NUMBERS --
YOU KNOW THAT THE PROGRAMS THAT
WE USE HERE --
WHAT WHAT ARE HONEY TAX THE WAY
OUR SYSTEM IS?
THAT THE WHOLE DOT SYSTEMS OF
THESE OTHER COUNTRIES HAVE HER.
MUCH BETTER PUT TOGETHER QUITE
FRANKLY THAN EVEN SOME OF THE
ONES THAT WE HAVE HERE.
IN THOSE REVENUES GO DIRECTLY.
TOWARDS THAT END IN TOWARDS
BENEFITING THOSE COMMUNITIES IT
GOES IN THEIR SCHOOLS ARE GOES
IN THEIR INFRASTRUCTURE. TO HELP
PROTECT.
THESE ANIMALS IN IN AND FOR ALL
THE REASONS FOR OF OF ALL YOU.
LADIES WITH YOUR PHONE SHAKING
YOUR HEADS NO AT ME AND I
ENCOURAGE YOU TO GET THE FACTS --
BE BECAUSE OF YOU TRULY WANT TO
PROTAGONISTS.
THESE ENVIRONMENTS YOU NEED TO
BE ABLE TO FUND IT THAT MR
MATHIS WOULD YOU DIRECT YOUR
COMMENTS TO THE COMMITTEE NOT TO
THE CROWD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN GARCIA --
I IDEAS I HAVE GREAT CONCERN
OVER THIS BECAUSE THESE
COUNTRIES HIT HERE WE ARE IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND WE'RE GONNA DICTATE.
THAT A POSSIBLE FUNDING FORMULA
FOR EIGHTH ANOTHER COUNTRY TO
SURVIVE IN AND WE HAVE NO
BUSINESS.
DOING THAT IF THEY WANTED OUR
HELP THEY REACH OUT JUST IN GOOD
HEALTH.
AND THEY'VE GOT.
WORLDWIDE ORGANIZATIONS GOING ON
THERE ARE CONTRIBUTING THAT ARE
FUNDING THIS [inaudible]
AND THE THERE'S SO MANY DOCUMENT.
MEMORIES ON THIS AND THE
BENEFITS OF THESE PROGRAMS.
IN TO TO OUTLINEDIN INDIGO EVEN
WITH --
SOMEONE FREEMAN'S COMMENTS.
I MEAN SOME OF THE THE PIECES OF
THE BILL.
GET INTO THAT THE CELL THE
OWNERSHIP IN IN THESE PIECES
RUNNING FULLY PUT TOGETHER.
ARAMBULA LOT OF CONCERNS WITH
YOUR BILL --
I I KNOW YOU WORK HARD ON YOUR
LEGISLATION SENATOR --
WOULD LOVE TO TALK TO YOU MORE
ON IT --
IT TODAY THANK YOU [inaudible]
AND SOONER XIN DID YOU WANNA
REQUIRE CAN WE HAVE SOME OTHER
MEMBERS YEAH THAT SOUNDS
FANTASTIC THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR -- I
I HAVE A QUESTION FOR MR MISTER
KALRA THANK YOU MISTER PER. ONE
OF THE THE LAW [inaudible]
FORGET [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
YES IT [inaudible]
AGAINST [inaudible]
THERE ARE.
NO I UNDERSTAND THAT THIS
NOBODY'S --
TO COMPARE THAT.
OF WITH THIS THIRTY DAY.
GET OUT OF THE STATE MISSION.
I FIND THAT THIS BILL.
IS SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR TO THE
NEW JERSEY LAW.
I THAT WAS CITED.
THAT WITH THE FACT THAT COME OUT
OF BY THE BOARD SO THAT REASON.
I THINK THAT THE I'LL BE VOTING.
IN OPPOSITION.
IT'S JUST A HARPER SCAR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
LIBYAN.
OF MY END OF THANK YOU SENATOR
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD --
YOU KNOW. THREE MONTHS AGO THE
LAST MALE NORTHERN WHITE RHINO
DIED -- AND
IN JUST LOOKING AT EVEN WHAT'S
IN THE US STAFF ANALYSIS FOR THE
STAFF TO WE COMMEND THE STOP
DOING A GOOD JOB IN THE NOW SAYS --
UNITED NATIONS WORLD TOURISM
ORGANIZATION OF THE FIFTY SIX
MILLION CHIPS AFTER TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN WILDLIFE WATCHING.
FIRMS IN 80% OF THE TOTAL ANNUAL
SALES [inaudible]
ARM.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
SUBSAHARAN AFRICA OVER FORTY
BILLION DOLLARS POURED OVER SIX
POINT ONE MILLION JOBS THOSE ARE
FACTS.
SAYING THAT THERE ARE SO MANY
DOCUMENTARIES IS NOT BACKED --
THOUGH THE REALITY IS THAT WE
UNDERSTAND WHAT HAPPENS WHEN WE
PUT IN REAL THOUGHTFUL
CONSERVATION PROGRAMS.
YOU SEE ABOUT THEIR* ONE
ANOTHER ONE THIRTY THE
ELEPHANT'S TODAY I'M REALLY WENT
AFTER POACHERS AND THE BAND
HUNTING -- A
BOOK THE DAY THEY MAY MAKE
HUNTING ILLEGAL.
SO YES AND I I DON'T DISAGREE
WITH THE NUMBERS THAT HAVE BEEN
STATED BECAUSE THAT'S THE STORY
CURRENT STATE OF AFFAIRS.
BECAUSE THERE ISN'T OTHER
ALTERNATIVES.
AND THERE ISN'T A MARKET DEMAND
TO CREATE THOSE OTHER
ALTERNATIVES WITH THE FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD
LEAD TO HAVE INFLUENCE OVER WHAT.
OTHER NATIONS DO AND WE HAVE TO
LIVE BY OUR VALUES NOT BY OTHERS
VALUES [inaudible]
AND CURRENTLY SOME OF THE
NATION'S OF ACTION PLANS
DEPENDENT ON HUNTING.
WE CAN HELP TRANSFER A FORM OF
THOSE ECONOMIES JUST LIKE IN
SOME OTHER AFRICAN COLONIES TO
ECO TOURISM BY.
SLOWING THE AMOUNT OF REVENUE
THEY GET FROM THAT ASPECT OF THE
INDUSTRY AND GROWING DEMAND
REVENUE THEY GET FROM ECO
TOURISM AND MORE ENVIRONMENTALLY
FRIENDLY ANIMAL FRIENDLY.
POLICIES SO WE DICTATE AS A
PLANET AND CERTAINLY
CALIFORNIA'S THE PRIVILEGED
ECONOMY PLAYS A HUGE ROLE IN
THAT WEATHER IS THROUGH A
CLIMATE CHANGE POLICY.
WHETHER IT'S THROUGH CONSUMER
CLUB OF CONSUMER PROTECTION YOU
NAME IT THIS IS ANOTHER EXAMPLE
WHERE WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SAY THIS ISN'T ACCEPTABLE FOR US
IS CALIFORNIANS PRINT.
AND AND WE CAN THEREBY HELPED
PROMOTE THE HEALTHIER ASPECTS OF
THE TOURISM INDUSTRY IN THOSE
NATIONS THAT ACTUALLY CREATE FAR
MORE JOBS.
THANK YOU MISTER KALRA MISTER Q..
AND SECULAR MCROBBIE SUPPORTING
HIS BILL BUT I WANNA ALSO.
A GIPSON COMMITMENT AND WOULD
LOVE BUT POINT OUT OF BROUGHT UP
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER FREEMAN.
YOU WILL WILL HAPPEN IF I HAVE
SOMETHING.
AGO WAS PASSED ON BY MY
GRANDMOTHER WHAT WOULD WHAT DO I
NEED TO DO.
I THINK YOU KNOW BETWEEN NOW AND
WE HAD THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR.
I HOPE TO GET A VERY VERY CLEAR
DIRECTION YOU KNOW YOU THROUGH
ASKED ME TO GO TO SOMEBODY --
BUT A TO TO VERIFY THAT THAT
THEY NEED NOBLES OF PECULIAR.
IT WILL BE A LOT OF PROBLEMS FOR
FOR THOSE PEOPLE PAGES BRETT GOT
SOMETHING.
ON THERE YOU KNOW GRAHAM GRANDMA
MAY JUST.
THE GOAL OF THIS MEASURE IS NOT.
TO GO AFTER HAND ME DOWNS OR THE
ITEMS THAT ARE WITHIN FAMILIES
POSSESSION IT'S ABOUT THE BIG
DOLLAR TRADE.
WE DON'T WANT TO GO AFTER
GRANDMOTHERS HERE UNLESS THOSE
GRANDMOTHERS ARE PART OF A LARGE
SCALE --
ENDANGERED SPECIES TRAIT SO BUT
I I APPRECIATE THE POINT I DON'T
MEAN I'M NOT TRYING TO BE FLIP
WITH YOU --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I I'M.
I I I WILL LOOK AT THE THE
PROVISIONS THAT THAT WE WE SORT
OF PUT IN HERE TO POLKA THAT.
THAT DETERMINATION AND WE DON'T
WANT THAT --
THAT PAUL CAST OVER EVERY FAMILY
TO HAVE TO GO THEN BACK AND LOOK
THROUGH KNICKKNACKS IN THEIR
DRAWERS OR YOU KNOW AND IN A
SIMILAR FRIEDMAN'S CASE YOU KNOW
THROUGH AN ANTIQUE SHOP.
BUT THIS IS ABOUT A THEM THE
MARKET IN THESE PARTS AT ITS AT
AT A MUCH LARGER SCALE SO BUT I
I DO APPRECIATE THE SENSE.
YEAH THANK YOU MISTER CHESTER
GALLAGHER.
YEAH THANK YOU SENATOR AND AND
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR NOT GONNA
GO AFTER GRANDMOTHERS YOU KNOW
THAT'S A GOOD THING --
BUT YOU KNOW I THINK ONE THING
IN AT SOME THAT I THAT I TRY TO
EMPHASIZE EVEN WITH WITH HUNTING
HERE DOMESTICALLY RIGHT IS AND
AND I THINK THIS POISON MAY BUT
I I THINK IT'S DESERVES
EMPHASISES THAT.
THE HUNTERS ARE ACTUALLY SOME OF
THE BIGGEST CONSERVATIONISTS.
THERE THE SOURCE OF THE REVENUE
FOR ALLOW THE CONSERVATION
EFFORTS I MEAN AS I THINK WAS
MENTIONED DUCKS UNLIMITED SO IN
MY IN MY DISTRICT IS YOU KNOW
AND WE HAVE ONE OF THE THE
MIGRATORY BIRDS WATERFOWL A
POPULATION THAT COMES ON THE
PACIFIC FLYWAY.
WE'VE WE HAVE CREATED HUGE
AMOUNTS OF HABITAT.
AND THAT AREA A LOT OF IT IS
DONE BY HUNTERS [inaudible]
AND RANCHERS --
SO YOU KNOW I HAVE SO MILD
LEGISLATION IS TRYING TO
ENCOURAGE THAT PRACTICE MORE
COVER CROPS.
THINGS THAT SUPPORT THAT BUT AND
AND IT SEEMS TO ME FROM LOOKING
AT THIS ISSUE.
AND YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY THERE'S A
LOT OF EMOTION --
SURROUNDING THE ISSUE I'VE BY
TOLD UNDERSTAND THAT --
BUT THESE.
WE ARE HUNTERS THAT ARE GOING
BACK -- ARE
ACTUALLY GENERATE A LOT OF
REVENUE TO HELP SUPPORT
CONSERVATION AT THE WAS POINTED
OUT -- NOW
THERE ARE DISPARITIES IN
DIFFERENT PARTS OF OF AFRICA --
WHERE?
WHERE THERE HASN'T BEEN THAT AND
THERE HAVE AND AND WE NEED TO
HAVE STRONGER?
ANTI POACHING --
EFFORTS TO STOP THIS UNITS
TRACKS HER [inaudible]
BUT ON YOU KNOW BUT NO TO KIND
OF PUT THIS KIND OF JUST A
BLANKET.
PROHIBITION GOING FORWARD --
SEEMS TO ME LIKE THAT DOESN'T
NECESSARILY GET OUT THE ISSUE OF
THE OF THE PROTEIN.
AND IT MAY HAVE THE THE
UNINTENDED IMPACT OF OF CUTTING
DOWN ON THE REVENUE THAT HELP
SUPPORT.
CONSERVATION PROGRAMS BACK IN
AFRICA AND HELPING TO SUPPORT
THE SPECIES THAT I THINK
EVERYBODY ON THIS COMMITTEE
AGREES -- WE
DON'T WANT TO SEE THEM IN THE
HISTORY BOOKS WE DON'T WE WANT
YOU KNOW WE WANT THE WE WANT THE
SPECIES PRESERVE A PART OF THAT
THE PART OF GOOD CONSERVATION
PRACTICES IS HUNTING TO BECAUSE
THERE ARE CASES --
WHERE WHERE THERE IS
OVERPOPULATION?
AND IF YOU DON'T LIKE TO SEE
ANIMAL STARVING BECAUSE OF THE
OVER POPULATION.
THEN YOU SHOULD SUPPORT.
RESPONSIBLE HUNTING CONSERVATION
EFFORTS AND SO.
WHAT I DON'T WANT TO SEE HAPPEN
IS AN UNATTENDED CONSEQUENCES
GOING TO HURT THE VERY THING
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO PROTECT
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE?
AND SO I MAYBE IF YOU COULD JUST
KIND RESPOND YOU KNOW TO THAT.
YEAH A PART OF YOUR WE WANT
THOSE CONSERVATION EFFORTS TO
CONTINUE IT ACTUALLY THEY'RE NOT
WORKING.
RIGHT LIKE THEY'RE THERE MAKE IT
THEY'RE MAKING A GO AT IT BUT
AND THERE IS SIT THERE ARE SOME
WINS OUT THERE BUT ON THE WHOLE.
THE CONTINENT IS IN DECLINE I
MEAN THESE ARE ENDANGERED
SPECIES ON THESE WATCHLISTS WITH
STUDIES AND THE I. U. C. N. FOR
A REASON RIGHT.
THERE THEY MAY NOT SURVIVE THIS
GENERATION SO SOMETHING HAS GOT
TO CHANGE HOW WE'RE APPROACHING
THIS PROBLEM ISN'T WORKING AND I
THIS BILL OBVIOUSLY IT IS NOT
ABOUT DUCKS ARE CALIFORNIA
HABITAT.
IN THIS REALLY UNIQUE I I
APPRECIATE THE EXAMPLE THE SO A
VERY UNIQUE CIRCUMSTANCE YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
A VERY LIMITED LIST OF ICONIC
SPECIES THAT --
ARE CLEARLY ENDANGERED --
ARE CLEARLY IN DECLINE THE FACTS
ARE NOT IN DISPUTE ON THAT ARE
ON THE WHOLE IN THAT CONTINENT.
THESE SPECIES ARE ARE ARE YOU
KNOW COLLAPSE --
AND AGAIN THAT THE SYSTEM WE CAN
WE CAN AGREE TO DISAGREE ON WHAT
THE BEST WAY TO TACKLE THE
PROBLEM IS.
OUR PREMISE IS THAT ECO TOURISM
AND THESE ALTERNATIVE FORMS OF
OF TOURISM ARE MUCH MORE
EFFECTIVE ABOUT GETTING DOLLARS
BACK LOCALLY THEN HUNTING
INDUSTRY AND I'M AND I'M NOT
SAYING ALL HUNTING IS POACHING
BY THE WAY AYE AYE THAT'S THINK
THAT'S NOT THE YEAH I I SHOULD
STATE THAT. FOR THE RECORD AND I
YOU KNOW THAT.
AND WOMEN ARE HUNTERS TO AYE AYE
AYE ALSO WILL ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
BUT I DON'T I DON'T ACTUALLY.
I DON'T CARE WHETHER YOU'RE
WOMAN OR MAN IF YOU'RE HUNTING
AND ENDANGERED SPECIES --
IT'S A PROBLEM --
FOR FOR AT LEAST FOR ME IS A
CALIFORNIA'S THAT'S WHY I
BROUGHT THIS FORWARD BUT I THINK
IT'S SOMETHING WE COULD LOOK AT
IN TERMS OF MONITORING OR SOME
WAY TO SORT OF ACTUALLY.
IMPROVE OUR DATA SETS I THINK
WE'VE GOT ABOUT AS GOOD AS WE
CAN GET OUT OF THE CURRENT STATE
OF GOVERNMENT DATA COMING FROM
AFRICA RIGHT NOW IT'S IT'S BEEN.
AS YOU KNOW THESE ARE VERY
CHALLENGING GOVERNMENTS TO
INTERACT WITH AND I YOU MAY
DISAGREE WITH THIS BUT I DON'T
HAVE A LOT OF TRUST IN OUR
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT RIGHT NOW TO
BEEN BROKER THOSE DEALS AND
REALLY PUSH THE CONSERVATION
AGENDA.
WHICH IS WHY I THINK CALIFORNIA
OUGHT TO STEP IN SO I I DO
APPRECIATE WHERE YOU'RE COMING
FROM ON IT AND YET THIS IS.
THIS IS OUR EFFORT TO SORT OF RE
ORIENT ECOMMERCE GLOBALLY TO SAY
THERE'S A BETTER WAY TO SAFETY.
HAVE I JUST IF OPPOSITION MAYBE
CAN RESPOND TO THAT AS WELL
CHAIRS DESCRIPTION.
WELL YES SIR --
FIRST THINK THERE'S I MENTION
BIRDS WITHOUT WINGS TO FLY.
WOULD TALK ABOUT DOWN.
THE ECO TOURISM IT WITH A LIVE
MANY HUNTING IS REALLY
ELIMINATING THE WINGS BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT MAKES THE
CONSERVATION SYSTEM FLY AS MY
ANALOGY BUT THE WELL LET ME MAKE
IT CLEAR.
THAT THE LODGES IN TANZANIA.
AND ELSEWHERE OR HALF EMPTY.
OKAY.
AS THERE ARE NOT ENOUGH ECO
TOURISM THE COVER THIS AND ECO
TOURISTS DON'T PAY.
THE FEAST OF THE GOVERNMENT.
ARE THEY ARE LIKE LIKE THE
HUNTING GOES IT'S OF IS THAT THE
CATAPULT CONSERVATION PARADIGM
IN SOUTHERN THESE IN AFRICA IS
BASED UPON SAFARI HONEY TOURISTS
A FOR HONEY.
ITSELF IT WORKS IT'S ALWAYS
POPULATIONS IN A STABLE OR
INCREASING AND THE DEATHLY OR
SECURE.
SERVICES PUT ON ABOUT DON'T CUT
THE WINGS OFF THE BIRDS.
OKAY WE WE ARE JUST SAY THAT BY.
NO ONE BECAUSE MORE CONCLUSION.
ONE NO ONE CARES MORE ABOUT --
BUT THESE ANIMALS HUNTERS THEY
NEED US AS MUCH AS WE NEED THEM
[inaudible]
CAN'T HOA WE CAN'T SHOOT DUCKS
WE CAN HELP THIRTEEN MILLION
ACRES OF A WETLAND HABITAT
WITHOUT BOOKS ONLINE OKAY
EMITTED THANK YOU.
A IS THERE ANY OTHER COMMENT YES
MISS KOREA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS VERY IMPORTANT
PIECE OF LEGISLATION FORWARD I
KNOW IN THE CONVERSATION IS NOT
EASY IT'S VERY CHALLENGING.
BUT AGAIN THIS IS NOT ABOUT THE
INABILITY TO HUNTS.
DUCKS OR GEESE OR DEAR THIS IS
ABOUT ENDANGERED SPECIES AND I'M
I'M SAD TO SAY THAT.
YOU MAY HAVE TO TAKE AN
AMENDMENT BECAUSE THE WHITE
RHINOCEROS NO LONGER EXISTS.
AND IT'S INCLUDED IN AND THE
BILL AND I THINK THAT'S THE A
TRAVESTY TO OUR PLANET.
AND DOES REALLY GRATEFUL THAT
YOU BROUGHT THIS FORWARD IN A
VERY HAPPY.
THANKS MISS CARILLO.
WE GOT TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION
MISTER CHAIRMAN MAY I HER.
WORK.
THEN I HEARD A MOTION FROM A
NEWS RUBIO AND SECONDED BY --
MISS KOREA.
AND MR GLORIA [inaudible]
AND A LOT OF OTHERS MISTER
CHAIRMAN COULD YOU INDULGE ME
FOR TEN SECONDS NO WE WE TOOK
OTHERS IT THERE'S AN EXTREMELY
JIMMY.
I IT SO WE'LL WE'LL KEEP THIS
HERE AT THE DAIS IF THERE ARE
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS --
SEEN NONE APPEAR I JUST HAVE A
FEW COMMENTS I WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE --
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF QUESTIONS
AND ALL AND A LOT A COMMENTARY
ABOUT --
ECONOMIC IMPACTS IN ABOUT THE
CONSERVATION FUNDS I DO WANT --
TO DRAW PEOPLE TO THE EXCELLENT
ANALYSIS WRITTEN BY COMMITTEE
STAFF THAT DOES I'D DOCUMENT
SOME OF THESE ISSUES.
SO WE HAVE ABOUT A FORTY BILLION
DOLLAR IMPACT TO SUB SAHARAN
AFRICA A ANNUALLY --
THIS WAS BASED IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
BY THE WILL TRAVEL AND TOURISM
COUNCIL AND WE HAVE DATA ON THE
THE HUNTING.
IMPACT --
WHICH IS ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS YEAR OF REVENUE
I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE NUMBERS WERE PRETTY CLEAR --
AYE -- I
MYSELF HAVE BEEN SUB SAHARAN
AFRICA TWICE INTO MY SOME ARE
I'VE BEEN TO THE SERENGETI
BEAUTIFUL PLACES I DIDN'T BRING
HOME ANY TROPHIES THANK GOODNESS
I THINK.
THERE MUST BE A SOLIS SENSE OF
ENTITLEMENT THAT WOULD DRIVE
ANYONE TO WANT.
TO KILL AND MURDER AND
ENDANGERED SPECIES AND AND SO
I'M I'M GRATEFUL FOR THE AT THE
SERVICE THAT YOU'RE PROVIDING US
SENATOR TO BE ABLE TO WEIGH IN
ON THIS.
AND A PROTECT THE SPECIES ALSO
WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE
CONSERVATION --
FOR A NATIONAL GEOGRAPHIC STORY
DOCUMENTS DOCUMENTARIES WERE
WERE MENTIONED A A STORY --
REPORT WAS.
WRITTEN ABOUT HOW IT WAS
NOTORIOUSLY HARD TO PIN DOWN.
I'M I'M REALLY JUST LIFTING A
STRAIGHT FROM THE ANALYSIS IT SO
GOOD OUT WHETHER CONSERVATION
FUNDS WERE PROPERLY USED.
AND THE CONCLUSION WAS THAT IT
IS IMPOSSIBLE IN KLEPTOCRACY.
TRACK WHETHER FOR CONSERVATION
FUNDS ACTUALLY CONSERVED THESE
THREATEN ANIMALS.
AND THAT TRUCK TROPHY HUNTING
MAY ACTUALLY MAKE MATTERS WORSE.
SO --
CHAIRMAN GARCIA'S RECOMMENDATION
IS AN AYE I'M GOING TO FOLLOW
HIS EXCELLENT LEADERSHIP AND AND
VOTE AYE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
WATER [inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
RIO [inaudible]
REAL AYE CHOI [inaudible]
A LITTLE. TWO I FRIEDMAN
[inaudible]
GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE HARPER.
HARPER NO KALRA.
KALRA AYE LEVINE AYE AYE LEVINE
AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS NO RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SALAS WOULD
[inaudible]
WOULD I THE OF THE BILL IS OUT.
EIGHT TO FOUR AND NOT MEMBERS WE
HAVE A BILL THAT WE NEED --
TO THAT WE NEED --
TO EXPEDITE OVER --
TO ENVIRONMENTAL.
WE'RE IN RECESS FOR ONE MINUTE
[inaudible]
THIS
WE WILL RECONVENE AND THAT
WE'RE GOING TO ADD ON TO THE
BILLS WILL START AT THE TOP BUT
WITH.
FIRST ITEM S. B. TWO SIXTY NINE
THE FROM SECRETARY [inaudible]
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
CARILLO [inaudible]
LEO I FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
KALRA.
COLOR AYE LEVINE AYE I BELIEVE
HIGH RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SALAS.
NO AND I REDUCES.
OKAY A ITEM THREE SB NINE
NINETEEN DOT [inaudible] NINE
EDUARDO GARCIA I HI GALLAGHER
[inaudible]
CARILLO [inaudible]
CARILLO I EVEN [inaudible]
KALRA.
RUBIO.
REVIEW I I DON'T FIVE S. B.. TEN
FIFTEEN TEN FIFTEEN EDUARDO
GARCIA I I GALLAGHER
[inaudible]
CARILLO [inaudible]
CARILLO I KALRA.
KALRA AYE LEVINE AYE LEVINE AYE
SALAS.
OKAY ITEM SIX SP.
TEN SEVENTEEN EDUARDO GARCIA AYE
GARCIA AYE BIGELOW [inaudible]
CARILLO.
CAREER AYE.
CHIU I'VE TO I FRIEDMAN.
KALRA AYE KALRA AYE LEVINE AYE
LIVING HIGH.
RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE WOULD.
WOULD I OKAY.
I AM NINE S. B..
TWELVE SIXTY THREE EDUARDO
GARCIA AYE GARCIA AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW HIGH CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE CHIU OUR CHIU AYE
FRIEDMAN.
KALRA KILEY KALRA AYE LEVINE.
LEVINE AYE RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE
WOULD.
WOULD I BECAUSE THEY'RE OKAY
ITEM TEN SP.
THIRTEEN OH ONE EDUARDO GARCIA
AYE GARCIA AYE GALLAGHER
[inaudible]
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE CARILLO.
MARIA HI CHIU.
CHIU AYE FRIEDMAN.
GLORIA ON YEAH AYE KALRA.
WE'RE I MATHIS NO MATHIS NO.
RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE.
WOULD [inaudible]
WOULD I OKAY.
S. B. THIRTEEN OH NINE THAT'S
ITEM [inaudible]
ELEVEN GALLAGHER [inaudible]
WHERE [inaudible]
CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE FRIEDMAN
[inaudible]
KALRA.
COLOR AYE LEVINE.
LEVINE AYE RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE
SALAS SALAS AYE.
THE ITEM FOURTEEN S. B..
THIRTEEN SIXTEEN EDUARDO GARCIA
AYE GARCIA AYE [inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
BIGELOW NOW [inaudible]
CARILLO [inaudible]
CARILLO I CHIU ARE CHIU AYE
[inaudible]
FRIEDMAN.
KALRA I'VE COLOR I RUBIO NOT.
ONE RUBIO NOT VOTING SLIPS.
WOOD I SALAS NO [inaudible]
SEVEN OKAY.
ITEM.
FIFTY S. B. [inaudible]
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN CHOI
[inaudible]
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
SALAS [inaudible]
CAN.
AND DOES THAT CONSENT CALENDAR.
EDUARDO GARCIA I I GALLAGHER
[inaudible]
CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE FRIEDMAN.
KALRA I KALRA AYE LEVINE.
LEVINE AYE RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE
SALAS.
SALAS AYE. THIRTEEN SECONDS AND
KELLNER [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
ABOUT HOW SO WHAT WILL LEAVE DO
ROLL OPEN FOR FIVE MINUTES. FOR
OTHER MEMBERS TO ADD ON FIVE
MINUTES
OKAY THERE OUGHT TO PASS
AND DIED THIS MEETING IS
ADJOURNED